[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
because
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the finals of the second ever American
Cup are underway in St Louis after a
grueling double elimination event
featuring the best in the country each
bracket is down to two a topsy-turvy
game in the open Final Had Each
Challenger both secure and lose a clear
lead that eventually fizzled into a draw
Irena crash on the other hand was in
Championship form handling a seemingly
overmatched Alice Lee round two is about
to commence will we finally Crown our
2023 American Cup Champions Day nine of
Championship chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 9 of the
2023 American Cup held at the Saint
Louis chess club we are entering the
final stage of this event and the
players we'll have to find the last
ounces of creativity and energy and give
us everything over the chess board let's
go to the studio and start the action
with Yasser and Joe
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America and this is
day 9 of the 2023 American Cup the
championship rounds begin live from the
St Louis chess club
hello and welcome from the Saint Louis
chess club I'm Ivanka houska and it's
been a great pleasure to be calling all
the actions and day two of the Grand
Final alongside Grand Master yasa
sarawan Ivanka as always a great
pleasure to be with you and Christian in
studio it's been great fun hasn't it
it's been wonderful it really is hello
everyone and Welcome to our coverage of
these Grand finals well yesterday Arena
was all business she came playing her
patented brand of strategic chess which
has just given Alice Lee that's an arena
took the whole point but it was a wild
Affair and the other Grand finals as
Hikaru went all out
created a position that just confounded
ourselves and then smack at the very end
ended in the shocking stalemate and a
draw was secured it was great stuff and
the Grand Final promises more Jovi do
the honors tell us about the brackets
yes definitely let's delve into the
situation so far so here was the
Champions bracket and Arena just raced
to the top she's still on two lives and
who did she knock down along the way she
knocked down Alice Lee into the
elimination bracket that 13 year old
Alice Lee while she defeated Naji
paikitsa and she bounced back up to make
her way into the Grand Final
and in the up and here sorry and here
she is this is the standing in the
head-to-head in the current match arena
is leading which leaves Alice Lee in a
must-win situation exactly and in the
Champions uh bracket in the open in the
open section you know he headlined the
event and he raced again to the top also
netting a ten thousand dollar bonus
along the way but uh who did he defeat
and knock down into the elimination
bracket none other than Wesley so and
where's he so playing in the elimination
bracket well he had to defeat Levon
aronian and do that he did to get a
place into the Grand Final and in the
championship match here is the first
round scores one draw and the format for
today's play yes it you know we have
seen a very special very unique
tournaments two eight player double
elimination and in the Champions bracket
the classical gay root classical time
control of 90 minutes plus 30 second
increments in the elimination bracket
that's passed that's done but it was I
played at rapid 25 minutes plus 10
second increments and the schedule for
today
and the schedule well it's going to be
very very exciting because the players
will start off with one classical game
now if the match is tied we're going to
see playoffs and the match will be
decided now this is the way it gets very
spicy because if Alice Lee and Wesley so
win their matches then we're going to
see some more chess because Hikari and
Hikaru and Arena are both on their
second lives so they're entitled to a
rematch absolutely but to dip drill down
even further on the possibilities
Christian good to see you in studio my
friend good to see you guys and what an
amazing start to this Grand finals we
had yesterday that game between Hikaru
Nakamura with the white pieces and
Wesley so was everything we asked for
Hikaru well it started off as a slow
paced English but I have to say Hikaru
did get some Advantage after that it was
equal then Hikaru was la lost but
unfortunately for Wesley he did not find
the right solution in that critical
situation all the way towards the end of
the game and that big matchup between
Irena with the white pieces who got
surprised by Alice Lee early on she did
not know that move E4 but I have to say
I was impressed by the way she handled
it and took the full point home let's
take a look at where we stand right now
in this two incredible matches we're
going to start with the open section the
grand finals in the open section well if
Hikaru wins the classical match today
then he will take the title home if the
match ends in a draw then these two
players are going to be playing a
playoffs we're going to start at a time
format of 10 plus 3 all the way to the
Armageddon if we need so and if Wesley
wants to win this one and take it to the
to tomorrow's final match day well he
has to win either In classical either in
the rapid playoffs if the match in the
classical game ends in a draw and let's
take a look at what's happening in the
ladies section well I have to say Alice
Lee so far in so many years that she's
been facing Irina Crush has not been
able to defeat her right now she needs
to defeat her three times but if Irina
makes a draw today or even wins the
classical match then the match is over
Irina takes the title home Alice Lee
needs to win in the classical match then
she needs to defeat Irina in the
playoffs as well and that will take
these two players into tomorrow's game
day and in that one Alice Lee needs to
win as well the playoffs I have to say
this is a very difficult task for the
young 13 years of age but we've seen her
spectacular opening preparation guys we
have some amazing chess coming your way
yes we do and the players have all been
fighting very very hard Joby but what
have they been fighting for for the love
[Music]
correct and in the open second section
the first part Place Nets 50 000 and
second place thirty five thousand
dollars but Hikaru has already won
himself ten thousand dollars just
because he won the Champions bracket and
in the women's section and in the
women's section look at this what a
prize 25
000 for the winner second place and
that's eighteen thousand dollars and
Arena has actually already gotten five
thousand dollars for winning the
Champions bracket and in case we do
Crown two Champions today tomorrow we
will feature a blitz tournament and
we'll be giving a live coverage of that
event and tell us more about the event
yeah it's a nine round Swiss no draw
offers biggest draw offers are not
acceptable in St Louis right very fast
time control of three minutes plus two
and this is my favorite point it
includes players from local universities
read very strong players and eliminated
American Cup participants right like
Olympic uh like uh participants of
Olympiad I mean to say is there you see
the players getting wanted uh no
electronics allowed of course
I noticed that Hikaru came in very early
today he's been at the board for more
than five minutes as he's really
focusing it down this is unusual right
he's really basking in the moment right
now he really enjoys this he knows that
he could potentially take the full title
today and yeah he's ready ready to go
now he supplies he surprised Lanier by
playing the open Sicilian a Kalashnikov
that he had prepared incredibly well uh
do you uh I can't say I expect that
myself either but E4 E5 yes that's my
guess e45 I really don't see him taking
Wesley
In the Sicilian he did take Wesleyan the
silion but in the rapid playoffs of
their first encounter I don't know not
in the classroom I don't think he'll try
it no no no no no no
his combativeness in this event has been
without Pierre he's he's he's like
yesterday he could have taken a draw in
multiple moments he kept refusing and he
was playing for the win throughout but
yeah by the way
um Wesley doesn't have to start with E4
right
that is true he hasn't started with D4
so far in the classical encounters I I
cannot remember any of his matches that
started and you were right it begins
with D4 exactly D4
Knight F6
and
I'm thinking about the C4
Indians with Queen C2 drawing on his I
have a suspicion of Catalan might be uh
up Wesley sleeve today C4 E6 G3
I don't think so
cc4 and C4 going to the names though
well I'm on schedule if you're Hikaru
and you're significantly better at the
faster time controls on your opponents
oh would you go into a nimso or would
you
let's see if A3 is going yes yes
today but A3
now we're going to see take take and
most likely now Wesley did get a nice
advantage against Fabi in this line but
we think that Fabi just actually had a
finger slip yes that line is uh harmless
and even with that finger slip Wesley's
position wasn't that dominant he got a
slight Advantage but I have to say I
looked at it with uh better engines and
it wasn't it wasn't easy at all
okay and let's uh jump over to the
ladies as once again Alice Lee uh facing
an opponent sadly to say she's never
defeated before she's going to have to
defeat her a number of times she's got
to win the classical then win today's
playoff
and then when
tomorrow's playoff to deny Arena as
second Crown three times yes she needs
to win on The Mad on demand three times
against Irina and she never beat her in
classical but neither in Rapid or Blitz
if I'm not mistaken
apologies I don't think is there a link
to it Alice is so young
right I mean it's really just a question
of when this is going to happen Okay so
we have seen is Bogo Indian and your
repertoire it has been in mind for quite
a number only on the white side and I
reckon Queen E7 is the main move here
there has been played A5 as well as C5
Queen E7 this is a line that actually
was very heavily favored by wolf
Anderson he would be very happy to play
D7 D5 and go into a Queen's Gambit style
position where the darks were Bishops
were traded quite early uh normally
speaking you you've helped
White's development through these Early
Trades because after all the queen which
was on its original squares now on D2
it's a very solid uh variation for Edina
and the bearing in mind that arena is
just one draw away from finishing the
title again right I think this is very
understandable but she has to be careful
because in this type of position as
you've highlighted you know white does
have a lead in development and you know
you can drift into passivity and this
negative kind of predisposition means
that you can take even you can
what I'm trying to say is that you start
making inferior decisions and before you
know it White's Advantage isn't it's
growing it's grown yeah coach Christian
what do you advise your players who are
playing black and all they need is a
draw for the Grand Master Norm or for
the tournament uh Victory uh how do you
advise them to play well first of all I
just tell them that it's a great
position to be in the first step of the
whole process has already been achieved
to put yourself in that position right
and this is I can guarantee you what
arena is feeling right now she already
feels a sense of accomplishment she got
all the way up to this point now all she
needs to do is close the show and I
really like what she's doing first of
all in this particular case because
she's taking a bit of a sideline
approach with this bishop to D4 and
after that immediately capturing on a D2
We don't see that very often we see
either 33 to E7 or the defense of the
bishop on B4 with either A5 C5 Queen to
E7 all of those are main lines this
bishop takes D2 is considered to give a
slight Edge to a white but what she's
doing she's taking her very well
prepared opponent out of the theory very
early on and we've seen what happened
with Alice Lee yesterday when she was
out of the theory after that move Bishop
to B5 which was an inferior move it was
giving in fact Alice with a black piece
is an advantage but she didn't know how
to handle it I think this is one of her
biggest weakness because of her age
right she's not experienced she loves to
be in her comfort zone and to know
exactly what she's doing I think this is
what arena is targeting right now and I
have to say I'm very impressed with her
gameplay strategy for today's game do we
know offhand if Alice Lee is actually
faced uh the BOGO Indian before does she
have much experience on the white side
I'm sure she has I'm sure she has but
perhaps once again not this bishop takes
D2 it's it's a pretty rare occurrence
again Bishop takes D2 is considered to
give white a very slight and pleasant
Advantage Bishop to E7 A5 C5 those are
the main moves
I have to say that I was I tend to kind
of handle this position either by going
G3 but a nice way that I found is just
to develop the knights go E3 right and
you see three easily exactly and put
pressure on the c-line yep and again Ask
black how are you going to develop the
light Square Bishop exactly in these
positions uh you the tendency is to go
with the fee and Shadow with either D5
takes C4 first but you know the only way
that light Square Bishop which is hemmed
in by the E6 Pawn you know you've got a
future right so I I think it's a good
line actually something said for G3 I do
like G3 a lot though yeah also
all right
and what do we think of the game between
Hikaru and Western
well it's the queen C2 and C tasty well
that's actually I find that move help to
be helpful for black just because after
E6 takes D5 then it's very clear that
the bishop on C8 has a way of getting
into the game I think Alice was better
advised to maintain the tension I think
she should have maintained attention and
once again we see uh her lack of
experience perhaps in this type of
situations play out now also when the
material gets limited and you truly need
to win to continue the mesh to continue
the mesh not to be eliminated then you
start doubting yourself and your
decisions right the more and more pieces
are being eliminated from the board the
more doubts start to creep in and this
is perhaps what arena is striving to
achieve with her opening choice right so
I have to say I'm not a big fan of
relinquishing the tension in the center
as you've both mentioned C5 e takes D5
the bishop is coming out sorry and I was
going to say the um my Golden Rule yeah
and this type of it really is one that I
I trust implicitly and I always do is I
only capture on D5 once black has played
something committal on the queen side B6
then I'm taking because light Square
Bishop has to stay on guard on that side
of the board this way be so now I'm
taking exactly now uh the bishop is more
or less obliged that you've played these
B6 to fee and Shadow itself whereas that
is a very good strategical point whereas
in the game position after C takes D5 e
takes D5 let's say I go Knight C3
there's no way I want to play B6 I want
to bring my Bishop out gleefully to the
F5 Square castle and maybe on a good day
you trade more pieces with them E4 just
making my life that much easier and in
the uh open uh well the players haven't
been moving that quickly Christian uh
all I've got is the position after oh no
let's sing out their moves no seriously
yes oh
where did it go
there it is yeah
yeah there it is oh excuse me you're
right many moves have been played and
we're on a different track after
it's very well known track for Hikaru if
you look at the database right now the
top level player playing this position
and he has three and more games ishikaru
Nakamura as black yes black yes versus
Hikaru Jeffrey Sean versus sikaru in 20
uh 21 and 2020 so Benjamin Bach against
Hikaru a couple of times
Hikaru is very much aware of what he's
doing nevertheless we know that most
likely Wesley knows that as well and has
prepared a bit of a wrinkle to try to
shake Hikaru off in this one okay so
Hikaru has been the Trailblazer in this
line yes he loves his life Bishop G
Bishop G4 pinning the Knight looks
pretty
straightforward now we've got ideas of
E5 E4 and Wesley played Bishop E2
and well they're still in theory I see
there's a lot of games being listed on
my database after this move and uh
what's the percentages uh
and I would say a lot is a bit of an
overstatement there's only seven games
with 97 okay uh which is the main line
and in fact the only move that has been
played in this position Knight David
seven after Bishop to E2 Knight to D7
yes you need to get right you have a
clear plan in the position and that is
to play the move C6 at some point how do
you do that how do you accomplish that
most likely after Knight to D7 after
that route to C8 and then go C6 you have
to attack and Target The Pawn on D5
start with 97 get your pieces out it
makes the most sense and by the way you
just played Knight to ba so you have to
go to D7 with the Knight it makes uh
perfect sense I'm not 100 sure why
Hikaru is still thinking in this
position he's had this position on his
board plenty of times you should follow
it up with 97 Hey Wesley show me what
you got show me what you prepared I know
you know that I've played this position
just show me where the novelty lies
this is where you kind of have to also
delve into the opponent's Minds because
yes you know know if I were in this
situation I would say yes I know that I
played this many times before right but
what you got up the sleeve and you know
your hikaru's opponent is none other
than Wesley so who's incredibly well
prepared so you know it's something
exactly you you feel that okay this
could be unpleasant so I always I can
understand hikaru's hesitation is what
I'm trying to say I can understand why
he's thinking isn't now all the time to
diverge from my theory or and freestyle
something so that Wesley is also on his
own or do I just go
right into the Trap well he should go
right into the track shall we take a
look at the Trap so there's no traffic
there's two moves that I I consider
castles I I that's like the third move
for me I would like to uh clarify what's
going on on the king side h2h3 asking
the bishop are you going to capture and
the reason why I would play H3 is
because of the following if I play the
move Queen takes C7 which nobody has
done by the way people are not capturing
this Pawn uh Rook C8 now attacks my
queen and the Rook is going to land on
C2 and I'm not a happy camper but if I
had included
the move H3 and the bishop had dropped
back well now
you know I'm happy to take this Bond
because I do so with a gain of tempo
therefore I'm thinking that it will
probably
precipitate Bishop takes F3 Bishop now
Christian was mentioning Rook C8 and
that was why I was attracted to the move
H3 because but I owe E4 in this position
yes he's already better yeah you play E4
attacking my queen now let's say I drop
back Queen takes B takes C3 it's a
bishop versus night position but the
Knight is going to have a very nice
Outpost either on E5 or C5 I think it's
the C5 output precisely yeah C5 I get
the pawn to B6 to defend that like
create a beautiful Outpost
it's just a really really nice position
for
um for black yes which makes me think
about the movie E4 first of all I
stopped black from playing E4
I prepared the move H3 and I'm still
keeping the option of Queen takes C2
Queen takes C7 but interesting enough uh
Hikaru has actually faced E4 yeah and
how did it go how did it go so let's
have a have a look at that that was the
game between himself and Jeffrey Sean he
played Queen 26 Castle Knight to F6 he
didn't seem to have any big problems in
that game uh it seems like once again in
fact black has not had a lot of problems
in this position he hasn't lost a single
game out of those seven I think six of
them finished in a draw one of them
black has managed to be victorious so
this is one thing that Elite level
players by the way if I would be playing
and analyzing this position as white I
would probably never go for this line
just because I see the percentages I
always look at the percentages if I see
black doing well in general I feel like
they have a comfortable position and I'm
not going to enter those type of
variations I'm looking for variations in
which white scores better in which white
manages to put some practical pressure
on their opponent this is why I'm a bit
befuddled by uh Wesley's choice this
idea of Bishop to E2 allowing 97
entering the den entering the variation
that Hikaru is an expert well let me be
the agent provocateur that I am queen
takes C7 let's imagine that Wesley has
the super computer from Norway as
his uh bedside companion and he goes
Queen takes C7 go ahead and do your
worst tell me no castles is uh what he
has done by the way but uh just out of
curiosity how would the line of God
would you use this
Rook ac-8 well there goes Pawn number
two E4
E5 E4 I gotta move the Knight I take
only two most likely take on E2 here I
have to pause because I can see that the
Knight is going to go to C5 and D3 if I
take with the Knight but if I take with
the King
eight almost you're really playing with
fire here is the idea that looks really
strong right because you're gonna go
Queen takes night you have pointers and
then you do have Rook D2 but I feel like
after let's calculate it no but hang on
a second there's Knight E2 at the end of
it sorry I'm jumping way ahead Rick
takes work
but I'm with you on this one maybe two
and then after Rook B8
I'll probably figure out some clever way
of uh of Defending against Rook to B2 uh
none of that ought to happen because
uh Wesley did play castles
and after castles
here comes the novelty here comes the
novelty castles Rook
a8c8
and that's why I'm saying hello Hikaru
is such a well prepared I love what
you're saying what you said about uh
Queen D6 and Knight F6 something that
Hikaru played previously against Jeffrey
Zhang that looks really solid to my eyes
Rook C8 immediately responded with Queen
to be Queen to B4 and that's a nice
that now that's a that's a serious Pawn
that that pawn is a upon I I feel I can
clip and now we're going to have to
enter some sort of uh more or less
semi-forced line I'm going to have to
take on F3
you take on a three otherwise you lose
the pawn right right
before you go E4 but E4 has some
strategical drawbacks you don't want to
uh get so extended overextended on that
side Knight to D4 it does seem like
white is getting the advantage here and
this Pawn feels uh more of a liability
than a strength I can see uh lines for
white that would go Knight C3 and Rook
D4 immediately targeting the pawn which
is why you didn't want to play E4 you
wanted to take take but then just Queen
B6 Queen to B6 yeah it has to be played
well this is the
a moment ago this was the um I'm not
sure this is the moment I was playing
for when I was thinking about Bishop G4
but uh
definitely something of this of this
type
what if I take the queen
trade
and let's get off that diagonal I guess
so
pardon me yeah I was wondering whether
you could go B5 no yeah it looks a bit
weird but my idea is I'm I'm a little
annoyed by this uh double hit okay yeah
I don't have the time for that for the
moment for the moment
um so you have to present that right
with E4 but
I don't know it seems like black is
getting his
his good moves in just checking in on
their live ratings that this includes
their game from yesterday
yes
nice not a lot has changed because
they're so evenly matched in their world
ranking right now that with the draw
maybe it's a change of 0.2 ratings
I see uh one of the things that
surprised me is that uh Hikaru came in
here yesterday after the after his game
was very happy about the game and the
the great fight that took place and he
said well I accomplished what I wanted
to do when I came into the American dub
I'm not going to lose any rating points
regardless of today's result and I
thought oh well well that's kind of a
strange attitude but at the same time
he's actually quite Rusty he has his
blade classical chess since the
candidates which I think was in May of
last year it was nine months ago yeah
yeah so he was a little worried that
maybe his form wasn't going to be great
it turned out to be outstanding but it
also is super important you know once
turn you know do you have to preserve
your rating because you want to stay
exactly because then you get those
invitations to the events including
events like this one exactly
uh Rook ACA Queen B4 Bishop F3 Bishop F3
and how is the uh how are the engines
evaluating this specific position
they're giving white a slight Advantage
but that usually dissipates if you go
along with the variation so if you go
deeper into the variation that it
usually dissipates into one Queen B6 on
the board by the way yes best move in
the position right by far if you don't
play Queen B6 then you're in some sort
of danger so for example if you go
something like B6 it looks like a normal
move right the problem is you're giving
me so many light squares right and this
is where I have uh Superior pieces to
tackle that Bishop to G4 that's going to
get
um control of this h3c8 diagonal Rook to
d8 and now I have ideas of Queen to A4
Queen to C4 once again I'm hinting at
the fact that you have huge weaknesses
over the light squares Queen to C4
followed by Queen to C6 or by the way
how do you defend the pawn on C7 that's
a big question in the position Queen to
A4 how do you defend the pawn on A7
that's an idea as well and after Knight
takes C5 I am going to take that pawn on
A7 and B upon up you have to find some
sort of compensation but it's definitely
not easy so still Hikaru is within his
preparation both players are within
their preparation because they're just
blitzing out their moves Queen to B6 now
is the big question what are you going
to do as white are you going to preserve
the Queens on the board with Queen to C3
or are you going to go straight into the
end game with Queen takes B6 and this is
the first time we see Wesley thinking
for more than a couple of seconds for
his wave
yeah okay I just took uh maybe a
question for the ending for the engines
pardon me yes because there's something
about this position that I do find a
little bit attractive for white let's
imagine I play the move E3 E4 which is
somehow a confounding move because after
all I'm putting my central pawns on
light squares I'm doing that with a very
specific purpose in mind I do see this
bishop coming back to the square E2 and
I do see myself supporting the move B5
very good idea and that's why I'm going
to stop you from getting that Bishop to
E2 I'm going to exchange on B4 yep and
then I'm going to immediately attack the
pawn on e4 with Knight F6 right but can
you do my plan now which is basically I
love this move B5 and the plan is to
kind of go Rook A1
have laser eyes on the A7 board not a
challenge I go C6 immediately
immediately once again tackle that that
B5 Pawn is dangerous I don't want to see
it hanging around there for a very long
time
it's something that you would look at at
least yes is it the pawn a strength or a
liability that's a problem
let's try Rook cd8 because I want to
play rookie six as well Rook to D3 okay
let's go Rook to E6 now E6 The Rook over
let's say Knight to E8 I'm trying the
most Force moves in the position yes I
understand you just to see if this is
the question my back to F6 right this is
a question of uh whether it's a strength
or a weakness let's say did you want
Rook A1 I was thinking okay one but
unfortunately there's Rook tape Rook
takes the seven I think that's
simplified enough that's very very
simplified indeed okay so this is where
you've played Knight F6 I understand
your move uh perfectly well B5 let's
imagine I go Rook A1 okay let's go I I
force you and now I play Rook C1 so the
idea here something similar I am in the
near future looking to play B5 but maybe
again releasing the bishop
by bringing my king to the center a
little bit better for white some
pressure
not in this instance no I don't think so
Rook to A1
A6 was not the most precise perhaps I
can start with C6 but even A6 Rook to C1
it doesn't seem like it's much 0.10
right now just Rook to d8 Rook to D6 and
only them
um
or perhaps even focusing on this newly
created weakness for the moment the pawn
on B4 Rook to D6 Rook to B6 it just
simply doesn't seem like it's enough I
understand you do have the bishop
against the Knight with uh the Rooks we
know the cooperation between the bishop
and the Rooks is touted as being
superior to the cooperation between the
Rooks and the Knight but it's just
limited material right now you don't
have any Targets I do have a Target yes
I do I see it G3 is the kind of idea G3
okay okay
Bishop H3 uh the C7 is my I see what
you're doing yes that's that's a very
good point G3 I'm going to stop you
whenever you go Bishop to G2
I think I'm going to go maybe G5 okay
okay okay
F3 let's go F3 can I continue with H5 or
is that too much
perhaps this is too much Rook to B6 back
to D6 nice nice okay we're in for a
penny in for a pound Bishop H3 let's
have some fun
let's have some fun
when we get these imbalances with the
Rooks and the Bishops and G5 I take on
e4 G5
G5 let's move the Rook
you take this one I take this one
you still have a lot of weaknesses this
one liability or a weak or a strength
the pawn on B4 like ability
Bishop C8 okay well I'll take this one
and Rook F1 no not D6 nah D6 yeah D6 is
hang on D6 96 yeah also Rook D1 no Rook
D1 sorry I I I tricked The Grandmaster
your Jedi Mind Tricks are too strong for
me Joe be careful he's got ideas that's
that's at least a draw right right that
is true so you have to defend with
Bishop G4 I don't think you yeah you
have enough okay well we'll keep an eye
on this one and uh we'll jump to the
cargo game for just a moment oh pardon
me the ladies game what I why did I say
Carlos game as uh we'll catch up with
them at least you didn't say Hikaru and
Nakamura I did yes
who would win and between mikaru and
Nakamura she did Play Bishop F5 uh Arena
again I mean she is really experienced
in these uh Queens Gambit decline
positions uh and she knows that
basically there's only one
um play here for uh White and that's the
um minority attack thank you for B5 I
was going to say the majority attack yes
the minority attack with Queen beef with
B4 B5 for that for that reason
um A5 is not completely terrible A5 is
very good I've had this played against
me well I've been like on the white side
of this type of position against the
Muzzy Chick Sisters and uh humpy Canary
and both of them played A5 and they
followed it up with okay this Pawn
stretch I just want to highlight C6 yep
and then the whole point was to go A4
with four white for black and B5
and then even B5 and even B5 and so that
way you can wedge a knight into C4 and
once I learned it from them I've
actually done it myself as well on the
black side yeah yeah yes sometimes you
just gotta learn from the best right
exactly yeah but A5 is one of those
moves that if it does stop uh why or at
least slow white down for example C7 C6
if you are afraid of this then you have
to play like super super slowly B3 A3
you know in order to get your your pawn
and it's still not that easy to get in
the move uh before and again if you're
not playing for B4 E4 is not going to
bring you much success either and you're
certainly not going G4 G5 anytime in the
near future so where is the break for
white again it's got to be the queen
side so for the moment I'm gonna say
once again that Arena not not that
yesterday was a success it became a
success but her openings in this
tournament have been
spot on spot on but this is what you
said at the beginning of the broadcast
yes sir you did mention that I got her
brand of this type of strategical play
right yes into this infused into this
matches specifically against Alice Lee
Alice Lee did not get what she usually
wants which is wild positions better out
of the opening she's not getting that in
this game as well no that's why I'm
really really appreciative and I
recommend this type of strategy that
Irina took today with this bishop to B4
and let's say an inferior move Bishop
takes D2 but still given the fact that
you only need a drawing the game to win
the title the whole title the match is
over you get the title simplify the
position this is what she's going for
and she's putting the pressure on her
opponent with this particular strategy
but this move C7 C6 I I find to be a
little bit questionable I will play E4
you will I will uh why not and you're
welcome to play Queen E7 all right Rook
b194 ideas if the if you find them
attractive but that's another uh thing
and this kind of meshes with the idea
that Jovi was mentioning you played
before you weakened the C4 square
there's no more upon coming back to B3
right I do I did now I can go A6 I can
stop you for the moment okay and if you
go A4 I would be tempted to go Knight E
for now Knight to E4 is an idea Knight
to E4 Knight to D6 is a definitely an
idea castle and now I guess 97. oh
Knight D7 let's let's develop the pieces
first let's just see seven uh Knight B6
is coming yeah I understand
um and uh I will as they say cut you off
at the past but now where's the minority
attack well a a new attack is coming I'm
going to put my knight
on the C5 Square I'm going to invite you
to capture and then I will have a
backward Pawn that I will gnaw on there
was a marvelous game between Anatoly
karpath and wolf Anderson over Anderson
was on the black side uh Talia put a
knight on C5 forced the trade and ground
um off down in an incredible uh rook and
pawn end game where the white king went
first to A1 back to G1 it was a great
torture of a very famous grand master
nobody believes you yes
nobody believes you but you you don't
think that this is something for white
actually no no I think it's very close
to equality really okay
um all I can say is take a look at that
game in my defense and uh you'll be
surprised that it wasn't let's try it
out I was going to say this is actually
better for black please
how do you say it go go ahead how do I
say well I saw I saw the kind of like a
nice cram knit game in this kind of
structure yeah 96 or midnight F6 and
night yeah the other night sure and then
you know he put his Knight on E4 and
this what he did was after night comes
to C5 he goes Rook a E8 and you know
the slice G5
uh show me the spice of life okay so
I've got the Knight on C5 which I think
is you know uh nice nicely wedged like
like let's put it that way I'm not gonna
deny it okay and I will play for the
moves F3 and E4 in the near future and
so he was doing things like ff5 okay
well now who's King is uh more exposed
and why let's see
um also by the way I'm not really sure
like who benefits I wouldn't even be
tempted to go Knight takes night just
because yep just because you know I'm
thinking ahead and thinking
exactly here or here this night is
rather tethered I would say to uh the C
C5 square but I do want to play in time
slowly slowly maybe I'll double Rooks on
the E file but Queen D3 F3 E4 in other
words I know I break exactly here you've
got a good position yeah I'm not I'm not
arguing that that the advantage is
somewhat severe or so on but you and I
will both agree that white has to play
for F3
what is black playing for black is
playing for Allah kramnik
controlling E4 and then when it's under
control F5 and because you have the
extra space you can go recap six G5 just
not not necessarily to attack the white
king but just to grab the space all
right the one question I have for you
yesterday yep what if I give you
everything you want keep going no no
keep the position as it was with the
Knight on C5
like you can leave the F5 on the board
you don't have to I'll take I'll take on
D2 okay okay and we'll recapture I'm
trying to give you everything you want
94 Knight E4 yes yeah I'll take on C5 as
well oh my God yeah okay F5 F5 and
exactly here this is the game or this is
the position I want to say that white
one in the game
you will have to give me something in
return okay give me something in return
give me the opportunity to set my pieces
up on the seventh rank to defend that
pawn on B7 okay and that's and that's
exactly what off did too is he doubled
Rooks on the seventh that's what I want
yeah so if I recall we're gonna play F3
let's play yes uh let's play this let's
put the queen backwards for just a
moment yes uh let me repeat that one and
something like this yeah okay so
Talia brought his King all the way to
the queen side what and then played for
H3 G4 okay
then he brought his King all the way
back to the king side God has pawns to
G4 got his Rook to F4 and finally like
50 moves in made his break E3 E4 okay
okay yeah all right it was like no I'll
give it to you it was it was one of
those masterful displays where you say
to yourself nobody in the world could do
this to off Anderson like Olf had just
one weakness which he defended like a
tiger
and he was outplayed
I would have to study remarkably I just
like a great game it was it it truly was
and uh I think it was pointed chaletio
during the grand
um the uh the GMA yeah Grand Prix and it
was like really funny because I had
beaten off
and for Gary it was very important that
oath not lose another game so Gary
Kasparov had walked up to off and said
oh if you're not going to lose any more
games after this stupid loss you just
had against Yasser and he said oh no no
no no no no way karpov beat him and they
tied for first
so Gary
and said you broke your word
mom said something along the lines of my
bad
but yeah it was it was really that kind
of an amazing amazing game both is an
amazing player I have to say studying
his game absolutely one of the funniest
games I actually learned about in this
recent years was uh his game against
International Master Mike Bassman where
Mike Bassman literally just went King
King h8 King G8 King h8
right come at him which is really
unusual or you know because Alf is
normally the one who like sees his
defensive right and then gets you on the
counter-attack and here was basman just
going back and forth
[Laughter]
here but
the fact that in the game between Wesley
and Hikaru
um
that Wesley made this decision to trade
Queens
rather tells me a story that this was
prep
there's something about this position
that Wesley had found attractive Queen
takes B3 of course we all know the
Golden Rule capture towards the center
right so in this case A7 takes B6 plays
itself versus C7 takes B6 when you will
just grant white or pass Bond A7 takes
B6 Bishop to G5
and Rook E8
okay so rook cd8 and we're anticipating
Rook to uh
no it's special very quickly I I have a
feeling Wesley just wants to make a
drawing
I'm thinking he's taking inspiration
from the legend himself of Anderson
brick C8
uh E3 yeah rookie tic-tac-toe
E3 E4 to defend the pawn firstly and
then he wants to play Rook C1 double
Rooks yeah F3 and a good day King get
the king and then do the wonderful King
Waltz where the King goes up the board
to on the queen side the king Waltz I
like that they came walk no although the
king runs away as quickly as he can and
then you know it's because it's like
fleeing from danger but you know in this
type of ending the Majesty is just like
walls is his way up exactly up the board
uh I'll ask you a simple question is
this much have you seen Hikaru ever lose
this type of positions no
don't bother don't bother me with facts
we're talking about real feelings over
here you know it's the waltz of the king
uh he's trying to get is he hinting at
B5 or C6
okay well that was it seems like he
wants to move one of the pawns on the
Queens okay so imagining C6 for just a
moment isn't this something that was
this now I feel like something yes of
course you cannot take on CC you have
take on D1 first of course of course
sorry isn't this something that uh
Wesley would rather Embrace I mean after
all he's the one with the active rook
and don't even think about playing
rookie six because this is a upon ending
that you may not want to suffer
definitely not yes no so after Rook D6 I
will Define passively with Rook d8 with
Rook to C8 sorry yes and if
free to Rome
this is not
like this by the way right this is
something that I really would like so
let's say We're Not Gonna See C6 you you
mentioned B5
I mean what about just because he was he
was pointing towards moving one of the
pawns whenever he was uh yeah he's kind
of channeling me that I really wanted to
activate that Rook A8 I like that move a
lot also the other reason why I like the
move is it kind of uh talking about King
waltzes there's one weakness in the
position upon on C7 so if you keep it
nicely protected do you get it there in
time so
okay so yeah I guess we gotta go here
right King f8 King f8 it sure looks like
we're we're
arriving well in time
yeah let's remind everybody of the what
is uh for today yeah and you can just
see if Hikaru does win today's classical
game
he wins the playoff he is the champion
and if Wesley is the one who wins the
match
well he will force a playoff on Sunday
in which the two the two players will
play the 25 minute plus time in 10
seconds and then tomorrow if not by
today we will have uh crowned our ground
a chess uh finals Champion same same is
true for Alice Lee Alice Lee needs a win
yeah then she got to win today's playoff
right and then she will have to win
again tomorrow's playoff to deny Arena
and there you can see Irina crush is one
classical game Draw away from being
championed so honestly will need to win
first the classical game then a game in
the playoff
right or two games let's say and then
she has to also win the playoff tomorrow
right
right she doesn't do that it Reno is
Champion it's that simple by the way
um for me a little bit sad that we
didn't see that move b2b4 by Alice I
think that was her
one chance if you will I thought C7 C6
may have been just a little bit
inaccurate allowing white some edge with
the move before when Alice played the
move castles well Arena didn't have to
be asked twice I'm going to stop you
from your minority attack I'm going to
play in a move A5 and then I'm going to
do everything I can to prevent E4 as
well and that's going to be like rookie
8 Queen E7 Knight D7 that's interesting
I'm learning something new every day
because I've never been bothered with E4
yeah now I know actually you can take
the time out to do that yeah well for me
a strategical play is about weighing the
pieces like which piece so I I literally
go like this these nights are equal they
offset one another this night is
superior at the moment to this night why
because the knights on B8 doesn't
control any squares so I strategically
do that and then when I broken that down
I said well where are the brakes
you know is White Plain G4 G5 is white
playing E3 E4 E5 you know where are the
pawn breaks because the pawn breaks
allow us to blow open the position
hopefully in our favor sometimes
you blow back I mean it's not it's not
very nice when that happens so for me
the breaks in the position for white or
B4 or E4 and that's it and for for from
Black's point of view if you know like
you say you can put your knight on e4
and you can play F5 Rover with your Rook
there's your play right and I look for
that that's what my strategy strategic
ideas are all about it and I I really
think that white is feeling the absence
of the Bishops because you know if the
Bishops were on the board you could even
think about jumping in with your knight
to E5 and then doing the old Pillsbury
attack weight exactly F4 I was thinking
you might even do that anyway because
you're kind of running if you're not
playing B4 sorry if you're not gonna
play B4 then playing for F4 has
something to be set for it does have
something to be said for it but on the
other hand here there's no lights my
Bishop to actually start pointing out
the H7 square right and I do feel I've
had enough experience on the white side
of this to kind of see their grand
Masters often repel it very easily and
then they look at me and they go do you
know F6 is coming and your knight is
going to get chased away from the center
right and I have even in these types of
positions where the Knight makes an
early advance in the center of the
movement I've even seen these crazy
moves 97 whole idea is that your F4 can
be kind of embarrassed shoot away if you
will uh with the move F7 F6 in any case
I do think that arena is going to be
pleased exactly in this moment where the
choice of openings Christian jump in oh
she's very pleased I can guarantee you
she's very pleased and you can see that
from their time Spencer as well one hour
and 22 for Irena one hour and I believe
it's four minutes and thinking
definitely honestly not very comfortable
in this position and she has to create
something out of nothing and we know
that this is not necessarily her cup of
tea in this particular particular case
but also you know she's so young you
don't know how to outplay your much more
experienced opponents when you're so
young I don't remember ever beating a
grand master in this type of situations
when I was 13. I think I did be The
Grandmaster but not from this type of
situations right right I was playing
much more active much more tactical
chess well there's no tactical chess
available in this position you have uh
to create something like you guys were
mentioning either with a minority attack
on the queen side either with this idea
of Knight to E5 but you know that Irina
knows the responses the general typical
responses as you guys nicely pointed out
Knight to E5 Knight F to D7 and then
this idea of F6 when did you learn Jovi
about this idea of 97 F6 from your
Grandmaster friends because you are
mentioning that as well
um how old were you how old was I well I
mean were you 13.
not at all now the night and moved night
to fd7 came actually when I was playing
on the black side someone did it to me
and I was like hahaha Knight ftd7
um I have paid these positions quite a
bit in my life
better
but not at the beginning of your career
not in the beginning not at the
beginning of my career and I would say
that when I was jumping in with with my
knight into the center with the white
pieces yes um I had some Bishops on the
board right and it looked a lot more
aggressive even even then you know they
would neutralize my initiative and then
just play very simple chess you have
some great gifts sacrifices if the
Knight goes to D7 you get Bishop takes
H7 going in yes that doesn't exist in
this position right if you put a white
Bishop on the H4 square or the black
Bishop on the E7 square and you followed
your move Knight to E5 up with F4 uh it
it would be much more threatening uh the
Bishops having been gone it just makes
the Defender as life that easier as we
were coming onto the show and I was
mentioning that Arena's getting to play
her strategic brand of Chess and
Christian you had said that for Alice
Lee she wants chaos
sorry but this there's nothing chaotic
at all that we can talk about to today's
position or exactly this position I mean
and here one of the big things that I
see as well she's not able to set
problems to Arena Arena any choices
because Irene has played this type of
position many times she knows a Night
Belongs on D6 she knows you know the
queen can just move the Rooks will
connect themselves as a half open line
to play with she's neutralized the
minority attack exactly Alice the one
who has to come up with some creative
moves
uh to be honest I don't see it exactly
again I once I see this Pawn on A5 I
think the idea of a minority attack is
basically stuffed I'll use that
expression stopped I just stopped the
minority attack which kind of suggests
to me in in some fashion we'll do it
this way but let's show our
extraordinary sense of accuracy uh
F3 I mean I I it may not look anything
special and it probably is not but at
least it's a it's a play to get some
kind of imbalance you know I've got to
play for some break in the position and
I don't think B4 is going to bring me
right Laurels do you know something
thing I just had like a flashback to
this chapter that I read in chess for
life which is all about the this this
porn structure and one of the great
experts on this porn structure is
English Grandmaster Keith Arco and he
often plays it
you know without the Bishops right and
one thing that he does is he goes Knight
to E2 so in the restarting position
like so he will go Knight to E2 he will
transfer the Knight to F4
okay and we're looking for a really long
wheel he'll he'll also
also control I have to say he will also
control this poor move A4 as well to
make sure it doesn't happen on the board
and then the plan is to go their
minority attack a3b still still with the
minority still with the minority attack
oh boy yeah so I mean but this is like
so you you're saying you've got to do
something incredibly long-winded it's
very very long-winded like this I just
put a few moves on board to try to get
to Keys set up yeah exactly and let's
say I don't know Queenie 7 for arguments
right and Knight F4 yeah Knight F4 he'll
play some H3 move he'll put the Knight
on D3 I see he'll go be he'll go B4 but
it's like very very slow and he will
massage that position and so until you
know black has uh basically Robert
enough to draw yeah one of the things I
can say about the position that Alice
has is it's not something that's going
to Peter out it's something that you can
play like Keith for a very very long
time like Anatoly karpov who just
tortured off for probably upwards of 90
moves if I've got that right and uh it
the reason why I'm so familiar with that
particular game too is I had analyzed it
in the book King walks because it was
this really great King march that until
you made all the way from G1 to A1 and
all the way back to life H3 he decided
he didn't he didn't like it uh on uh A1
by the way we have a move by
um
Alice and that was Knight to A4
okay that is uh
that's a little bit of a surprise I must
say I don't see that as being anything
that black will be upset about 97
. maybe put the Rook on
C1 which
one book yeah but I think the a row
which rock
afro excellent excellent okay so while
you're busily controlling this Square
I'm going to be very visibly controlling
this Square so Queen to E7 and Knight D2
has I feel Knight to D2 and I'll drop my
knight to E4 yeah
and
do something because bearing in mind
that she's in a must-win situation
exactly
I feel almost she's obliged to go either
F3 or actually change the pawn structure
and go Knight takes night okay but
I'm
not a fan not a fan neither am I I'm
thinking you know you've got a square
like good for you but like I've got a
square too you know good for me and uh
those nights in my mind will be
um equal yeah and uh pretty pretty even
what about the open game Christian I'm
looking at the I'm trying to understand
what's happening in this uh very
interesting end game simplified but it
remains interesting because I was going
through the lines and black indeed can
get into a worse position by the way
this is I think where we left it off
after the move E4 Rook to D6 not
touching any of the pawns yet by Hikaru
but obviously this move Rook to D6 uh
creates a clear signal I want to play
the move C6 right and right whenever you
take back I want to take back
potentially with the Rook get my Rook on
the C file penetrate via the second Rank
and start creating my own counter
chances Rook to D3 B5 first not C6 yet
my guess is that after C6 which by the
way would have indeed been the best move
in the position perhaps he was afraid or
concerned about this move Rook F to D1
if you go Rook to d8 then maybe I can
try to bring my king to E2 and then take
on C6 or any way create some sort of
imbalances in the position nevertheless
I do feel C6 would have been the right
solution he played B5 Rook to C1 this is
what we have on the board C six King to
F1 and now we have King to f8
King to E2 King to E7
but how is this position the engine by
the way is starting to really like white
after this move Rook to C5 I'm trying to
understand why me too there's a big
threat you you want to take on C6 and
then you have some problems with the
pawn on E5 so how do you defend this I
think you have to play F6 what if I go
Rook to d8 oh not F6 right Rook d8 you
take take and I think this is good I
mean you still have C7 but this is just
equal we're going to get a Perpetual
check check check you don't want to go
to C8 but you're just uh checking me all
the way to Eternity so
our route to d8 seems to be just okay
nevertheless I can play this move Rook
DC3 we do have a trade on C6 already
okay yeah yeah if you took on C6 then
this is a draw yes now with the King
only 17 on C6 you don't have any
advantages in the position anymore Rook
to C6 is going to easily be met by F6
maybe even Rook takes D3 and then put
the king to D6 this is not enough
definitely not enough and I don't think
you want to take only five because King
D7 take only eight Rook to B3 you might
indeed have some problems with the white
pieces I'm going to pick up the B2 Pawn
you don't pick up any of my pawns on the
king side this is looking good for black
Rook cd1 I have to say guys the the
players are speeding through this uh
process and most likely we will be
seeing a shake of hands very soon and uh
a result
I wouldn't be in any way surprised
um by a draw
I just want to say that because of the
possibility of b3a4 it means that you
don't ever want to go into a can Pawnee
and game as black yes uh like I would
see this
not necessarily as lost or anything like
this but I would see this ending as very
dangerous so just say that because I
always have the possibility of using my
a pawn as a decoy and forcing your king
maybe into a passive way but you don't
have to do any of that exactly exactly
just take on day three put the Rook on
A8 that's right specifically against
these ideas of b3a4 and it's just not
much well that then my question is
because your king is cut does that does
that allow white any possibility of
breaking on the queen side but I have my
own ideas right I can go G6 followed by
F5
G6 followed by F5
hmm
okay isn't there ideas of
no I I say it I know I just know I want
to simplify but then I realized that
simplifying was actually playing in
White's hands I wanted to go B4 yes that
was what I wanted as well that this is
where I was going was I was thinking
that that black would play for B4 as
well and I wanted you to be so kind yes
would be a and I was hoping that I'm not
that nice yeah yeah yesterday was my
birthday not every day is a birthday
you're right I get that I get that uh uh
but okay uh this and in case they do uh
go into in case this game is drawn uh we
will have a playoff later today that
starts uh 5 P.M
5 30. that's exactly right and this is
what the playoff scenario is like yes
and you'll see first of all the players
will play a two-game rapid playoff at
the time control of 10 minutes plus five
second increments and if the match is
still tied there will be a two game
Blitz playoff at three minutes plus two
second increment
still tied after these two games then we
go to Armageddon where whites will have
five minutes black will have four
minutes for draw odds but the two
increase two second increment kicks off
move 61 and we have to stress we can't
stress this enough if Wesley so makes a
big comeback win and wins the match then
playoffs tomorrow on Sunday tomorrow
exactly uh yesterday was interesting
when we had my birthday party birthday
dinner if you will uh
Hikaru joined us with Crystal John a
second and his stepfather sooner we were
in mantri we were asking
about the time the controls does he like
game 25 does he like game 10 does he
like game three and plus two he likes
them all he he just said very very
clearly that you know these These are
great time controls and anything that
you know uh speeds the game up he's uh
it was a favorite he was a big favorite
but he didn't it wasn't like he was
lobbying for one time control over
another like small yes I have to say the
same is not true of me I prefer I prefer
no increments I think I don't I think it
has a place in the sporting world
because you know just imagine you're
playing basketball every time they touch
I know I know I know one second
increment there if you are not a chess
player the increment for a lot of sports
fans they will not like that at all in
American football we look at that clock
and we see it ticking down and we almost
ten nine eight so the increments but
it's come that time that we have to talk
about our friends at Q Boutique and what
am I holding what are you modeling yeah
sir exactly for today it's the learn to
read and write chess Jeannie singfield
the wife of rexingfield she says well my
husband's really that interested in
chess I better learn how to read and
write but chess moves myself yeah so she
taught herself how to read and write she
said well that's pretty darn easy and uh
all of these great players come from all
over the world whether it be Indonesia
China Europe any any country and she
nabs them Genie says could you translate
this for me and so this reading right
pamphlet it's for free you can download
it and uh it has been translated into
how many languages multiple languages
multiple languages I think uh Christian
you even had to do it in Romania
I mean my Romanian is one of them I
don't have to I just wanted to do it
then no when Jeannie asks you for
something you kind of feel like uh we
will next week be okay
no I mean but this is such a fantastic
idea it is chess accessible accessible
and you can as you say it's free you can
download it on the website and
go out there and enjoy it spread the
word if you love chess make sure that
everyone else plays chess as well and
we're going to take a quick break see
you on the other side
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic Summit continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back just in time to see
Wesley so and hikara Nakamura agree a
draw in their game and that means that
that's only one thing there's gonna be
some playoffs yes and so around about 5
p.m but 5 30 yeah your time the players
will kick off into action as they fight
it out and the rapid playoffs at time
control over 10 minutes plus five
seconds per move players analyzing there
but uh when the scores are one point
each well it just means that play speeds
up yes indeed and too much Adventure
from yesterday yesterday's game it felt
like as wessie didn't really I want to
say pressure Hikaru he knows that this
is a special line that Hikaru has played
uh quite often and he didn't put any
particular pressure on Hikaru so
playoffs playoffs I know and uh well uh
in the other game where arena is just
gunning for a draw I've got to say she's
it looks to my mind like she's doing
really really well uh the Alice has just
played a move I didn't particularly like
I didn't like Knight A4 but I especially
didn't like her follow-up in this
position she played the move Knight C5
and to my mind the pawn on C5 is
actually not a good Pawn to have in
these positions Knight takes E5 uh
recapture on C5 I like this move a five
a4s as a way to artificially isolate the
pawn not to allow
b3a3b4 and just to say to White okay I
may play Queen E7 I may play Rook A5 I
may even play Queen A5 and
um
yeah very very easy position for uh
black to play
not only that but perhaps maybe even
better for black right
after this move Queen to E7 it feels
like I have space Advantage potentially
Brewing on the king side with F5 F4
given by that Knight on e4 but also A4
Rook to A5 right this is what yes and I
were discussing in the break you know
why it just has to go on the defensive
B5 at times yes yeah it just feels like
a better position I mean uh the Knight
will have to do the old Switcheroo uh
Knight to E5 to D3 to defend and you
know in time to play the move F2 F3 but
really oops wheeze whoa Knight to D4 was
the queen E7 Knight to D4 oh Alice Alice
she's competition but uh does it work so
okay so if we take Knight F5 I think we
need three and then we just take
yeah yeah it's uh it's nice that we get
to capture with check but no this Knight
is yeah but Queen A3 is the uh issue and
then you've got to play B6 and this is
this is actually something that white
has a definite advantage in the isolated
Queen Bond position here so we can take
right away but we can ask White
to step back and force something along
these lines maybe you'd go Rook C2
because I'm sorry no no no no sorry
sorry
I was
drifting drifting I was confused by this
Knight D4 me too yeah me too uh Queen uh
back to C2
um but then A4 A4 is happening A4 is
happening well it's one of those uh
can't do I have time to give you the old
try it yeah but you you said it in a
kind of a Clint Eastwood way that said
like make my day
give it a try that's three because you
know you you can put your nine on a five
F5 to D6 yes I I like that I like where
you're going so let's take away that
option from White okay from the
beginning from the get-go let's play
from the get-go
did you like rookie eight no Christian
no no no no no no why not G6
G6 yeah
I mean it's not like you have a dark
Square Bishop to hinder me on on the
dark sweaters right true uh okay so away
you go Knight G5 Knight G5 and uh I see
that you want to challenge yep again all
I need is a draw I know any any
exchanges favor me at this point I'm
playing with this gold in mind I'm
trying to put myself in irina's shoes
she only needs a draw to finish the
match and take the title why not okay
and uh if we can carry on like a
four four okay I know it's a little bit
of a surprise yes it is a surprise
I'm always happy C3 is the idea okay and
then let's uh get rid of this guy this
guy's your best guy so if I get rid of
your All-Star
I'm a happy camper I'm not touching that
so you can go Knight B3 yeah Knight to
B3 but now that you just played this
move A4 do I have some ideas of maybe
annoying you with Queen H4
just try to look at that point on a for
eign
was actually just to
wish that you played Knight takes D4 and
then the whole idea with A4 was to go
Rook D Rook B3 okay okay that was that
was the idea so something along the
lines of H3 uh even though I was
thinking Rook C1 or something okay let's
do it let's do it uh Rook C1 you defer
defending this this guy I'm gonna get
rid of your strongest yes porn takes and
then I feel like you've corrected my
Pawn structure a little bit and then
Rook B3
I've corrected your Pawn structure but
I've got an active uh Rook as well I've
got active pieces don't I right but I'm
kind of hoping that
at least some imbalances right yeah I
can
it just feels like you need to do
something
I'm feeling this is a drive I got it I
got the bad news for Alice Lee's fans
it's very close with limited material
like this sure you're going to attack my
opponent B7 but also I will attack via
the D file your Pawn on D4 okay but we
have a move from Arena A4 A4
and okay
we have A4 yes we do and what happens if
we
start with the golden plan of going F3
well here there is
ah so the idea is uh that Knight takes
C5 still can't be played uh for a moment
there I thought I had Rook A5 maybe I do
maybe you do Rook A5 and there's there's
a pin right
oh you got Knight F5 Knight F5 Who's
Laughing Now
Knight F5 uh-oh and my queen is forced
off the diagonal and I'll end up losing
my Rook
dope
I don't think this is something Arena
that's one thing you should intention
for whatsoever let's go back just a
second
um
instead of Knight to E6 all the way
towards the end so you take well well
this is the current position yeah all
the way towards the end so F3 you take
on C5 Queen A3
okay five b four do I have Knight A6 yes
now Knight to five I take on B4 so you
have to lose a Tempo to do something
else my queen is still trapped my rookie
excuse me still trapped so I'm still not
out of the woods yet and the moment you
move your knight I go Knight F5 in order
to take the Rook so and then I have
enough time do you have a threat right
now yes yes
yeah yeah yeah you're right
um I don't think this one is looking
good that's actually a a funny uh an
unusual tactical sequence that before
you can't play on for song yeah you have
to move the Knight and then suddenly
you're in a kind of a pickle my final
question
Let's uh keep going with that variation
instead of Knight A6 I take on B3
no no I take home V3
instead of Knight A6 he does what I
think on B3 yeah I was also thinking
about this as well
and you do you have to go King H1 and
now I go Knight D3 do I have enough
compensation well can you not
yes for a piece for for a rook for peace
because I'm going to give you a rook
either on the F2 square or on the C1
Square no no compensation not enough not
enough Knight takes B3 kind of throws me
off
and if I start with B2 you just take it
yeah that was my question uh a a tricky
line no but you take on C5 with the Rook
oh that's the problem I apologize that's
much much cleaner yes that's the problem
uh yeah I don't have enough
can you go back to that sometimes
sure I saw a fact against Queen D3 I
have Queen E1
yeah Queenie one yeah yeah I saw that
tree no I missed it I missed it helped
me out what did I miss yeah so if you
take on C5 if you go B2 take on C5 now
Queen to D3 attacking both the Rooks and
trying to promote but I have Queenie one
yeah I was like yes
that's a goodie that was a goodie
um
A4 on the board
and it has been an extraordinary event
it was I love the double elimination
format but let's just remind everybody
about the other participants and they
had
some great uh games as well they
certainly did because you have to
remember we started with eight only two
remains so let's take a look at
everyone's ladies and here is
she was relegated to the elimination
bracket and the first round by Bear game
took in Genova and unfortunately
eliminated from the competition by Tata
abrahamian in the first round of the
elimination bracket right and then we
had
she was relegated in the first round by
Naji paikitsa and eliminated from the
from the competition by atusa percussion
in the first round
and then we have tatev abrahamian and
she was relegated in the first round I
remember this by Irina crash and
unfortunately eliminated by najupakitsi
in the second round
and then we have a Tusa percussion and
she was relegated in the first round by
Alice Lee it was a very convincing
demonstration by the 13 year old and
eliminated by beg him tooken Genova in
the second round and here's begum
talking to Nova and she was relegated by
Irina crash and eliminated from the
competition by najibaikitsa
I think this was the third was like
yeah who had really regaled us with her
elimination match was in spectacular
form and she was relegated in the second
round by Alice Lee and I remember really
informed very very much great game and
eliminated from the competition by Alice
Lee in the fourth round of the
elimination bracket
and that's it and in the open section we
have Sam Seville he was relegated in the
first round by Hikaru Nakamura and
rombay he lost in the classical games
portion and eliminated from the
competition by LaVon aronian in the
first round of the elimination bracket
then we had Ray Robson who had a very
similar Journey eliminated sorry
relegated in the first round by Fabiano
Carana and eliminated by Sam shankland
in the first round which was
unfortunately for Ray Robson fans
because he had the joy of winning one of
the best games of the tournament against
Sam Shanklin who won the war lost a
battle did Sam that won the war and Sam
himself got relegated to the elimination
bracket in the second round by lenia
Dominguez and eliminated from the
competition by Wesley is so
and then we have last year's champion
champion Fabiano caruana who was
relegated in the second round of the
championship bracket by Wesley so that
match was closer where the tie breaks
and was eliminated by Levon aronian in
an Armageddon game in the second round
of the elimination the most spectacular
matchups I've ever witnessed seven
uh playoff games seven decisive playoff
games in that elimination with Lavon
really it was fantastic and that
was relegated in the second round by
Championship brackets oh sorry in the
championship bracket by Hikaru Nakamura
and eliminated from the competition by
levonne auronian Lavon the Lavon was
knocked down in the classical but got
his revenge oh here we see it you're
right Lavon aronian was relegated to the
first round by
by lenia Dominguez and eliminated from
the competition by Wesley so in the
fourth round of elimination bracket
and don't feel too sorry for everyone
because look at this they'll beat the
blitz of it yeah back in Action they'll
be playing nine Blitz rounds no draw
offers
time control of three minutes plus two
seconds and of course the blitz event
will actually be much more than the
eliminated American Cup participants
will also include players from the local
universities and I say that with a very
Sly grin on my face because those
players are shocked and very dangerous
absolutely we'll look forward to that
with the uh one game remaining in the
classical game and we're waiting for
those playoffs which we will see later
today after the move a 5 A4 how do the
engines uh evaluate this current
position
you mean f2f3 oh I didn't realize F3 was
on the board CSS so A5 F3 was played and
right now the engines are recommending
black as the favorite in this position
same idea Knight to G5 Knight to E6 that
makes the most sense get the Knight to a
better Square I mean E4 is a beautiful
square but it can be attacked from E6
you cannot really attack that night the
only thing that you need to be worried
about as black in the position is to not
allow the Knight to get to D6 the White
Knight to get via F5 to D6 so
the obvious question arises what if I do
it now what if I do it yes exactly I do
it now Queen F6
Queen E5 is is also uh definitely a good
move but unfortunately after Queen E5
you have ideas of f4 right okay maybe in
the future Rook F2 and now let's say
Knight to E6 you don't have Knight D6
yet and that's the important thing
because I take on C5 you take on C5 I
take on D6 and I'm going to be a pawn up
to the good
um at the end of that variation so you
have to get ready for it
yeah but if you do this I take only four
I feel like I am okay opening up that
diagonal well that D file
on the F line you want we don't need to
care about meatballs
um not the biggest fan all right so Rook
Rook a eight two Knight D6 Knight takes
C5 still
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
um my spidey sense is tingling I'm glad
I've got issues I've got pawns that's
fine you can take that I've got a knight
to D6 sighting maybe maybe on a good day
I'll I'll uh pull out my bamboo stick
and I do not believe Rook takes F7 I do
not believe you
Queen E5 Queen E5 why not
not a not a care in the world
the thing is though even if you do get
your knight to D6 yes watch this what's
this rabbit out of the hats I'm going to
go B5
darn it
I was really hoping you wouldn't find
that move but that is a very strong move
indeed and queen takes a force is going
to be met by
can I just see that uh
just want to make sure I don't have any
trickies Knight D3 at the end
Knight to D3 at the end
fair enough uh that is a a good one yep
trying to make something work for Alice
we do have Rook F2 on the board by the
way right no or that's F3 is on the
board Irina is thinking about where to
put F3 is at the board this is the line
that we've been looking at night there
night there Queen F6 Rook F2 and
um well 96 I maybe E4 is a bit of an
overreach I'm sorry I agree yeah I think
that's not really
but the problem is
well the desirable B4 would be great if
you weren't allowed to play on passant
the problem with it is ampassan maybe
Rook A1
is more than sufficient yeah no that's
uh not a possibility
um
and by the way the engines are in fact
recommending Knight F6 as the pattern
moved in 1995 F6 but to my eyes Knight
G5 makes so much more sense
Knight F6 right and I think what they
want to do is whenever you land the
Knight on D6 I will be able to just uh
hinder that with the move Knight to E8
so for example you go Knight F5 I go
Queen E6 you go Queen Knight D6 then I
probably can't even go B5 first
and then later on in the future a little
98. he's going to go B5 B5 B5 just as
you uh yeah that was my formula oh hang
on a second
oh that that doesn't work that doesn't
work that was a movie that we had
rejected because of Queen A3 now you
have to go B6 you're still in the game
you're not losing by any means but
this is where we saw chaos don't do that
and she doesn't she played B6
okay that this makes sense you give away
the C6 Pawn you exchange a few more sets
of Pawns
wait a minute I mean uh
hasn't uh Alice gotten a little bit of
something a little bit of something
exactly yes she has definitely gotten
something right Queen F6 uh
D5 D4 moves okay there might be I'm not
even calculating anything right so I
just don't want to bother with that so
you just think okay just secure the
night follow the principles of your
favorite chess offer nibs
you know the generations were ruined
the setback has been you know
devastating you even had to write a
letter
yes
I had to uh yeah defend myself against
the yes sir he's a big fan of names
by the way yeah Christian just on that
note were you a nimsovich I've studied
names of each yeah my my system or
whatever yes yes my my Dad read that
book to me plenty of times so I guess I
should probably be a fan of it and but
well I mean as you grew up and you
realized everything he taught you had to
had to be unlearned
I didn't think too much about that I
haven't gotten to that stage of my
career what things don't you like
because like this one his his rule here
is you you blockade you restrain you
destroy okay and it makes sense right
you can Emmanuel Lasker did that before
yeah okay and then he okay he prescribed
these things centralization we all know
that Paul morphy did that hundreds of
you know well before so centralization
blockade that was Emmanuel Lasker then
he he prescribed here it comes right
this is nimsovich
over protection
have you ever won a game from over
protection but you know it's funny you
should say that the top guys are winning
the game by over protecting and they do
it when they have seconds left they
literally every single piece they defend
their pieces that's not over protection
I I once asked this of uh Magnus Carlson
and he did something that really really
stunned me it was at the closing
ceremony of one of the tournaments in
Oslo at one of the events in Oslo
and I had asked him well what do you
think about Nims oh Nims are fine
and then I said just as I did now he
goes yeah that's true that's true and
Magnus did you ever win a single game
from over protection
and he stopped and he thought about it
and his eyelid started twitching
and I understood that he was accessing
memories like literally accessing files
and he goes once against Hikaru Nakamura
and I said that doesn't count because
you were over protecting the the pawn on
B2 he had castled on the grease so with
with King A1 and Rook B1 you're over
protecting B2 defending over Protections
in the center as defined by nimsovich
and he goes yeah you're right it was a
is terrible
that uh
where dimsovich shines and he's simply
outstanding he's he had some marvelous
marvelous quips
uh the um the threat is stronger than
the execution and do you know where that
comes from
no
Emmanuel Lasker chomped on during the
games and he smoked the most foul
smelling cigars this side of Cuba it was
really really bad it wreaked the playing
Hall so all of the participants of one
of these major tournaments dug into
their pockets and they bought for
Emmanuel Alaska the finest cigars they
could find
and the manual was very very grateful
and he came the next day with the awful
smelling cigars and put them on his
table and nimsovich ran to the Arbiter
and said Arbiter look at these cigars at
but he's not even smoking them yes but
the threat
is stronger than the execution
complaining them as a and in this
case you got to give the guy credit that
was brilliant that was a great quip he
had some Great Clips but uh don't study
his games because you think you'll
understand chess it'll it'll ruin your
game
uh what's going on in this particular
game uh well she didn't play Knight D4
as she didn't anticipating no she did
not play Knight before she played night
before with an immediate threat
obviously to take on D5 okay doesn't
this allow the move d4 and the potential
trade of another set of Parts well that
was the response of E4 but that was why
I liked what you were suggesting just
blockade that and make sure the pawn
doesn't step forward you could play
Knight D5 as a Prelude if you like uh to
playing E4 or would you like to just
play E4 instantly the problem with E4 is
that I can go with E3 can't I
yeah there was that D3
I'm gonna have to play Rook but now they
don't have the queen before check now
this is actually looking fine
so I think you have to play Knight to D5
let's let's try this queen let's say is
D6 maybe Queen did he say David six yes
why not and then I was gonna take
and if you take my knight well
here Rook to d8 okay Rook a8d8 this
would not happen
it was her
it was Arena's Choice Rook a a to d8
well I must say for the moment this
Knight is really I mean it it's won my
heart that is a really beautiful night
this night on the other hand
it's not so good I don't like the more
I'm looking at it I really really don't
I despise the move night before I mean
it's if if you don't win a pawn and
black gets to play D4 at D3
let's go one move further let's say
white guys Rook after D1 improve the
worst place peace okay and I and now you
you do your lovely 19 oh you can't do
that E4 E4 E4 first
and now and now wow this is remember
golden gold trade the Queens
but Jovi is not going to be happy if the
golden rule is not adhered to right
by the way now I think I spot a very
nice movie instead of Rook fd1 for some
strange reason you're not coming through
on
uh yeah I don't think we're hooked up to
your mic or something really do you I
hate Christian okay good but not so not
so loudly that's a lot okay sir
all right go go uh Christian so instead
of Rook fd1 yeah if you go Rook cd1 Rook
c d y i don't think you have D4 do you
D4 I take on D4 yeah and there's some
nice geometry going on if you go Knight
D5 and if you try to continue defending
the queen with Queen E5 or queen H4 I
have Knight E7 check
nice and then Knight to C6 and the
square E3 for your check with the queen
is defended by my queen on A3 now the
difference is that with the Rook Chrome
C coming to D1 Rook takes D1 doesn't
come with check because that round F1 is
protecting the King right so here here
here
you move Knight D5 I'm not forced to
move my queen now I can just I can trade
first with a check yes and then that's
absolutely fine for for for for black a
big moment right now because D4 I mean
the more I look at it it seems like it
simplifies the the position very quickly
well it's the move that black wants to
play because if this block Pawn comes to
D3 this Knight on C5 it's going to be a
happy camper with a pass Pawn so D4
well again what about my idea of trading
Queens I mean yes so I feel like to get
an advantage you have to do something of
this like right and then now you're
saying no we're not going to go for
trading Queens right the move that
caught my eye was something like here
I'm anticipating that the night is going
to come in right you can read me like an
open book and there you go and I was
hoping that uh something crazy like F5
might be undermining uh what's going on
Knight takes B6 and I gotta check I just
wonder is am I leading myself into a a
dead end or is it genius
yeah exactly he's a genius or is it a
dead end takes takes might be genius
okay I think it's great
it's weird right those are four those
are dangerous pawns yeah I mean I I need
to sacrifice my night for it yeah you
you you start to respect them right as
the pawns are
but don't even have I take on I was I
was wondering whether you even had moves
like Rook C8
the irony of it all oh but I don't think
it quite works because why not you take
ones and then go B3 and then you take
and then you take on c yeah yeah that's
nice right that's a beautiful
spectacular breakthrough
that final position by the way that's a
visual right the pawns are on D2 need to
what what did you do how did you how did
Black get her bonds to d2ity too well
they started slowly but then they picked
up steam somewhere along the way uh a
crazy line I I wanted to avoid the queen
trade what you were prescribing Joey and
I was going to play for this um and if
you kind of saying I guess I really
respect this idea F5 if you go Queen D2
and say you know what yeah and then we
get to uh to a position which I think is
just going to end up pretty
pretty balanced I I I think it's really
hard for you to because anytime you take
it you're going to be in some awful pin
you're just not going to break that PIN
you know what I mean takes
tags and even if you're King I'll give
you something right like here
and I'm just I'm doing it in the worst
possible way the problem is is that you
can go like this son of the King has to
step forward and you check me away and I
go back and you're just not breaking
that pin I'm not afraid all right well
there you go
and by the way uh we loved your
questions yesterday you can join our
conversation and try your best to stump
our uh All-Star commentator panel here
with any questions you might have of not
nimsovich of course but how to improve
your game coaching secrets from Missouri
and uh
um uh Jovi uh you can always tweet us
asking us a question getting involved in
the action and using the hashtag the
American Cup you can also send your
comments on the YouTube channel the
twitch and we'll try and answer them on
the show and in that I was going to say
this was great at nimsovich
1996 uh match Gary Kasparov Deep Blue
so we're in the Equitable building
Maurice Ashley and I uh we're doing the
commentary for the audience we're in the
Equitable building the theater
700 it looked like you know the Geeks of
all of all the Science World
descended into the theater for the man
versus machine match
and everything we said went out onto the
internet and there was a court
stenographer in the room and she was
extraordinary
whenever we finished speaking it was
like she stopped piping
and I was watching her because I'd never
been in that situation where Court
stenographer was doing everything and
then we took a break everything was
really nice and she came up to me and
said Mr Sarah one how do you spell names
[Laughter]
hmm can't we just call him nimzo and
leave it at that and of course there are
like 12 spellings with W's and Zeds and
there's a Polish spelling and there's a
German spelling and it was like no no no
I didn't have an answer is that kind of
ask you a question please so if someone
came up to you and said yes sir yes sir
can you sign this book for me yes and
you get it you look at it
I will sign it I'm a good sport in these
matters yes yes and I'll appreciate the
fact that you're playing a dirty joke on
me
yes indeed so ask your question
and let's just take a look at how Irina
got to the Grand finals she did it in
the best way possible she did it and the
best way because she is still on two
lives so she beat Tate of abrahamian
then she beat a begum talk engine over
and then she faced off against Alice Lee
it was the first time that we saw
playoffs but Arena was triumphant and
she's played a total of eight games
forget this five wins three draws no
losses whatsoever that's how you become
Champion
it's so simple you just win your games
and uh poor Alice who hasn't beaten me
nonetheless she herself is also in the
finals and uh she did it pretty
impressively to start so she won her
first match two to zero I believe and
then yeah she won and then she also won
one and a half half against Naji and
before losing the playoff uh arena in
the playoff and exactly have to say she
also hasn't lost a single classical game
right she's lost games in playoffs and a
rapid format but not too classical
exactly and we are looking at this
position we do expect Arena to play the
move d4 uh pardon me D5 D4 uh what's her
alternative what do you think she is
considering beside the move d5d4 I mean
it's not well that obvious is it you
could over protect the G5
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I can't help it what can I say
[Laughter]
my dear
sorry it was just a joke
I mean I'm fading fast here right uh how
because I have a trick for you okay
imagine you were to play Queen E6 yeah
okay now I will gift meet upon right you
will attack my Pawn
I will attack your Pawn you will be
obliging you will be very kind I will
take take and here you'll get the cold
shower right as you realize that night
takes has a nasty ideas of a double
um a discovered attack on the rook in
the night on The Rook on E3 that was why
I was thinking that Arena really didn't
have a choice about the move d5d4 does
she have a choice Christian
um yes but they're not that great so if
you don't play D4 you will suffer uh the
strategical consequences of having to
play with an isolated Queen's Pawn for
the rest of the game for at least for
the prolonged period now D4 I was
looking at these lights take a look at
what I found first of all
I found that were pretty good
so E4 D4 Knight Queen C3 Queen G5 if you
do go Knight to D5 and this F5
this line is exactly the correct line
Queen E3 check take on e4 take on C5 and
this ends in a draw
E2 I can go D2 you can take sure King G1
you will pick up this Pawn but in the
process I'm picking up the other pawns
on the queen side that's going to be
three versus three that's going to be a
drop this is exactly what Irina wants
from this game right so Alice Lee has to
shy away from that but how do you do
that
if you try to go Queen to D2 for example
or perhaps after Knight to D5 F5 by the
way if you don't see F5 and if you don't
if you are unable to calculate all these
crazy lines with giving up uh the Knight
and going with the two pass pawns all
the way on the third rank if you play
Rook to E8 you have to understand that
Knight takes B6 is not
such a bad threat because once you take
I take only four and now I have Queen to
it recheck I regained the piece and
that's going to be most likely an equal
position once again you take I take take
and I take on B2 that's going to be four
versus four that's going to be limited
material and a draw and she played it
D4 is on the board guys she's on her way
to retaining her title I don't see a lot
of ways in which Alice Lee can
complicate the position unless she puts
that Knight on D5 and once she does that
we've seen this very important idea
which I'm sure I really understood
involving the move F5 it's all about the
outposts that Knight on D5 you need to
get rid of its Outpost the way to do
that is by playing the move F5 yeah I
see this active move D5 D4 I appreciate
the variations you're showing us they're
Christian but I'm seeing that and I'm
saying that if I'm in an Alice's shoes
I don't want my opponent playing moves
like rook d8 and D5 D4 with a great
Outpost of her Knight on C5 I think it's
just too easy that's why I think that
that move Knight C6 B4 was a step in the
wrong direction an arena is inching ever
closer to retaining her title in the
meanwhile as we get prepared for break
so our viewers what they can expect
a feature film that was featured uh Dr
Jeannie singfield and it's celebrating
the bicentennial anniversary of the Boy
Scouts
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parson approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16 year old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone and started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project
Jeannie was there I had to give a little
speech that I didn't really know I had
to do but that kind of of has taught me
a little bit about speaking too so I
think that has helped me too this
project it's made me real proud that
everyone is enjoying it like every time
I go down there somebody's playing
and then they're taking care of it which
really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time I like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the second day of the
Grand Final where our finalists are
battling it out to see who will be
eventually become American Cup champion
and well we've already had a result in
the open section but Christian what's
going to happen
If Today ends in a victory well let's
take a look at the what if scenarios and
we're going to start with the open
section well Nakamura did not win
today's classical game the game did end
in a draw so these two players are
headed for a playoff scenario and that's
going to start at 5 30 PM Central Time
Wesley so needs to win that playoff to
continue the matches because if he
doesn't if Hikaru wins that then he
takes the title home today if Wesley
wins that playoff then we will see
another playoff between these two
players in tomorrow's matches that is
Sunday Championship Sunday here at the
St Louis chess club so that could be a
very intriguing scenario now Alice Lee I
have to say has an even more difficult
task ahead of herself because right now
she's in a very difficult position
against Irina crush and she needs to win
today's game to force a playoff is not
available for her right now because she
lost the first game against Irina
yesterday so if she wins right now in
the classical match we will be seeing a
playoff at 5 30 p.m central time she has
to win that playoff as well and then we
will be seeing her in a championship
Sunday as well very very difficult task
ahead of herself for Alice Lee if none
of those results happen Irina Crush
takes the title today
and oh and
rhymes for Alice Alice Lee and talking
about
let's have a look let's have a look at
the position have this position we
didn't expect the move Rook pardon me
Rook d8 D4 we didn't expect to move Rook
D6 I think we were uh primarily focused
on the Move Queen G5 intending the quick
F5
um
Irina spotted something a little bit
different Rook to D6 Knight to D5
current position on the board now Queen
G5 you still can't take on D4 and that's
why
I was thinking I was thinking in a
desperate times called Desperate
Measures yes
could Alice take the night with her Rook
okay so let's have a look there's some
like Waters to navigate so after Pawn
takes work obviously
um well unless you're gonna flick in I
was thinking to include the move Rook G6
yes yes but in that particular case you
can defend it so I have no choice
actually I must take and then Queen
takes exactly and so my big threat my
big idea is that if you move the rook
and you have to guard the E7 Square yes
uh and move the Rook yes and then I can
just simply take the Pawn With The Rook
or even the queen and you've got two
pawns right and maybe a third and maybe
a third
okay so Queen takes uh but the Desperate
Times Desperate Measures right
um no Rook take no counter sacrifices I
can't believe that the counter
sacrifices would work a move that I
would certainly love to play and get in
a mate it doesn't look 97 yes and then
Knight takes G6 check and every I'll
talk about losing the house I mean that
that would be Dreadful so rookie and uh
let's say hmm what else could I do
something like Rook to d8
you could take and right you're starting
I I you you made a nice collection there
but can I
I'm an exchange up for two paws hmm
I'm trying to get some but then you have
ideas of Queen C4 eyeing up the king
although I don't know where I will go
away yeah and then e
5 E5 yeah
no no checks
there no high Casitas there intriguing
um exchange sacrifice a little bit
desperate but uh I I thought you were
when you were saying I'm going to play
Play It desperately I thought you were
gonna go F4
for some reason I thought that that was
uh on your mind uh the idea is as
straightforward as it looks you you want
to you want to take the pawn without
blundering yeah on C1 where does the
queen go though just out of curiosity
I guess H4 H4 but then you have I was
going to take a pawn and I said
yes yeah
Knight takes
here
it could be even better
um
I've got the the trick I wanted it it's
almost a 50 50. mate
oh no oh it's so close
uh yeah it it didn't work that one
um
Knight takes E4 how about do I have a
tricky
you still have the F5 sorry
um Alice needs to mix it up Christian uh
it feels like there might be some
tactics but she does yeah yeah Rook
takes C5 I have to say from a practical
perspective I sort of like with the idea
of taking then take on D4 you're getting
a lot of Pawns now still the big
question is how safe is your king and
how many
risks in the position can you take so
for example you take on D4 I would
assume after Rook fd8
Rook fd8 why not yes seems like a very
natural move you take on D4 ah with the
queen okay I thought that you will take
with the Rook just so that you
have ideas of Rook they say four but I
have Queen E5 right now
Queen E5 and whenever you take on A4 I
take on B2 it's not that easy to create
any sort of Separation right now
the big question from the beginning from
the get-go
what happens if you take on B6
yes there is that you have that little
flick as well in the position I was
afraid of this move yes so there's an
important thing that you need to notice
and that is after Knight takes E4 if you
try to play first Knight takes C4
this is very problematic because you
have Knight C8
ooh very nice and not easy to see by the
way not easy to spot this little move
and now after Rook to G6 you do threaten
check mate in one move but the problem
is Knight to E7 finishes the game yeah
we saw how that finished the game a move
or two ago exactly so uh after Knight
takes E4 so you can start with Rook G6
we have a very curious if Irina has
calculator or calculated all of these
ideas
you play G3 most likely
now you take on e4
and now there's no number
okay that needs to be answered but now
you have a very beautiful tactic you
take on G3 first
I thought that wasn't possible because
of Knight E7 97 and queen takes C7
and queen takes A7 Knight F5
jumps back with that scorpion sting that
we've been discussing that's game over
nice pretty that's right that's a very
beautiful uh geometry but she needs to
see all of these things right so after
Knight takes C4 most likely
what do we do
so Rook G6 g33 Knight takes C4 so Knight
takes
Rook here
G3 Knight takes C4 takes
I would have to take but then then black
is a happy camper what if I go on
December instead of C8 that's another
Square G3 or you take on e4 and now I go
97.
okay so once again uh Rook G6 yes give
me the Checkmate it's it's it's a very
complex line Knight to D7 now now I'm
threatening mate in one that's got to
get your attention exactly over a custom
move you have to attack the Knight right
otherwise you lose a piece in one move
for nothing
so you have to go Rook to d8 now I take
on e4 right you take on D7 and this is
the key position right here right now if
you take on A4
no problem I have all sorts of checks
Queen to E3 Queen to E3 check that's
going to be a Perpetual right that's all
I need with black
you have one move that gives you the
advantage and it's all about
if you meet Rook to C8 with Rook to d8
and if you meet Queen takes A4 with
Queen to E3
it seems like the queen is defending a
lot of squares right it's eyeing a lot
of squares d8 as well as E3
how do we force it to move somewhere
else so that we can do either Rook to C8
either Queen takes
A4 not H4 and H4 Queen takes G3 that
yeah but that's not clear because you
just uh you have Checkmate yes exactly
back rank
s that's an idea as well the problem
with H4 is I take on H4 with a queen
yeah right but you do go root to C5
exactly
and now this gives wide the advantage
uh pushing the queen away very difficult
position you have to stay on the H4 d a
diagonal so that you made Rook to C8
with Rook to d8 otherwise you get
checkmate right
so you have to go queen d8 or queen F6
or things of that nature but once you do
that I pick up the pawn on A4 that's to
connect
she went for it guys I takes B6 we're in
the that's the move that's the money
move Rook to C5 did she see that because
we know that Irena is going to start
looking at this position she probably
has calculated this already
is she hovering is she getting ready to
make a move
I see a hand it is the clock a factor
yet not yet 26 minutes for young Alice
Lee more than 40 minutes for Irina Crush
40 plus one minute my first instinct is
that this must be good for black I don't
know right it just looks like this
Knight on B6 is is is way off sides and
I see this move Rook to D and again
aren't I all I need is a draw right so
after moves like G3 I'm almost thinking
go ahead take my knight let me sacrifice
my my rook and I'll take your knife I
know in this particular case F3 is not
the Perpetual because of the queen yeah
so uh Knight takes this move Knight D7
it's easy to spot
perhaps easy to spot if you calculate
for a little bit in my opinion Rook to
C5 is very very difficult
if you manage to get there I'm sorry I
can't hear him
yeah I didn't catch it either yeah so
you think it's difficult to spot yes you
guys cannot hear me very well yeah
you're you're my you're not miked up
with us
I don't know why so long as the audience
hears you that's all that matters that's
uh that that's a great audience can uh
yeah can hear me well okay so once again
Rook to G6 G3 help us out here Joey this
is it feels like with these black pieces
primed on the king side you'd you'd
almost expect that you'd have a shot
here don't you didn't you what Knight
takes E4 but this move Knight D7 that
was offsetting I mean can you sacrifice
the knights
I'm thinking D3
D3 this is Queen takes though right
you need to stop you yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's okay okay I mean it's let's see
how this is here
okay I would say that that you know
you've got compensation for the pawn
maybe it's not what you intended when
you went D3 right but okay
still kind of uh stunning to me that
there isn't a move like Queen H4 Queen
F4 or something so if I go Knight E6 and
you go Knight here
once again I don't have any of these 97
Checkers it's very annoying truly so it
just seems that right now in fact
objectively Irena is in a much worse
situation
fighting her way uphill
and it's Rook C5 this is the chemo and
Tim The Black Queen if she goes to d8
yeah I can just dig the point then you
take the pawn and doesn't black have
enough counter play based on this it's
very important they're still counter I I
would think so yeah in my view yes one
thing that I did see instead of taking
the pawn if you were to drop back to d8
oh I apologize because people at home
might be like hey hang on a second wrote
DC One
isn't that going to be great for that's
another good move yes that that is
another good movie I probably have to go
home
black has D6 D3 sorry D3 but uh that is
a queen unfortunately yeah D2 uh check
check
the D1 and you don't get uh
you don't get the the the one yeah so
you can't do that so you have to
actually
I have to move my queen we have to move
the queen probably to f8 after Rook D1
so after Rook C5 yeah Queen d8 is fine
and then after a good C1 Queen effect
let's see okay
I have to get ready to meet Rook C8 with
Rook to d8
yeah again I I I'm with you Jovi I would
have thought that this Pawn would you
know really give you you know sufficient
counter play after Queen d8 Rook D1 uh
you got to do something like Queen f8
but not that easy guys not easy no no it
seems like Alice finally has gotten
something so it means that Rook D6
really was the wrong movie and she
should have gone for the queen G5 F5 D3
first she was supposed to go with D3
first right so it was somewhere here
that we had
anticipated anything like Queen G5 not
yet D3
uh followed by F5 D3 first or D3 first
apologies D3 Knight D5 and now Queen G5
this is where we were and then we were
heading for F5 but Arena tossed in what
she thought was a clever little move
Rook D6 because like ourselves she
probably saw a situation where she was
going to get in this nice little uh Rook
G6 Tempo and she was thinking oh now I'm
going to be better but why is this move
Rook to D6 is a bit strange because okay
95 is one way to deal with things and
it's a very concrete way but can I just
simply locate that pawn on D4 with the
move Knight D3
from the get-go instead of Knight to D5
off the root to D6 I'm not following
what he said after Rook to D6 maybe can
I go Knight to D3
19 to D6 can I go Knight oh yeah instead
of not D5 he was uh saying that white
could play not D3
okay the pawn
yeah
but it doesn't feel as active
you know Alice's continuation
is much more natural because you know
she is in a situation where she needs to
ride or die you know so exactly throw it
forward so I mean the tech yeah I mean
93 was a a a nice
um how do you say positional way of
playing the the position but uh Alice is
like saying okay let's mix it up
tactically Knight takes D6 and I hope
I'll come out on top and we've been
looking at in this position to move Rook
G6
G3 Knight takes E4 Knight to D7 with a
rather massive threat of meat in one
group to d8 and only because of this uh
it seems like the queen is a little bit
overloaded yeah on the one hand the
queen defends or attacks the E3 Square
so it stops Queen takes A4 on the other
hand it's necessary that the queen
defend the d8 square in order to meet
Rook CA check and that's why we play
this petite little move Rook C5 and say
to the queen
choose your poison give up the E3 square
or give up the d8 square
the d8 square is more uh crucial yes
there's no change
we went Queen d8 Rook C1 and we got an
advantage for white as well as Queen
takes A4 some in here if we were to play
it from the black side I mean how easy
is it for Alice because to me to my eyes
it doesn't look that easy so for
instance Queen takes A4
yeah okay and so you kind of go let's
get I would think yeah
or upon me you want D3 yes because
can I
save this move because again you've got
these back rank problems right so if you
trade you're not going to take twice
that that would really make my day Queen
E8 would be made
um
so that was why I was thinking you you
needed or H yes you needed the
Luft
and by the way I was in in Dusseldorf
and Elizabeth Pace said it's not Luft
it's Luft
something is like Luft with a square
it's air pocket
okay it's an air Square so that the
correct German is left with a secondary
word uh we Americans have always just
said oh make space for the king we
create Luft but the Germans say uh an
air pocket in air Square
just thought I'd throw that in you never
know what you're going to learn
information and no my brain is going to
keep that for the rest of its life will
it remember the theory no no no no but
remember your air pockets
um yeah uh
how good is it uh Christian uh the
engines are giving white an almost plus
one Pawn Advantage almost plus one
advantage 0.7 sometimes 0.8 but once
again those are achieved for black those
only one Pawn Advantage with perfect
play Rook to G6 and go all the way into
this Rook to C5 idea and try to survive
in that position this is not easy
because you can easily try to find some
sort of a very aggressive way to survive
this and create your counter chances and
those usually don't work and in fact
throw you into a much much deeper Abyss
than you are in right now so are I have
to say Alice Lee has her chances in this
one and we could potentially see a
playoff in this match as well
wow that first of all it would be so so
surprising because Irina came out of the
opening is with one of the most solid
Queen's Gambit decline type of positions
that you could ever hope to achieve then
she purposefully mixed it up with this
whole uh captures on C5
and this is over nice takes E4 Knight
takes E4 Knight C8 this is over
he didn't play Rook G6 this is a blunder
alert right here Knight to C8 finishes
the game I mean the best thing you can
get is maybe be a piece down go Rook to
d8 or something along those lines 98 97
excuse me and then take only four piece
up for no compensation we saw this
before that the move Rook G6 loses the
entire house after Knight E7 check King
h8 Knight takes G6 yeah Knight C8
finishes the game right can we zoom out
to see the reactions of the players
because I'm very curious to see how
Alice is looking and there it is
we need to see irina's reaction right
now because she missed this she
certainly missed this move
Knight C8 and she's hunkered over she's
looking at that night where did you come
from oh she doesn't like it look at her
oh oh no
Knight C8 we've all had that cold that's
the cold shower of her experience of
like I didn't see this move Knight C8
it's an easy move
to miss when you're just like
calculating to yourself you attack my
Rook
I'll move with gain of tempo you don't
have time to capture the Knight because
of checkmate
and uh you take my knight I'll take your
night and here we see the blender once
more
uh all the time in the world 30 minutes
she thinks she's got it all under
control Knight takes you C4 forgets to
run through that list of Alternatives
that white can play exactly because you
also see you're thinking porn takes
night where it takes nights exactly
check check no no no
but this move it's it's a very unusual
pattern uh in the sense of Knight C8
to attack the E7 square if the knights
on F5 and the Knights on D5 you're
automatically drawn to the E7 square but
Knight C8 to E7 you have no time for
Rook G6 97 and if you move the Knight
now well you're losing The Rook
and as Christian said if you go back
hoping to trade Knights nope
one check and this time
Alice
winning guys this is history in the
making this is the first time that Alice
Lee will defeat Grandmaster Irina crush
the eighth time U.S women's champion in
a classical game in in fact in any story
rather than Blitz doesn't matter this
will be the first time that Alice Lee
gets that coveted Victory against Irina
Crush well the score had been so
lopsided I almost like eight games with
Arena taking like five of them to
victories and just a few draws
but if Alice wins oh looks nice because
we are bound for the playoffs and that
means the players will play a two-game
rapid playoff and the time control is 10
minutes plus 5 Second increment if the
match is still tied then we're going to
go off the Blitz and after those two
Blitz Games if it's still tied then
we're gonna see Armageddon and however
it is not all over for Alice because yes
she's reached the playoffs but she still
needs to win more games right because
Arena has two lives having won the
Champions bracket without a defeat
Knight C8 and arena is
stopped and she just like Frozen in her
chair and she realizes the horror of
what she's done to her position her Rook
is hanging her Knight is hanging 97
check uh binds the King
of The Rook on f8 sorry you're not even
getting any compensation no it's zero
compensation right it's not even like
the night's going to be misplaced it's
gonna find itself on D5 right uh like a
huge home
there and that that move yes she you
know sometimes you're just blind to a
move and that move Knight C8 and I
remember very very well I was calling it
a match between
Vladimir kramnik and deep Fritz
and the computer had put the Knight on
E8
and Vladimir after much thought made his
move stood up from the board was looking
you know and was feeling very good about
his position
and the computer operator played mate in
one yeah
it was like
seven mate because you're not used to
seeing the Knight attacked the part on
H7 from the square It's usually the F6
or G5 and he was completely out he just
missed it and it was made in one but you
know what happens to
very famous game where
gunshok was playing against and I think
in some PCA rapid tournament and he
misses like something super simple like
Queen takes work right like the queen is
on e4 and you can take on on H1 and it's
Checkmate yeah but somehow the G2
squares are covered and the other
squares are all covered so he has like a
blind spot right and he doesn't play the
mate in one oh yeah and I remember the
commentators Danny King and Maurice I
was like he's investing he's missed it
but you know sometimes it happens
sometimes the double blind spot that's
very very very frequent I also had this
with a friend of mine a friend of mine
that was in my teammate and he thought
he'd played a great game and he analyzed
it with with his opponent and she also
concluded you know this is a great game
and uh and then he got back to his room
and his father sent his message and said
you know it was
it was interesting it was a great game
but what's up with you blundering the
Rook and he kisses
right and he goes you know there was a
Black Knight on C2 it could have taken
me one and he goes no and then he goes
and rechecks and he says okay yes I did
I did blunder my rook and it was just
funny because not only did they miss
both message during the game but they
both missed it in the analysis
afterwards so it happens right yeah your
stories of blind spots uh they're
Christian so all right I'm trying to
think of any
this type of situations and I can
remember one from the Romanian National
Championship I think it was the last
round I had a terrible tournament I was
just coming back from uh winning the
world youth uh Championship but in the
national championship I was doing uh
poorly I think I was 10th in that
situation no chances for a medal and I
just wanted the tournament to be over
and in the last round the one thing that
I did I played the second move from my
calculation so I started with the second
move from my calculation
um and obviously I resigned two moves
later because that was just losing a
piece so not necessarily blindness but
just one of those hiccups and I was
thinking about this position and I was
starting to feel the trend reverse in
this game because take a look at this
Knight takes C5 already we understood
this was not the right step for Irena it
seemed like she was getting on shaky
grounds Queen to A3 B6 sure you're not
going to go Rook to A5 to give up uh the
piece in one move but take a look at
that as we go through the variations
Knight to B for Rook to d8 Rook to D1
Rook fd1 D4 sure that's good but now
Rook to D6 another mistake right another
hiccup in the position Knight to D5 and
of course the final hiccup right now
Knight takes E4 which allows Knight to
C8 and gives yd Advantage it's all about
the trend and it felt like the trend was
reversing she got a great position out
of the opening Arena but it feels like
the nerves as you get closer to winning
that title they get a bit more impending
and uh in your psyche so this is exactly
what we're seeing right now with
happening with Arena crush and we do see
her now realizing to her or horror yeah
that in fact there is no way for her to
get anything near sufficient uh play uh
in fact it looks so bad to my eyes I
just have to ask you what the engine is
advising plus five it's plus five plus
five right now the best thing you can do
is just go rookie six and take only four
and try to play that position
Rook E6 F takes E4 Rook takes C4
good luck defending that well there's
there is one trap in the position okay
90s so takes
no it doesn't even work I was I wouldn't
stop before he even got started there uh
this one
I mean I was just gonna say that okay
The Rook can come to E2 exactly and uh
if you're careless true I was actually
thinking that then I don't know if
they're seeing ghosts the Knight can
come to E7 and go Knight G6 check but of
course these seven square is covered
yeah but the Rick and queen No rookie I
mean main thing is just don't go Queen
takes porn don't get greedy don't go
greedy yeah something like Rook C5 Queen
C5 very very true I like Queen C5 that
looks like a very
the golden rule of Jovi when my cake is
being attacked I should trade Queen
exactly Queen C5 works all the time nine
times out of ten yeah nine out of 10
dentists who ever get this position
recommended recommend trading Queen so
Rook E6 is the best and I gotta tell you
that is uh yeah that's that looking so
forlorn that I I wouldn't even want to
play it out frankly
if I had to do that do you play it out
is the question given the match
situation like do you try to adjust how
do you try to adjust to this new reality
the fact that you lost and you have to
play another mini match against this
young lady to try to clinch uh and
finish the show
how do you
get to that how do you accept that
psychologically you have to get to that
stage and this is very difficult to do
that in one move right because so do you
resign and go back to your uh yeah I
mean for for me it's this idea that
okay I blew it I blew it but guess what
I'm still doing great in the competition
like really great if I win this playoff
match is over and my opponent has to win
two playoffs so I have to build myself
back up and say okay well done I
blundered but guess what I I had a
really good position so you try to talk
yourself into this it's not the end of
the world all right yeah that is a dream
that is you're in a guru speech yeah but
the reality is
like why on Earth did I do that you know
and I know a howler man exactly but also
Irina would think man I had such a great
position out there open everything was a
dream and I just started complicating
things like an idiot and so I know it's
very
dig deep down inside of you but the
howler of course is a chest term that we
use where you know you've blundered this
winning position uh you correctly shake
the hand of your opponent signed the
score sheet leave the chess club the
moment the door closed Scream and Shout
the world you know ah your cries of
Anguish are so great they can be heard
in the next County that's a howler
or you could be like nimsovich you could
stand on the table and say why must I
lose to the city
which did take place I
[Applause]
recover and I'm
alive she will
now she's on a 10-minute thing and by
the way she played Knight takes E4 with
just be after two minutes or so this
move Knight C8 was
completely blind I mean she that was a
blind spot and once more rookie for you
know what I'll take it back if I do see
rookie 6 and Rook takes E4
and I can play a few moves you mentioned
it yourself Jovi that you know rookie to
a spark of counter play in the position
you make Alice find some good movies all
right I'll go Queen G3 I'll Queen G3
I'll light out your spark see he's he's
the party pooper and ha Rook G4
maintaining F2 let's see
there was a special circuit Queen F2
queen queen F2
okay I was a little afraid you were good
yeah okay
I'm not happy here
that must be it and you've been telling
me about this whole idea
get some advantage on the second rank
I'm stopping all of that yes I agree 96
yes
uh
resignation is usually a move that you
you you you can
do almost any time you can do it anytime
but uh I think arena is going to play a
few Spike moves for sure for sure and
then just get mentally used to the idea
that she's lost and then she's gonna
make a beeline to her room and get on
the phone with a coach sure coach or
say the right words yeah and uh the same
goes for Alice because she also has to
temper her emotions because she will be
riding High because she's achieved but
what was very difficult I have this
great story to tell it's so such a
hilarious story because you said you get
on the phone and your coach will tell
you all the right words well what
happens if you have a coach who tells
you all the wrong words
so there's a story like this and I'm
gonna mess up the names but it was like
this
grandmasterkovsky who had come from
Siberia
and somehow he had managed to make the
all Soviet final like it was
unbelievable I mean this the this
Grandmaster from Far Far Away
had qualified through these you know
Supernatural kind of things and he was
the only coach in the entire
Supernatural finals of the Soviet Union
who didn't have a coach the only player
who didn't have a coach so the Soviet
Chess Federation appointed him a coach
and the coach came uh the day of the
super finals and so it said okay today
you play uh Naj Medina
your your white black it doesn't matter
medinaf is going to sacrifice at night
somewhere in the middle game there's
nothing you can do and He will destroy
you
okay
thank you coach
it happened just the way the coach said
as Medina did some magic sacrificed a
night and won the game
wow and then the next game he was black
against Petrosian
and the guy said you know petrosian's
gonna take you know control of the E5
Square squeeze you for the rest of game
and just throttle you
and it happened just like
fired after these two losses
back-to-back losses and the coach went
back to Kiev and said well why did I get
fired I told him what was going to
happen it went just the way I said
sometimes you don't get the good the
good matchup with the coaches
but it's true you know he should have
paid attention to the coach right you
know what I mean it's like the guy is
telling you look he's going to put this
so you're like yeah okay fine I'll put a
piece on that square there you go I
might see what what has happened Arena
still
recoiling from the shock and horror that
Knight C8 has completely changed the
position and Alice's is winning please I
was going to ask whether you had any
personal experience with this type of
situation you call your coach coach says
something because I have never really
had a coach right so one of the things
I've always envisioned is like some kind
of like you pick up a red telephone it's
always red and red it's always red and
you go ahead of the emergency call what
do you do and you they give you some
moves and you get them
like just like Austin Powers right very
good done and you're all set to go no
unfortunately in my day uh the price
ones were not high we simply could I
simply could not afford a coach I had I
was very very lucky to have some very
dear friends like John Donaldson that
who could at times
accompany to accompany me to a
competition but mostly I just didn't
have a coach at all and so I didn't have
that Solace of having somebody I could
call and say you know I feel like an
idiot today oh that's too bad you'll do
better tomorrow okay didn't have it but
you see it's actually quite important to
uh the top players I mean today today I
mean they they're always
has a whole team yeah he has Peter Heine
and Nielsen and his father around is a
very good support network sure and you
know things that they do is that they
know how to put Magnus in a good mood
right they they know what to say they
know what stories to tell they know how
he's going to snap out of it and also
have to say a lot of the top players
they've told me on a personal level that
you know they've they've played so many
games they've lost so many games that
you know event they can just go
yeah yeah they recover very very well
and I remember most especially
when I was playing in these tournaments
with Gary Kasparov the the dream was to
be his follower like Gary was this force
of nature that just blasted his way
through the field so you wanted to play
Gary's opponent the next day because
they were usually really from what had
happened in the previous day and uh yeah
this idea that that that that that you
you have to be in this mindset and I
remember Gary and Anatoly both they had
some of the best coaches that the
Soviets could provide and um they were
long long time coaches so they knew how
to interact with one another too like
sometimes you just need to be left alone
and they intuited that
this position well what can we say it's
been a 15-minute thing suddenly for
arena you know she's down to her last 12
minutes so she will need to do something
at some point again perhaps she's in
fact considering just resigning and
because we only have one hour left until
the playoffs are supposed to start so
again comes the question what do you do
do you just try to play it out for
another 20 30 minutes and then you will
not have that much time to recover
before the playoffs or do you just
resigned here because you will be a
piece down that's quite a lot
go home speak with your coach have an
hour of preparation and trying to go
through your lines and try to come
around refreshed after this disaster of
a game for Irina Crush well rookie six
rookie for I would play those moves and
I'm forcibly reminded of a playoff the
U.S championship in between Arena and
Jennifer
Arena pardon me Jennifer blundered a
bishop she was just a pieced out
and rather than resign and you know like
uh woe is me she kept playing on and
Arena was trying to force and trying to
force and slip slip slip slide and one
of the great you know turnarounds of all
time we we witnessed here in Saint Louis
was Arena a full peace peace up against
Jennifer you Jennifer went on to win the
Women's Championship because of that uh
there was a difference in that one what
was it a loss the match would have been
over exactly right now if Irina loses
the match is not over the match
continues right so she was in a must win
situation she had to continue that match
if you do resign that position then you
resign the whole match right now this is
a completely different situation from an
energy preserving perspective at least
that's the way I see it
and Arena has come to the the
startling realization that she's just
that loss uh again when she played the
move Knight takes E4
she expected that she was well within a
drawing Zone there wasn't even any
problems uh you know she didn't see
Knight C8 it was just a total total uh
yeah
flying spot exactly and unfortunately
there aren't too many pieces on the
board as well which does mean that the
margin for actually saving the game is
Just exceedingly low I mean if there
were Bishops on the board you know
perhaps
white kid you know say okay black could
say UK white has to be careful because
they have an unsafe King this way
nothing you know I when it comes to Big
saves I do also remember Magnus Carlson
against gawaine Jones yes
but you know he kind of shocked his
shoulders and wentless carrot let's
carry on carry on very recently
um let me get it right there was
happened in tata Steel in the challenges
section I can't quite recall
yes it was Tabata Bay versus
yeah easy for you to say and so that was
another one and he's he said you know
there's uh the person who won with the
piece down said you know his inspiration
was Magnus costume Jones right and you
know in a kind of case of karma
um I also remember in 2000 I want to say
11 or 2012 and the British championships
at the playoff
um Stephen Gordon was facing Dwayne
Jones Gwen blunders is Queen
is Queen he's a queen yeah oh dude I
think he gets a bishop in return oh dear
but he kind of carries on you know we
were all kind of really shocked and we
were thinking oh no he's gonna go in has
to resign but he just kept on playing
because rather like the situation with
uh Arena crash and Jennifer you you know
if he lost he would lose
everything and the title will go to
Stephen Gordon and so he just kept
playing he kept playing Scrappy moves
and he turned it around you see one of
the things that happens there is when
you're the queen versus the bishop as
you just described it
you know you're so anxious just to win
the game that you start to think okay
this trade may not be the most favorable
but it gets me closer and you give it a
little bit more compensation and a
little bit more and a little bit more
and suddenly the trend is irreversible
right now you know there's nothing you
can do to stop that threat nothing yeah
Irina did play the move D3
upon me she played D3
D D3 yes and now we have F takes E4 so
that was uh okay so D3 came with the
pardon me D3 came with the idea of Queen
E3 take on D6 don't take on D6 uh By the
way when when you first learned this
smothered me
did you react
I still think to this day is like the
most beautiful thing of all the times
right the chessboard because it's like a
knight
single-handedly defeating the entire
white Army exactly this is it this is
the the smothered Checkmate it's a
double check the Knight and the queen
jointly attack the King has to go to the
corner if you go here there's Maiden one
now comes this unbelie I mean it just it
blew my mind when I saw this smothered
mate I literally I ran home to I ran
home my mom was in the kitchen doing the
dishes I grabbed her hand mom I gotta
show you that this is like the most
unbelievable thing ever I sat her down
and I went Jack Jack mate isn't that
gorgeous and she said yes sir that's
wonderful can I go back to do the dishes
pearls are casting the pearls yes but
this smothered mate how old were you I
was 12 in this I was younger actually
yeah and who showed it to you you
learned it at the club I learned it at
the coffee house where we all the chess
players hunting yeah I think I just
learned it from a book you know my
father would go through from the book
I'll go through some chess books and he
would show us these things and uh I was
just astounded I mean the thing is
though I've been playing chess for such
a long time I don't remember when I
learned such principles right and
checkmates so for me you know the queen
was the bully of the chessboard so the
queen was like this greatest piece and
whenever I lost my queen I lost the game
because it was like ah this is no longer
interesting my queen would capture
everything I love capturing with my
queen so this idea of voluntarily giving
up the queen no no no no no no no no no
achieve a smothered mate no no no no so
it was something very special we do have
Arena continuing to play She's she's
trying to lay a trap for uh Alice in
this particular position you can see the
desirable Knight B6 in order to during
the night back into The Fray and you're
a full piece of wood we met by the cold
shower check winning back the piece here
I think Knight goes back to D6 right oh
I was about to suggestions
but Knight to D6 actually gosh darn it
when I see that move uh I just want to
bring the track back that's it's nice
it's very nice the Knight will find a a
loud pose I much prefer Queen C5 I do
too just just from the from the sheer
annoyance factor of the queen being away
from the King side Queen A3 to C5 covers
the square offers a trade
and who knows maybe on a good day I'll
still keep 97 check on tap and what is
Alice going to play She's reaching
Queen C5 yeah it's all on the board
somewhere somebody's chess coach is
smiling into this move
and one more uh look at this move that
rocked the house as Rook G6 was a
necessary Prelude tonight takes E4 Arena
did it in a wrong move order Knight
takes E4
and then came Knight C8 and Alice was in
business
yeah definitely and that is the moment
31 minutes playoffs yeah and it was it
was a 20-minute thing for arena after
Knight C8 and D3 was her try only five
minutes left for Irina in a hopeless
situation right now and as you were
mentioning with this move Queen to C5 if
you don't try to go Queen to d8 now
finally that Knight comes to that desire
desirable Square D5 P6 with Tempo
everything with Tempo which is very very
nice and pleasant to do you can go Rook
to D4 but then still I go Knight to D5
you trade you take on A4 I take on D3
let's trade those pawns full piece up
this one is over yeah I would I'm such a
greedy I would say trades I'm off I'm
all about willingness to trade in such
moments uh I might find the move Rook C4
but I agree with you wholeheartedly yeah
Christian 95 take this pawn and uh
really does nothing nothing at all white
is just a one whole night up I mean no
you know that was the great line of
Michael Tall
so at one moment Bobby Fisher said that
he could give the woman's the Soviet
women's world champion Knight odds odds
of the night and still win a match the
Soviets said we accept we accept Bobby
recanted no thank you only being
facetious and Michael Tall explained
Bobby's decision
Bobby's Bobby but at night's a night
interesting enough there was a match
that was held maybe a few years ago
between Australian Grandmaster David
smurden against the computer I think
stockfish where the Grand Master had the
night odds no way yes
and and okay well then we were asked you
know like what what
most people went I'm sorry but the
computers the computer you make a
mistake and it's gonna pounce right but
I know he did he did win I thought it
was remarkable that the computer could
win with pawn and move
the computer would take a Pawn off the
board and you got the white pieces and
the move so you could go E4 D4 two moves
and you would have a pawn up and somehow
the computers were playing against top
Grand Masters successfully with those
odds I didn't think a night good to hear
that David got him yes
nicely done and queen C5 Queen d8 on the
board were expecting Knight B6 just
bring that Knight back to a protected
Square not the only move uh to win the
game of course lots of uh winning
winning moments and the problem is after
Knight B6 you don't even have time to go
D2 because I can take on D7 you take on
C1 I take back with the queen that's
nice it's it's over once again and yeah
you just want a pawn in that whole uh
trade as well Knight to B6 was on the
board played
I think we
we I smell a resignation coming we're
gonna hurt ourselves for two playoffs
already did it I came to today's
broadcast anticipating a single
playoff I did not expect to I hold my
hands up and say I also expected the
same I thought that Alice was not going
to be able to do it no
and we do have Rook D4 on the board a
choice for white do you play Rook C4 or
do you like uh 1995 95 and then just
Rick takes porn simplify the position as
fast as possible gotcha
so
that's fine you can take my Pawn on e4
no problem I'm not going to try to save
absolutely everything like Wesley did
against Levon I'm not going to be that
greedy I'm going to go 95 and she does
and she does
I just suspect that the position is so
bad for arena that when the resignation
happens it will come instantaneously
true true so 95 tax The Rook
uh essentially The Rook is trapped it
forces Rook takes and this is what we're
talking about the trade you get this
Pawn on e4 but I get this very dangerous
Pawn on D3 my Knight's nicely
centralized and uh well I just look
forward to the time that I can play Rook
to D1 and I don't know find some even
nicer squares for for the night Rook
takes E4 Rook takes D3 is going to come
on the board very shortly
three minutes yeah three and a half
minutes
Rook 28 most likely right now yeah
that Rook into play right
now the question is how do I I cannot
stop you from giving me a check on
anyone most I mean I can but I don't
think I want to
do I just make a lift with H3
uh nothing wrong with that one I I tell
you I like this idea of just uh making
sure that there's no uh back rank
awkwardness that I have to deal with H3
I like
I like it a lot
I also I think it's a very practical
decision the thing is though black also
has to take the time out to look after
the background as well as well as indeed
um
the only thing I would say in such
positions like this where your king is
that slight he does have some slight
vulnerability is the Knight on D5 it was
if it was on F3 I would be absolutely
Stone Cold
uh certain my victory just uh
maybe maybe something just to be said
for Rook F1 and Rook F3 and making sure
that my king is quote over protected
I can use that
I like Rook F1 yeah I also like
and uh just to let you know that if the
this game ends soon yes then the men
will still be playing their tie breaks
at 5 30. whereas the women do get a half
hour rest okay gotcha so will that does
that mean that they start earlier
because right now we're still an hour
away from the playoffs
so they all of them start at the same
time unless unless this game goes uh
close let's say this game closes out at
5 15 local time they're going to have a
30 minute break we got it you got it but
this game we're not anticipated we're
not expecting it to last that much
longer
and the arena is
really wondering oh my goodness why why
why why have I let my my opponent do
this to me
stopping any sort of Chinese I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
on the contrary it's a very very safe
consolidating move discovering the first
rank maybe setting up for and another
one Knight C7 and another one Knight C7
yes yes boy I must say the more I look
at D3 to D1 and so what if you try to
get a queen out
let's go Queen G5 yes I was hoping for
that because you can go yes Knight C7
but I have to be quick I have to be
careful because there's a trap Rook E1
on the board but then I'm that one yes
that's a tricky tricky because if you
take the queen we check on C5 that's
right exactly you're ready I just
literally abundant myself
ah check okay so um let's not play
Knight C7 so still
for some reason when I saw Knight C7 and
rookie one the theme song of the good
bad and ugly went through my mind like
wow yeah
by the way Enrico
his ambition the the man who composed
that his ambition was to be a
professional chess player
oh yes
I didn't know that exactly I was on the
chess Base website
um
you know nice interview with him uh
Queen G5 again you you know in Arena
shoes you've got to be your most
irritating best I mean queen if you
allow Alice this to consolidate guys
yeah there's a check mating yes there's
a very serious you take you take that
threat very very seriously
and the first thing I would I would coin
off too
how about that for a moral Victory I
threatened Checkmate in the position at
least for a second
I I Pat myself on the back for such
things even when you know the moral
Victor you know my threats were were
very strong okay Queen F2 yeah I would I
would stop that in an instant yes you're
welcome to snack on the uh
B2 Pawn but the trade of Queens is so
good for me I I reckon I'll let you
you'll get away with that little snack
over there and I will just uh uh play
for
for the the extra piece uh ending I
agree and would you consider the move
King H1 at all
no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's why not no I understand it's
probably a good move but you you you do
you do invite the trade of Rooks no way
but then why not just go
I was gonna
the king H1 so King H1 is good okay I
was just wondering I was looking at ways
for Alice to go wrong so say for
instance you went H3 is that a misstep
because the queen can come after all the
trailer works the queen can check on
any fires on E5 although the universe
asking each one and then Queen to G1
yeah
so check but Age Two is a possibility
another move I would be attracted to if
I was in Alice's shoes would be the move
Knight E3 because I'm just thinking as
soon as I get my knight to the king side
then my slightly vulnerable King no more
and of course what if I go H6 I do have
the Bobby Fischer teaches chess back
right
you go age six yes and then I go Knight
F1 not F1 and say yeah yeah
Knight F1 never get mated yeah but
that's the rhyme doesn't work it doesn't
work
now Knight f8 don't get mate Knight F1
I'm gonna I'm gonna coin one you don't
get you don't have fun
I like it
queen of course okay that's that's the
most natural move in the position I
think everybody likes the move Queen F2
very very much indeed
and
and Irene does
time on the club she is not there at the
board
and she has uh
two minutes to get back and make a move
if she wants to continue the game so all
right let's keep going Queen takes F2
I really didn't like the fact that he
went back on the first rank uh
you wanted me to go up just go up yeah
why not and Rook takes B2
you want to go A3 and Rook B3 Rook C3
yeah okay I hear you just stay active
you know I I don't want to yeah Queen
takes F2 okay so we're going straight
into this end game
and you wanted to be active I just like
an active King yes I'm a big fan of an
active King
big fan of the active King yeah
and we'll see if Alice agrees with you
if this game finishes soon yes and uh it
will probably begin at 5 30 but if this
game drags on
then the men will always start at 5 30
so that's a guaranteed okay
uh
and again just to re-emphasize that the
women do get a 30-minute break between
uh the time this game is completed and
the time that their tiebreaker begins uh
at least a 30 minute break would either
of you be attracted to the double Pawn
sacrifice
of this position in this position you
got two warthogs
on the seventh rank usually that's good
enough I mean but you're giving up the
pawns oh that's surely good enough for
sure okay yeah would you yeah go for
this absolutely
you'd give up the pawns but I probably
wouldn't it wouldn't be my first it
wouldn't be your first I think my first
Institute would be actually just
rounding up the apron
yes throw in the towel right but would
you do it with Knight C3 then or would
you be doing it with A3 in Rook check C3
I like the rookie sorry A3 and then
lifting up you've got to keep your
pieces active gotcha yeah yeah and that
defends everything
and Arena just looking around like get
me out of here why why did I do this why
did I find my taxi for a while she's
gonna have to adjust soon because she
Bound for the playoffs
and she's been there before Oh yeah and
she has to dig deep and she won uh in
the Champions bracket uh when number one
net number two number one prevailed in
the playoffs
yes and a good trick that I like to use
myself and I'm sure Irina will probably
think about this type of tangents as
well is look I was half a second away
from being sent to the elimination
bracket it could have been worse right
you're still in this match you still
have two lives left so there's still you
know the half glass full right right in
her situation right I think this is what
her coach probably will tell her to
think about and I think we will be
seeing a refreshed Arena comeback for
the playoffs yeah sometimes when you do
have a setback
you tend to lose objectivity you know
you had to set back you had a loss and
woe was me the end of the world and
everything else and then somebody says
to you but you know you have two lives
and you know all you have to do is win
one of these matches and you're the
champion well you know what that sounds
so bad it really isn't so bad
and up to this moment exactly take check
out the Champions bracket you know Arena
was absolutely dominant and she still as
yasa says had two lives so if she wins
the playoff against Alice today today
then she is the champion once more
absolutely so uh
yeah she she will uh she'll put this one
behind her and just say okay I had that
horrible horrible oversight it happens
to everybody
um I think it was
wasn't it David brodstein who blunt or
maybe it was Tegan Petrosian who
blundered the queen it was just like
night Retreats
attacks the queen Knight takes the queen
he was famous for blundering quite a bit
Yeah and uh pal benko a great player
many times in the candidates it's very
famous for blundering Rooks
you know like somehow you know he had
this blind spot where Rooks were
concerned uh what you're seeing is the
analysis position what we have right now
is the current position King F3 uh will
lead to our analysis position after Rook
takes B2 and our panel is debating the
merits of A3 versus
you know the Tactical the tactician
inside of me uh has suggested uh Rook
takes Rook A2 I can't believe I made the
suggestion of sacrificing a couple of
Pawns to get what is
self-evidently a checkmating pattern on
the board you're just ready to go
and
rips narrow Terror let's see what Alice
Lee will choose in this position once
again I'm a proponent of keeping things
safe
yeah just this moment again I I suspect
both players might have missed Knight E3
because it's not you know when you just
played the move rookie eight you know
you're taking control of the square E3
but if you do see Knight E3 and you do
see well I'll just put the Knight on F1
you you won't even get a pawn
uh you kind of go for it Queen F2 I
think is the move that you you you you
play you naturally want to trade Queens
I have to say I love the fact that Alice
is taking her time yes yes because you
know psychologically Arena just wants to
play exactly you can get out of there
she doesn't know this is carefully
considering every single option that we
see the king king lift up to F3 keep the
king safe I like him I I mentioned that
too that I think that Alice's
unbelievable her playing style is
unbelievably mature for her age and
that's just not fair I mean I want those
young kids to be tactical Wizards I
hated that they can play strategically
positionally good end games
I mean she plays like a veteran I agree
I agree y'all know her coach definitely
must be very proud
well for Alice this will be like
breaking into the arena because she
knows that when we talk about women's
chess in the United States Arena crush
is the player she has to beat and she's
never beaten her up until this moment so
it's sort of like
I can do it you start believing in
yourself right but I you know Alice is
so strong that I think her Ambitions are
not just limited to that I think you
know she's looking at The Grandmaster
title she's also
looking at other things as well for now
you know it's a really nice when you
take a step-by-step approach small baby
steps and I think her focus is on
getting the international Master title
she's got two Norms already
Christian when you were interviewing
Alice in the Champions bracket she said
something like she was taking Advanced
calculus as a 13 year old and we were
saying that next summer she'll be
running for governor
pretty extraordinary step by step
her future is so bright you know you
need sunglasses here definitely aiming
high-end don't forget she has her own
show on it and Alice's Palace yeah this
is Pond Palace yeah right and rookie one
okay oh by the way I really like this
move you do I'll explain you in just a
second why so he's a very tactical move
and I like how she switches from a
strategical play to Tactical play Rook
to E1 you play Rook to d8 right clear
now I go rookie too
rookie too yeah that's it just to uh uh
you cannot touch my Rook takes A2 do not
think about capturing this Knight and
allowing the back rank mate either by
rookie eight or Rook C8 and that's all
her friends I have to play A3
A3 yes but now I can just move my knight
back right Knight E3 for example yep
you
could also play Rook C2 and say I of
Rook C3 that's also yeah that's that's a
move as well
the one thing you don't want to do and
that's pretty uh unfortunate is this one
although
no you're not under this you you but no
you're not still winning it's that is
the one thing you don't want to do uh
and this is the current position Rook d8
on the board uh sorry this is the
current position no actually you can get
away with that Paula can you I think so
how Okay rookie too as you predicted A3
okay now obviously I would never play of
course but you know just just for I was
going to say Rick D1 H6 right yeah and
then you do you have Knight F6
um so if you move the king if you move
the king to f8 then you go King up the
ball exactly so I will go F5
and I think this uh solves both of my
problems because if you go Knight F6 I
go King F7 I don't take on F6 or Knight
to E7 yes yes
yeah okay so Alice don't be tempted to
out calculate your opponents right
playing Rook takes B2 right and it
doesn't work well we we suggested A3 but
yeah also we could
Brook C3
but A3 is like the the last gasp hope
here and Arena how much time does she
have no Irina said okay I'll drop back
with
The Rook
but now I just love that uh
consolidating move of Knight E3 keep the
king nicely protected
so you no 97.
or is she going what is is she going for
Brook C8 perhaps yeah that's
she's going for it yeah it's Roxy it is
her plan you're right exchange as
trade as fast as possible exchange the
pieces trade the pieces
well it's true uh trading Rooks is uh
definitely uh
yeah you know for thousands of years
they've they've used the old formula
went ahead
trade and trade some more so Rook takes
C8 by the way uh Knight takes C8 that's
been the golden Square for the night it
does come with a bit of a threat rookie
a check followed by Knight D6 Jack and
trade more Rooks
so Rook C8 on the board
and I don't know how long how much
longer Arena will want to see this
position but you know I think maybe
maybe it works yeah for them for the
moment and just I myself would have
played the move Knight E3 and then
I I feel like a rook trade is absolutely
impossible
for arena to ever stop but okay 97 I
mean not bad not bad Rook to C8
and Irina down to
just over a minute and a half
not the not the worst of her problems in
fact she's has such little time she's
trying to find a way to Corral that
night stranded on C8 the problem is you
just simply don't have enough pieces to
do so 96 97 Knight A7 is a way out as
well lots of squares yeah no I mean it's
also black doesn't have the time to kind
of go F5 to deprive the night of a good
circuit because as you pointed out
rookie eight going to end the game and
we see the Rooks come off yep
Rook C8 Rook Knight takes C8
and by the way if you do allow my knight
to jump to D6
I'm starting to look at your king as
well right that's a checkmating thread
if you go Rook D5 try to stop me from
going there then I can go Knight B6 now
and you will have some difficulties
defending that pawn on A4 so true that
and you also need to defend the D7
Square because you do get checkmated
still if you go something like Rook A5
or something remember the story told to
me by Boris Coco it's playing in uh one
of the Soviet qualifiers
as we have a rook check on the board one
of the Soviet qualifiers and his
opponent was was blind
and the opponent had one of the Braille
sets you know where the where the 32
squares are up and 32 squares are low
and you know he could feel the pieces
and then he would make the move on his
Braille set and then the system Arbiter
would make an impress his clock and
inform him the blind player of how much
time he had
so Boris had pawns on F2 G2 and H2 and a
king on G1 and his opponent the same
three versus three and Boris had a rook
and his opponent had a bishop
so Boris went Rook on F1 over to the
queen side so he's threatening the
expected lift
and the the blind hand was feeling the
pieces
that suddenly the blind hand went like
this as Boris had put his Rook on pre to
the bishop
his opponent took the rook and Boris had
to ask himself after the game who was
blind
the excited hands on the Braille set for
us and he'll never forget that I mean
temporary uh blind spot Rook Shack King
E4 G6
uh defending the Rook
I guess I like the way she plays I like
the way Alice plays she keeps her pieces
active night even the Kings yeah
and actually I really like this idea of
Knight to B6 and even moving your king
towards uh
the uh A4 Pawn Knight to D6 you
mentioned also ideas of rookie eight no
more because the pawn is on G6
well it's not just about the I was
thinking rookie a check and rookie seven
in order like for example let's say you
go here
and
the idea of checking
Rook F1 okay look at one we're most
likely going to see but it doesn't
really matter right now okay no I would
be I'd be heading towards this guy I was
gonna say there's only one move that
Alice can't play but
one move you definitely well you don't
want to play Knight takes porn
by death in King D3 but of course you
can't yeah King King D3 but then of
course after root D1 Rick D2 right the
skewer is not a killer and it's not a
killer check the king D4 I love that
move
you're just making a b line and you're
saying you're extra Pawn on the king
side is going nowhere I've I'm ready to
to to keep that and maybe on a good day
maybe that's like the best chance you
know just to get F5 F5 yeah and then
yeah
so that uh you yeah but yes
get something like this
that's okay I'll take
you know it's bad news when this is the
best chance that uh you might have okay
because uh I'll probably look to trade
off everything on the king side
uh hang on yes there's night today you
don't even have the liberty of doing
this okay I have to go
I have to go G4
she's going for it
well you into it that Irena was going to
do something like that it's either that
or resignation I know and resignation
has a lot to be said for it right now I
mean this is really this is bad I mean
she's just uh playing out the hand but
uh
yeah there's nothing going on here
wow but for arena
this
I mean it's disturbing she's she's
played such a nice tournament and this
like feels like she just got a donut you
know on the classical games and she had
been playing so well
uh sour feelings for her right for two
years she hasn't had a loss in this even
two years right undefeated in the
classical portion at least that's what I
meant yes in two years but right now
she's yeah
um feeling the bitter taste of defeat
for the first time like B6 on the agenda
exactly
with my king my knight is far more agile
let me uh put uh
the horse to work King G7 and I like
what you said Knight B2 Knight B6 go
after that a pawn
wow
I don't need to be asked twice
the one thing the one thing that you
don't do though is you don't get scared
Knight takes you just pause for a moment
and realize that Rook F4 check is on the
agenda so you do something you move your
king I'm not sure
but you just don't play Knight takes A4
In This Moment here I it looked like
Alice was actually reaching for a king
maybe I think she's making C3 King C3
okay I like them oh so good
so many good moves here good positions
give you good choices yes
exactly
and
15 minutes and Ticking down for Alice
plenty of time to enjoy the position
truly
Knight to B2 try to Corral that pawn
could be an interesting alternative
King D3 I like that move just waiting
for the moment and
seeing what you're going to do
for example if you go King F6 now I
attack it from B6 I attack the pawn on
A4 from B6 and you no longer have Rook
F4 because exactly you're just
sidestepping
um I like this move yes okay
and F4 by Arena from Arena's point of
view she's sitting there okay I've got
this lousy position I'm completely lost
but maybe
what could I do if I could trade off
some King side Pawns
I mean limited material and all that
good stuff you would love to trade off
the queen side pawns that is for sure
unfortunately you cannot do that no
but do you think she's looking to play a
move like well let's put a kibosh on F3
right now with the move King E4 and now
finally I can start looking at that A4
point now I like Knight D2 and Knight F3
so the only thing Aruna can do is
actually pay G5 right and then I take
all the
The Rook moves to any old place you
don't want to go towards the checkmate
with King F5 and maybe I do I was
thinking that I will uh head head for
that you want to do it slowly yeah very
very quickly
so slowly but yes
uh King E4 on the board
30 seconds
less than 30 seconds left for Irena
so we expect them both G5 King F6 okay
okay F6
that's what about Knight to subscribe to
right now id2 sure has my attention 92
and the problem is if you do go Rook to
A1 I can just simply take on F4 and the
polo NATO is uh taboo because Knight to
E4 comes with a check a discovery check
that is picks up the rook and that's
game over I think we're seeing the final
moments of this classical portion of
this incredible match and just to say
once again that for arena this would be
her first loss in any American Cup in
the classical
uh games yes and for that matter first
loss in many games as you didn't lose no
she hasn't lost a tiny playoffs games
either she's Come Close against Alice
Rook to H1 okay King
H3
you mean H3 or Knight F3 Knight F3 we're
going to see G5 come for sure swiftly oh
but Knight to F3 G5 Rook to E1 yes let's
trade Rooks oh that's a nice thing that
would be
the cruelest Yes she'll do it I mean
absolutely she played Rook C8 you know a
while back the trailer wait one second
is
very bad yeah
there's no more counter playoffs
after G5 Rook to E1
that's a very good time to give it a
rest
visualizing this position without the
king if the king is not in the middle of
the board right here we go yeah so say
the white King was like down on the
second row she will play
that came very very quickly uh Alice
says she did not even blink if I can
deny you there you go and that's it we
have two playoff bound
uh Grand finals I know I I unbelievable
stuff honestly defeating Arena Crush in
a must-win situation to take it to
playoffs and Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura they will be playing in just
over half an hour I was for sure
thinking we were going to be calling
Blitz tomorrow I'm no longer that
confident that we won't be seeing these
Grand finalists as as both games are
playoff bound
so because of the length of the game of
the classical game with the ladies I
understand that they were they're going
to be staggered they'll they'll start
their match about half hour after the
open players do so we expect the open to
begin
treat some music
foreign
[Music]
Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the World Chess Hall of Fame sponsors a
fantastic music series with a short
break in the American cup action we are
happy to show a performance music
director at the hall of fame Brian Owens
performs The Crush records Collective
enjoy the concert and we'll resume our
coverage of the American Cup shortly
good evening everyone
oh that was whack
thank you welcome to the World Chess
Hall of Fame my name is Brian Owens I am
the music director and artists and
residence here and so glad to have you
all here for this very special night I
want to give a quick shout out to Heil
sound who provides most all of our mics
Silverback who is doing all of our audio
and video tonight and rink Rex and
Jeannie singfield who are our
Proprietors who make sure that all this
cool stuff happens so let's give
everybody a really big hand because yeah
because without them it would simply not
be possible
right on time we were clapping for you
so
um the music Series has been going
really amazing this year we've had some
some really great performances if you
were here last uh performance we did a
commission piece that was done by Adam
Manis and it was absolutely awesome uh
we've had Mastermind this year we've had
Anita Jackson this year so um it's been
a really great season I can't wait to
let you guys know what's coming up next
year but that will have to wait because
tonight
I am here to introduce a very very very
special group of talented young creators
if anybody knows me you know that my
heart is for young people
um my heart is even more so for young
creatives and just making sure that they
can be good people
above all else but can reach their full
potentials as creatives and so when I
came to the world to Hall of Fame one of
the passions that I shared with joy was
that I want to make sure that whatever
I'm involved with I can also involve the
young creatives that I work with and joy
was like cool
we can do that
um and so tonight is just the beginning
of what we call the next move initiative
which you'll be hearing a lot more about
later
um tonight we're featuring Crush records
Collective it's a group of young artists
who support each other encourage each
other who do business with each other
um and I think are going to make a huge
impact not just on this community and
regionally but around the world with
their art and their craft so
I'm going to introduce the first person
and then they're going to introduce
everybody else and I'm going to sit down
so it's appropriate that this is the
first person because literally this is
the first person who I was introduced to
um we went to church together he ended
up living with my wife and I for a while
he became like he's like our adopted son
and then I found out he was very
talented as a writer and as a poet and
as a spoken word artist and as a hip-hop
artist and so ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome to the stage Christopher
Daniel and the band
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
more time for celebration time for
meditation time to hold on in this time
you need replacing time to slow down
cause you figuring out the basics time
to speed up and that's due to my lack of
patience allow me to be specific like
Atomic commitment all the time I spend
hurting making me go ballistic memories
are horrific wanting to be encouraged
but I am my biggest critic
hard times is very concerning wishing
for hours and minutes that you wasn't a
burden praying to heal the next day but
leave the other one hurting I know
people that want to talk but I'm keeping
it urgent they say Thomas money and
money is time I'm just speaking my mind
you spending time so you can keep more
no matter how much money you got it's
always something you gotta pay for hey
when did the time go visit my friends at
kinfo carrying all these pounds got my
back car didn't like limbo doubting me
as an insult problems I never asked for
wanting to be a hero and slice the game
like I'm Kimbo continue to give you
reason
[Music]
to get suited up for a better case I
handle it anyway
that's how I handle it anyway
[Music]
but look I question what it mean to get
tested
there were insecurities that just
manifesting
trapped inside of a shelter running away
like Welter trying to hit a pan so I
being better than standing walk down the
street looking from west to east call
the police I murdered my own piece but I
kept it discreet because money people
should be illegal imma manage what's
next like I'm William Regal I struggle
with less I struggle with all my trust
and I struggle with pain understand this
game I'm feeling running yeah
but now I'm feeling for play
feeling like nothing that's left
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up y'all
hey this is a good looking crowd here
beautiful people oh oh no problem no
problem
so
that song was called time
uh
actually buy a show of hands
how many of y'all have ever felt like
um
like you went through a whole day and
you just feel like all the time you
spent in that day you wasted like you
just felt like what did I just do
yeah I also have had those moments too
and that's basically what that song was
about you know
I know as humans a lot of times we'll
think like
dang like we'll think about the time
that was wasted the time that we wish
that we could get back
and then sometimes also the time that
we're not sure that we will have
and that's why that song specifically is
really important to me also my best
friend that passed away Daniel uh he
passed away about almost a year ago do
you like that song a lot too uh
so yeah it holds a special place in my
heart
but this next song
is called cold promise is not about the
weather
but
um this song
actually I don't know what it's about uh
it was like I was writing it and it was
like
dang uh I'm all over the place with this
one but it's still a good song You Know
well let's get it
foreign
[Music]
and
I'm blessings why am I stressing after
the past I started accepting I had to go
and get depressed and I'm reaching my
life you call me a rep
[Music]
ly
I need you right now for what's gone I'm
losing myself so what's going on where
you at please pick up the phone it's
about time I tell you what's wrong cause
I met a whole other zone I'm hitting
these shots inside of my home in the
month they sound like a gun my
heart going cold I need you right now
before it's gone I'm losing myself so
what's going on where you at please pick
up the phone it's about time I take
what's wrong cause I'm in a heart of the
zone I'm hearing these shots inside of
my own in the mud they sound like a gone
[Music]
I think thank God so much uh for this
next song I would like to bring the
lovely sunka win up to the stage
[Applause]
uh this next song is called Mind Games
it's one of those songs that's like
about so
I know a lot of people that struggle
with mental health
and depression anxiety all those things
especially me
uh and this song is about how a lot of
times
like those struggles
for those people who feel like like they
are hearing these voices in their head
that's telling them they can't do
anything that they suck and all that
stuff it's about how like you struggle
with that and how you could potentially
overcome that
and
I'm ready are you ready so I'm ready you
ready
[Music]
lost in the world that deserves
got me falling falling falling falling
falling falling falling
another story about some damage getting
hard to manage another cut that was
neglected from being protected stains on
the ground making more than Mama's frown
had another soul that forgot that they
had a crown I fall backwards and Philly
capture what a disaster a broken mind is
way worse than a physical fraction go
through obstacles higher than any Raptor
cancel my laughter leaving me stuck with
her thinking I never matter every door
to my confidence shatter moving a
greater passion people go from security
to Heaven check my Snapchat see the
future like Raven Baxter and amateur to
who I am I know I'm pretty mad
[Music]
due to the hate that would hurt me I'm
standing lonely lost in the world that
deserves
[Music]
falling falling
Rocky likes Sylvester Stallone you see
my heart yes turning the stone people
left there alone I gotta help a life for
the day that I'm gone now I'm investing
my stay with a heavy Led Zeppelin dang
it's scary to never know it's coming but
dealing with Temptations like I'm David
Ruffin tears dripping my mind skipping I
feel the listen locked in this world 22
must have been my sentence like in this
world I'm 22 it hurts to say that
sentence locked in the screw of 22 it
hurts to say that sentence
[Music]
falling falling
falling falling falling falling falling
[Music]
falling
I'm falling
[Music]
[Applause]
thank y'all so much
[Music]
[Applause]
I got taller
oh hello
hi everyone
give it up for Chris
I love Chris
he really keeps me grounded um he's one
of my best friends again with everyone
in this room pretty much
um so if you don't know Crush orchids
Collective is a collective of musicians
that are singer-songwriters creatives
video people
silly people we're just really good
friends that like to make music and
luckily we get to make this as a
business so
I have some singles for you or some
Originals for you is that okay is that
okay
um this song
it's a song I wrote It's actually my
friend dominicus
I took it from her
but we wrote it together so I'll play a
little bit for you
[Music]
I got so much time cause lately
time and time again
[Music]
say you want me
say you want me to
[Music]
I got too much time
lately I've been thinking I need to find
a way to make it stop
you had other plans and I can never
understand gave you everything and you
lost your shot
[Music]
off your chest
say you love me and you want me to
want me
foreign
[Music]
we are back and it's playoff Galore at
the championship final of the American
Cup the grand finals were not supposed
to give us this but we've got it we've
got playoffs we have playoffs and what a
journey our players have been on first
up I think it is Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so I've seen him at the board
already he carries at the board he's uh
he's roaring and here are the playoffs
and here you can see it is Wesley so
with the white pieces against Hikaru
Nakamura the two will be playing a
two-game rapid match of 10 seconds 10
seconds that will be fast 10 minutes
plus five second increments
and they'll play two games black and
white as will Alice Lee also with the
white pieces matches uh up against Arena
Crush now because of the length of their
game they're going to be staggered in by
about 30 minutes so they won't start
right away with the open section
they will not but
and it's all rapid as here what happens
in case of a 1-1 result after these two
well they carry on playing Yasser
because they move on to two game Blitz
playoff with a Time control of a very
fast three minutes plus two second
increment and if the scores are still
tied after all these games then we are
going to go for the Armageddon love them
or hate them they are the best in my
opinion five minutes for white four
minutes for black the black gets to our
odds and there is a two second increment
from move 61. now remember in the first
playoffs between Hikaru and Wesley the
game the match was not decided in the
two rapid games it actually came down to
the Blitz Games right where uh Hikaru
won the Champions bracket there
there what do you reckon on this playoff
scenario
um well I have to say Wesley must be
happy with what happened in that initial
match between these two players because
not with the result of course but with
the way they play those uh games
especially in the rapid portion Wesley
was having the upper hand with the white
pieces was really really close to
winning that game with the white pieces
then he bounced back he lost by the way
that game from a winning position but
then he bounced back with the black
pieces so he can put the pressure early
on on Hikaru Nakamura when he has more
time on his clock as soon as we ended up
in the blitz portion it felt like Hikaru
just took off he was just so dominant
started off with a crucial Victory with
the black pieces in the Kalashnikov it
didn't even feel like Wesley touched the
ball and touched the pieces in that game
I remember he was having a very
lackluster let's say performance in that
Blitz portion definitely once the game's
speed up eres Hikaru Nakamura who has
the upper hand but in Rapid portion I
have to say I've been impressed in this
particular event with Wesley saw it
looks like Hikaru at the board just
huffing and puffing thinking about all
kinds of openings that Wesley might try
D4 nimzo Indian with Queen C2
was played earlier
will Wesley play E4 like he did in the
previous matchup right so it very much
feels like Groundhog Day for Hikaru but
I've never seen him arrive so early at
the board you know players do this to
get in the zone to kind of get that
familiarity with pieces Bobby Fischer
was notoriously Elite for his games his
clock would often be uh starting Gary
Kasparov also notoriously late Gary did
it because the there was five minutes
for photographers to take their pictures
and oftentimes the photographers were
getting into like scrums to get you know
photos next to Gary if you will and Gary
didn't like that so he tended to want to
arrive six minutes late to avoid the
photographers but in this particular
case nothing like that is happening it's
just uh Hikaru trying to get a sense of
the plane all playing venue and he
certainly is ready for what's come
because he had so many hours he had
three hours with his second Chris
Littlejohn to discuss understand what
went wrong in their first match how he
can improve on his opening play I have
to say the strategy definitely worked
the strategy of playing the Sicilian
taking more risks as we have uh very
short time controls uh nevertheless he
needs to play more precise in the
opening because we've seen Wesley take a
full advantage and create imbalances and
create a better situation for himself
early on with the white pieces let's
just remind the players a reminder of
yours pardon me how the players got here
yes and take care and Nakamura did
headline the event and he made his way
all the way to the top of the Champions
bracket netting a ten thousand dollar
bonus and sending Wesley so down to the
elimination bracket Hikaru Nakamura is
still on two lives that's right and uh
Wesley he did get relegated but he made
his way to the Grand Final by beating
Lavon aronian Wesley is on his last life
if he does not win this match that's it
Hikaru Nakamura is the American Cup
champion and E4 and when we looked at
those uh matches match ups
uh prior to the start we saw that uh In
classical chess the very very even and
Rapid chest they have a very very even
um ELO rating if you will but in Blitz
chess
then it's 19. Wesley's number 19 in the
world Hikaru is number two just behind
Magnus so wait no more Colossians from
Hikaru no he he played E5 uh instantly
by the way
um I'm thinking this is the format that
Wesley's got to a score I I don't like
his chances if they get into that three
and two so I mean Wesley with the white
pieces to start this playoff I think
he's
he really needs uh to put the pressure
on and hope to score Ken is a win yes
yeah yes no absolutely I tend to agree
with you it just feels like in Blitz
Hikaru is Untouchable yeah it's
encouraging encouraging F4 right but I
just wanted to mention that there is a
game in the database with Fabiana
carrona playing against Wesley so with
the black pieces I love that game ended
in a Droid
for white with
with Bishop E6
age they're still following that same
game and Fabiano play the move King to
H1 yes that's what I what I was
expecting King H1 prepping F4
Knight to C4 Novelty four nice wrinkled
by Wesley by the way the best move
according to the engines inviting Bishop
takes C4 no no no no uh Hikaru says no
way I'm not going to give up the the two
Bishops but by giving up this diagonal I
I don't have to play the tempo losing
King H1 to get an F4 I can get it in
right away which is exactly what Wesley
has done now he takes on C4 to see Caro
and it doesn't look like Hikaru has been
surprised at all because he just keeps
listening on the moves at tempo right
exactly wow
um well whoa whoa whoa
C5 C5 okay what if I take that okay
and then it takes I just had this alert
ski I've got E6 yeah and
Bishop G6 on my agenda okay then I have
to be a bit more careful
after C5 I will go along Castle okay
well well hang on a second yeah yeah
exactly so suddenly suddenly I got Jovi
getting excited too uh possible but
you're not threatening anything right
because Bishop C5
um
I think I am threatening something with
Bishop F5 check
okay can I go Knight D5 yep yep yes you
can 95 oh no 95 I cannot but go should I
explain to you to Christian what he
might have missed
um just saying uh what we have in In
This Moment let me just uh
refresh I am I saw the move C5 with this
idea of Bishop to G6 going E5 E6 and I
suddenly got excited that C5 might be a
Break by the way if I don't play C5
I'm a little bit afraid the Knight will
take up residence on E5 and black will
be perfect maybe that's actually what's
going to happen after C5
97 anyway well well I do have Rook D1 in
that case right
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah and
then I was just thinking like but okay I
think the king definitely has to go to
safety okay
muscles makes a lot of sense doesn't it
can I uh just Retreat I should what's
wrong with Bishop C5 chuck oh nothing no
no absolutely and then and then after
King age one you just put your knight on
D5 oh well
um then I was gonna go King okay
that's the problem I don't like the fact
that I don't have this Escape Route with
King B8 King 8.
Knight C7 are you are you going to give
well um yeah then I'm gonna I'm
vulnerable I get invulnerable yeah I
gotta Focus everything everything yeah
okay this is going horribly wrong no
no this is not good so maybe C5 is an
opportunity what do you think uh
Christian it certainly has to well he
doesn't have to but it's a good idea to
play it for sure yeah it's an
opportunity but after C5 it seems like
Castle is indeed the best move and just
the lines that we were discussing white
has a slight Edge but it's not decisive
by any means oh no no I wasn't thinking
it was either I was just afraid that if
black gets Knight D7 95 it's a way to
continue the pressure it's a way to
continue the pressure not allow Knight
to D7 Knight to E5 because strategically
if that happens for a black that's going
to be very good news and don't allow
that play C5 get rid of the double pawns
and play with the two Bishops and uh a
some initiative as well on the e-file
due to the fact that you have the light
Square Bishop on the board it's looking
good for white after C5 I I find Wesley
to be in a remarkably good place they're
just really really really good by the
way the C1 was played moments he tends
to mismanage his clock he goes into
these like two minute things during a
10-minute game or a minute and a half
thing during a five minute game and uh
he ends up being seriously behind in
Hikaru a key moment when he could use
the extra 20 or 30 seconds he did not
play C5 and I find that a surprise he
did play the move Rook ad1 instead
Hikaru said wow okay if you're not
playing uh to attack me out castle and
I'll bring my knight to E5 maybe you can
still do C5 anyhow
because you can always follow that up
with E5
well but I'm not getting the tempo
against the bishop that I was getting
last time so if I if I do it now it's
not as
is Punchy you do have a knight D5 was
yeah I don't feel I get this I'm not
getting as much bang for my Pawn as I
want it uh could he be thinking of B4 C5
B5
I mean you have to do something like
that because the kings are on opposite
sides of the board and it's a slow eight
King H1 was played Rook to E8 it just
feels like Wesley is playing a bit slow
right
Rook a a t e a could he be thinking or
he wants his this is way too slow Bishop
GG three days fe1 was played Rook fe1
and uh bear in mind that the best Wesley
can do in this match is to win it and
take it to playoffs tomorrow right
whereas Hikaru just has to win this yeah
and uh that's it he is the champion
exactly
exactly by the way right now Wesley has
five minutes and 30 seconds against nine
minutes Hikaru almost doubles him on the
clock right now it's not looking good
from a practical perspective Wesley saw
right now is in a pickle and to be
honest what I would do as Wesley I would
take the Practical approach try to pull
the brakes
pull the brakes find the simplification
find draw
really I still I feel like five minutes
in a 10 minute game I mean that's such a
good huge Advantage I want to play with
the two Bishops uh you know there is a
backward Pawn on the board I do like if
you go Knight D7 I do have these ideas
of Queen G3 and Bishop takes D6 the old
double attack
and I do have in the back of my mind B4
B5 yeah it's not that easy for black to
break open the King Size Direct action
wow strikes first okay Mission drops
back to G3 and now you know you have a
new Target right the work can move to F1
or maybe the other root can lift up I
definitely agree with that
um also by the way Bishop G3 good move
Maybe
something that might be D7 Knight D7 in
any case I was going to reset my pieces
uh to focus on the F7 Pawn with moves
like Queen H5 and Rook F1
um just saying that Bishop G3 yes that's
like kind of the automatic Blitz move a
little consideration and I can
understand why you might want to play
like for example if I play Bishop E3
Jovi and you go Knight here and I go
something like I don't know just
throwing it out there C5 and I'm trying
to mix it up right by weakening your
king you can see why the bishop might
have a role on the G1 diagonal Bishop G3
for you know having said Peter you have
to say Paul okay okay he's going for
something but
uh I like it I do I like it yeah I'm a
big fan of this because like age H4 the
queen can you know okay caveman it's
coffee house yes that's why I like it
that's my style uh coffee house okay uh
wow
um coffee house but he's putting once
again pressure on his opponent's clock
he's playing practical chess the
Kalashnikov Sicilian is sort of coffee
house as well right I mean it's not seen
at the elite level just play it and put
pressure on your opponent's clock how do
you defend against H4 do you go H3
yourself well why is it a threat let's
say B4 move page coming forward
yes bishop and then I would be tempted
to go one step forward in F5 whoa well I
was expect I was hoping you would play
G4 so I would play like Queen E3 with
the intention of course a bishop takes
H4
ah he didn't play that he he's he said
one of the best ways to avoid a pawn
storm is to get out of the way of the
pawns anticipating that H4 and G4 would
come with Tempo Wesley played his Queen
to F5 and that makes perfect sense right
it does make perfect sense
um
but okay Hikaru thank you thank you so
he has a choice he can go to Knight D7
Knight to E
yes at heart we're all chicken uh we we
want a solid and he's played H4 and whoa
now this is really Kalashnikov this is
starting to see some Knight G3 ideas wow
well wait a minute I've got C5 as a
possibility I really like attacking this
Pawn on F7 and guess what that Knight G3
possibility
Wesley said let me sidestep that King G1
inviting Bishop B6 by the way uh denying
white the two Bishops
makes a lot of sense I like it
I really like this move Knight H5 King
G1 I'm not sure about King G1
I'm feeling like Hikaru is taking over
I'm not gonna lie to you guys yeah yeah
it feels like a few missed time moves
has given an early initiative I want to
say to Black right I also quite like the
move F6
just
just an F4 okay one question can you get
Ultra aggressive
and try to go for some D5 lines
what D5 and setup
the walking into a Tempo yes
okay so you want to say you would go I
would love for you to take with the
d-pawn yeah because now I'm not sure how
you defend your king side
yeah Queen H3
is uh certainly no joy I will uh none of
that
um
crispr the Arbiter and get you wanted
and scanned I mean it's fair commentary
you know something quite a few years ago
this was when Hikaru had his um
reputation of being an extremely
attacking player yes he's kind of toned
that down since there was like this just
personality web page and I you know I
answered some questions some questions
and it came you are Hikaru Nakamura the
Barbarian
nice uh B4 by the way I I would have
probably played B4 without the move King
G1 because I would not want to have
faced Bishop C5 Bishop
um uh B6 because I'd have C5 we do have
Knight f4 on the board
before and A4 Rook A8 and A4 A4 is on
the board okay uh
I want to play A5 and A6 let's go sorry
what what am I saying what I'm sensing
is that the queen doesn't have too many
squares somehow
attack but it's on a light Square so the
only thing you can really attack it with
is the Knight he played Queen F7 give me
the pawn
okay is it time see Bishop
it is not time Bishop to be three I
thought it was time to undouble the
pawns with C5 and now Wesley's speeding
up his play a little bit well he has to
but how about Queen H5 now with the idea
of H3 and Invasion on the light squares
clock times once again six minutes to
three minutes three minutes 28 seconds
Queen H5 Invasion on the light squares
why not good I think white has to go
like rugby two kind of ideas
defense yeah yeah
um
okay if I'm in white shoes and I'm
aspiring to play C5 I'm kind of happy
that the queen goes away because at the
moment the queen is pinning the pawn
Queen H5 Rook D2 to defend the light
squares that makes sense
and perhaps ideas of H3 still in the
position after that
let's take it one move by move okay can
we do that sure the queen H5 Rook D2 H3
G3
now I can get Ultra aggressive and try
to go Queen F3 the problem is you're not
even going to look at that light you're
going to go Rook F1 or Rook F2 right
just drive you right out of uh Dodge and
that's great fun maybe not Rook F1
because I have Knight E2
sorry not Rook F1 because oh but you
have Bishop D1 okay so he has paid
Rook A8 E8 sorry let me just refresh my
board I apologize everybody only be a
temporary
and immediately Wesley Wesley had this
a4a5 conception from a long distance
away he's still looking at ideas of A6
as well as B5
and prying open the queen side now you
were saying
that the queen doesn't have that many
squares so if we could get in C5 and
rookie E5 would be uh I think he's going
for that
oh by the way now I see Bishop E3
followed by Queen F2 remember when I was
saying we could make this battery
create a few weaknesses over on the king
side pardon me over on black oh
he did something okay but the rookers
may be coming to E5 Bishop D4 sorry
about the repetition Knight E6 are we
going to see a repetition in this early
middle game
I will be so excuse me this was the
position right yes could he have played
C5 Knight takes D4
Bishop take sorry take on F5 you take on
the eight correct
I want an exchange you did yes and my
next turn is to take here as well so uh
maybe Wesley when he played the move
Bishop E3 and Basics
realized that Knight E6 walked into C5
and didn't give him a second opportunity
to play it
Rook to D2 King to A8
now any sort of battery on the long
diagonal with the queen in front is
going to be met by Bishop to B8 Bishop
A2 sets C5 sets the stage for B5 as well
great move
Queen E7 sidestepping
uh the discovery
is it time C5
and of course once again remind
everybody we're going to be playing the
colors reverse regardless of the result
as uh somebody gets a chance for Revenge
Bishop B why is Wesley hesitating
playing the move C5 well he doesn't want
to
want to diagnose especially with a clock
situation so why not just improve the
position maybe put the bishop on D1 come
out come out to
because he had played Bishop A8 last
turn it seems like he's lost a little
bit of the thread maybe both players
realizing the position
doesn't allow for favorable opening of
the position right it's interesting how
they're now putting their pieces on the
protected squares right
protect your pieces at all times defend
yourself
I'm not a big fan of this Rook on E1
I think I would put the Rook on F on F1
he didn't Bishop to B8
waiting for these uh moves uh for some
time uh B5 C5 break open the queen side
for crying out loud maybe world time and
by the way time Wesley is now up on time
remarkable you don't see that where a
three-minute Advantage just dissipated
uh Hikaru down to his last two minutes
and 40 seconds definitely not enjoying
this situation on the board Bishop B6
inviting a capture on C6 this bishop
will find
I quite like trading off the Bishops and
then off the trading of the b b take C6
and then C5 but remember all trades or
you're at a market trade on your terms
uh Jovi uh take on C6 and play and if
you wanted if you wanna capture undouble
the fancy Play Bishop A4 he didn't take
on A6 he didn't take on C6 he's keeping
the tension was that a good move I like
it you like it I mean The Rook has to
defend the C6 points or you have to
consider a takes B5 which would open up
more lines would come with a massive
warning right do not open the more I
look at the position the more I like it
for Wesley well he's got happy moves
doesn't he Bishop takes D4 a double
undoubling
oh Black's King is really getting pried
open now Hikaru is looking for some
counter chances on the C file and here
we go takes takes but C2 is covered
which means we can go Rook to B1 to B6
like a
true Barbarian yeah a true Barbarian
thank you
by the way does G3 work at any point
just to get my queen involved in the
play well he's perfectly one fast but I
agree with you
I'm thinking this bishop is coming to
the long diagonal like a magnet oh
but a big it feels like like no
seriously guys it feels very very
comfortable rushing right now right Rook
B6 I mean you have everything you want
as white and black doesn't have an
attack
he's had that night on F4 for 20 moves
hasn't done anything with it right the
knight's not going to win the game alone
and one minute 50 and Wesley two minutes
and 30 seconds Wesley could be striking
here Rook B6 and Rook A6 that's a deadly
threat I I told you guys Wesley
outplayed him outplayed Hikaru in both
the rapid matches in their first match I
I agree with you both but don't right
off Hikaru
it's one of the world's best
truly never and he has played the move
Rook B6 inviting Bishop C6 check putting
that Bishop on that diagonal now I like
your G3 very much in order to release
the queen and Rook the Beast and Rook B6
wow how he didn't play Bishop C6 is a
mystery to me because he could have put
his Rook on he could have gone Bishop C6
and Rook B6 both
okay well he does have a ideas Queenie
oh no not nice
is the trend reversing guys because
you're gonna take my A6 Pawn but
well maybe you're not even going to take
my AC spot
I just don't want to blunder my Rook so
let's go Queen B7
that's the well Queen B7 invites
D5 and Bishop C6 that's unpleasant whoa
we're gonna see it later
D5 looks boss he's perhaps looking at
something but 25 and Bishop C6 is just
overwhelming it looks great for for
white right now come on are you going to
sacrifice the exchange with Rook to C8
but that must be losing
absolutely because A6 will be hanging
Queen takes A6 so D5 and Bishop C6 I
think myself he missed D5 D5 C6 but
he won that's not the right
he missed that's hard to believe
D5 and Bishop C6 was just
overwhelming exactly overwhelming at
that point but not not that this is
terrible
[Music]
what rookie eight Bishop F3 is on G4
I'm trying to get to your king as well
that's also an indication that you're
trying to get to my king as well H3 on
the board well I gotta play G3 I don't
want to see you can play Bishop F3
if you want to make that transfer but
somehow other I mean it feels like
Bishop F3 doesn't threaten anything
because of e after E5 you've got D5 I
don't want you were prying open my king
I think I would have played G3 he played
it uh instantly later well Hikaru less
than 45 seconds on the clock
by the way B2 was a it was a winning
threat if the Knight had just dropped
back so Knight G2 rookie
Hikaru barely hanging on but guess what
he's going on he's hanging on King F2 in
order to
not bear the consequences of Rook C1 one
minute then 30 seconds for Wesley 45
seconds for Hikaru King 12 I'm worried
about Rook 2 C6
I'm coming to take that pawn
that I'm thinking I can put my Bishop I
I've been dreaming of putting my Bishop
on the long diagonal so Bishop back to
B3 Rook to C6 Bishop to D5 oh if you
start with Bishop B3 then it looks good
for you I think yes okay yeah but is
there any kind of check
try it out it should be three Rook C1
King F2 King F2
don't see it myself it's so difficult
Bishop B3 is on the board guys
this is the most consequent move that's
the money move right there for Wesley
and eyeballing that opportunity see the
problem with Rook C6 Bishop to B3 Queen
takes B6 is you're opening up the B file
against your own King and he would go
Queen to A1 defending the pawn on D4
threatening Rook to B2 and still 20
seconds
he throws in a check will he just move
was that a spike check that he threw out
there and the clock 10 seconds
um Rook to B1 okay okay okay
so first of all there is this nasty move
Queen A2 five Queen takes B6 more
directly he played it what what
is he doing tonight
holy smokes that actually traps tonight
and did you say that Hikaru he did not
spelled that but Wesley caught it
immediately I thought Wesley was playing
for a mating attack
that wait a minute what was that he
wants to go night after F4 Bishop H
nobody believes you Bishop because
there's a past Pawn in the position E5
about the white ah why did he start with
F5 because he needed the bishop Off The
Square to GA diagonal yes
okay Knight to F4 but how easy is this I
do have that a pawn which is very strong
as well
why didn't he play E5 I don't know right
therefore you have to take and then take
on G5 okay no King to G2
take on G5 or play F5
I don't know this is going to go down
the wire no okay take on G5 pawns
together stronger yeah we'll play F5
yeah and you've got an H Pawn that you
just put your Rook behind Rook to H2 H5
and just push
[Music]
the problem is is that the Rook is going
to get behind the age Pawn exactly H5
and you got to use your a pawn as a
decoy but I think White's King are you
okay to do that 40 seconds uh now I
don't think you're in time to do that
H6 keep going
pushing baby how Rook G2 or H6 H6
this should be winning Rook to G2
Rook G7 H6 H7 you win everything
Rook G2 wins everything
why is he taking his time he plays okay
did he calculated precisely King to E6
or to E7 well can he go towards the
but can you create a decoy like for
instance well Rook H6 Rook H6 I think is
the eye oh H5 but now I go A5 no A5 you
take and you have Rook a seven right you
cannot do that right but isn't the plan
very simple you step up with the King
you create a central Plus Pawn I think
you go rookie I think he should have
just started with Rook H6 actually and
then gone King E3 King D3 keep the a
pawn under control with the King and oh
D5 why this is good enough guys
just what's wrong with taking the A6
Pawn
absolutely very good question
take the A6 Pawn that wins the game on
the spot and he defines it he does it
that wins the game on the spot and
handshake where's this Earth takes the
first rapid game in the playoffs wow
wow Christian we saw a lot of swings in
that game and it wasn't from the opening
no I have to say it was a really good
game by uh Wesley he wow for so long in
the opening he got the worst position
but after that he blitzed out those
moves B for a for A5 he just knew the
plan and Hikaru couldn't find the right
Solution on the king side
Wesley knew what he's doing on the queen
side managed to do and take the process
to its finality by opening up the
position on the queen side Hikaru did
not manage to do that and unfortunately
for him lost because of that reason I
have to say and I've said it at the
beginning of the match as well Wesley
seems to be anchored better into this
time format 10 plus 5. let's see what
happens when Hikaru has the white pieces
in the next game yeah because again in
the first playoff which which Hikaru did
win he won it in the blitz but in the
Rapids he was shaky uh right he won with
the black pieces
uh when uh when he was losing it's not
been in a must-win situation as either
so okay they're off the ladies uh pickup
uh their play as for those of you are
joining us late Alice One On Demand
and this exact same opening and it looks
like Alice has gone and checked her
theories because she's now developed the
knights before she captured on D5 and
that left
yes keeping the tension is Alice and A7
A6 kind of in now you take and look at
the big difference
uh imagine you get to play for example
uh
a minority attack in the game previous
A5 had been played so you got uh Arena
having to play the move A6
rookie one
not a fan of this move I don't like it
but then Arena has put her Knight six
and my general understanding is once a
piece is in front of its own pawns you
start trying to destabilize that piece
so for instance you attack the B7 point
I see in this particular case I think
the move Rook C1 uh castles I'm always
going to play so let's get the castles
and I'm not sure where the Rook belongs
maybe it goes to B1 maybe goes to C1
maybe he goes to E1 the castles I know I
need
so the difference here Arena couldn't in
the first game she got to play Bishop F5
maybe in this game she has to go Bishop
G4
to H5 to G6 together Bishop into the
game she I feel like she's made a
concession though with this Knight being
on C6 I'm always very optimistic because
White's plan is relatively simple simple
sorry you want to tether the Knight to
that particular Square so for instance
you double the bricks on the c-line and
then once you've tethered the Knight
then you start destabilizing his
protection
now because Alice didn't include h2h3
this move Bishop G4 is annoying unless
you're going to play Knight E2 and just
invite Bishop takes F3 you could go 92
to G3 inviting uh the Double pawns
Knight E1
not a fan not a fan Christian no I I
agree I mean where is that night going
you want to go to D3 most likely you're
anticipating potentially Bishop H5
Bishop G6 we exchange those Bishops then
I jump with the Knight of D3 and C5 and
in the meantime the open section
do you guys want to begin yeah let's
begin and they are off and running
wow Wesley taking his very solid
approach
with the Queen's Gambit decline
it's very excuse me the names
I'm gonna need Wesley sorry Alice and
Arena game
I'm gonna need the link to follow this
game so we're gonna have to stay with
Christian if we want to see this game
well we see it right now on
the bird's eye view the bishop on D6
just adjust it slightly you see I see
both players kind of adjusting their
opponents moves a little bit interesting
that Wesley has uh actually bought a
novelty to the table this last move a2a3
never been played before
you mean Hikaru yes
of course all right
playing with the white pieces
this is the no this is the first time in
the whole event that Hikaru has to win
on demand yes exactly
and also it's the first time in which
Wesley has been ahead in their direct
encounters he had a great chance in
their first match first rapid game right
did not take it second time he had that
chance took it okay this move C7 C5 okay
I think a lot of people would be playing
Bishop B7 and Knight E4 in keeping C5 in
reserve the move C5 to my mind when I
play C5 I really really want to follow
it up with C5 C4
followed by A6 and B5 to clamp down the
queen side C5 Rook through C1
and I'm just how do we want to continue
this do we go C4 or do we maintain the
tension as is and play Bishop b797
develop the PCS I'm going for C4 I don't
want to play the uh the hanging Pawn
structure it might be going for it yeah
yes I'm playing A6 right it's always a
very pleasant Pawn structure I have
I mean you might
you might on the king side or in the
center but if you survive then you've
got some beautiful long-term prospects
exactly the end games are nice and again
uh because this Pawn is on A3
if you know you go A6 and B5 it makes it
very hard for white to play B3
and uh
do the Alice game I need I I'm gonna
need a link if I have to call up the the
Wesley yeah
analysis yeah it's quite an interesting
moment in the Alice against Arena crash
okay because she's just uh pushed
forward with the F Pawn and
I'm gonna try to trap the light Square
Bishop getting ready to meet Bishop G6
with F5 right and if you give me one
more move I'm going to go H3 H3 G4 and
try to trap the bishop with F5 right
okay but because easier said than that
yes I was about to say because this
Knight is on E1 does it give me ideas of
Knight G4 and Knight takes E3 uh
possibilities you can try
you can certainly try
Knight to G4
I also have read this extra option of
going either Knight to C2 or Bishop to
E2 well well okay let me show you my
trick if you play Knight G4 Knight C2
yes I wanted to go Bishop to G6 and
thanks to the fact that my oh
you don't get to trap my my my Bishop so
that was my whole trick good point but
Bishop E2 why not
okay I'll go back
see I'm worried I'm genuinely worried
that I'm gonna Ponder my piece so I want
to trade it off
don't tell anybody
but uh that that that's and she did play
1999 yes she spied uh the same tactic I
like it no I mean this is definitely the
right approach and if you grovel please
with night to day one
okay
but
inspired gravel
yeah no the reason though the reason I
wanted Knight D1 is because then after
Knight F6 I could just go Knight f
2 Knight to F2 yeah okay okay
it is a very it's Fisher random on the
first rank there uh Knight G4 Knight C2
on the board were expecting Bishop G6
Arena spotted it right away she said you
can't play F5 you can't trap my Bishop
I'm a happy I'm a happy lady that you
can't trap my Bishop I think we should
go back to the elimination game right
now
with Wesley yes okay so once again
Hikaru must win situation for the first
time in this competition C4 Bishop C
Bishop G for H3 Queen A4
wow inviting Bishop takes F3 yes
but trying to stop the Avalanche of uh
pawns on the queen side A7 A6 and B6 B5
is what we were talking about before the
move Bishop G4 was S8
I like this move I like this move you're
gonna take that okay I'll take it okay
now of course I can trade Queens but I'm
kind of thinking
this this guy well
okay just no wait what about Quincy
that's fine King G2 I'm not afraid you
know I I I actually want you want a
queen of 6 97. I want Rook E6 and I want
Knight E4 all right E4 let's get the
glasses oh perfect thank you
that was that was exactly that I was
gonna go Queen H3 yeah Queen H4 that's
okay that's okay you don't have enough I
don't trust you you don't you you fight
my Jedi Mind your Jedi tricks don't work
Bishop takes Bishop takes G6
overcome my
my Magnetic Personality
um okay uh he did not capture on F3 yet
he's certainly thinking about it
um can we fall back on the old A6 B5
routine you're still a few moves away
from that yes because my you you you're
your will capture I get that part but uh
eventually I'm going to complete my
development and I'll get the tempo
uh B5
crickets
nobody wants to play uh White's uh
position here all right you have an idea
I understand it what if I try to get my
idea into play as well which I'm not 100
sure what is D7 by the way I like that
move 97. I do too and development is
good what about Queen C6 this is the
question
no
very quickly Knight H4 oh I was this was
the one that worried me I suppose Queen
C7 was Wesley's intent but is Wesley
down to his last four minutes yes yes he
is four minutes and 30 seconds against
nine minutes right now once again a
dominating performance on the clock on
the clock by Hikaru Nakamura putting a
lot of pressure but uh okay
can I just check nitrogen
IE what's the idea besides taking the
night if I move yeah my idea was to
I was working at Pawn takes night I was
thinking that was and it's in it
very good by the way guys Alice Lee is
better right seriously I just quickly
tab over shift over Bishop G6 what has
happened
that made her better whoa whoa whoa a
lot of things that yes got played uh we
left it here she got rid of the night
but somehow she got left with a stranded
Bishop that was not
whatever
Irina is not feeling
comfortable right now in this position
also you can see it on the clock six
minutes and 30 seconds for Alice five
minutes and dropping foreign I do see
that Arena if it was her turn I would be
playing for night before night D5 yes
I can't say I'm a big fan of what Alice
just played in 1964 I felt like hey
let's keep the tension well if D5 is the
dream Square for the night she's just
dropped her Bishop to D1 in order to
deny that possibility uh and by the way
imagine a bishop land on E6
5 well guess what it's the it's easy to
do
you have to respond Bishop B3 with I was
just about say 95.98
95 and now you can put your Bishop on E6
oh she wants to go to D3 yeah but that
doesn't matter because there's a rook
there's a rook there's a couple of Rooks
yeah yeah but that's Checkmate ends the
game
wow Joey yeah
look at her go you're she's sensing a
rook takes H7 she's gonna have
opportunity okay so she first of all she
sidesteps the momentary Panic that
Knight D3 could induce and she is as you
said looking at Checkmate Checkmate ends
again the problem is the Night Comes to
D5
diagonal or Square
but how do you get well I guess you can
get your queen over there just simply
Queen E2 and Rook takes H7 but that's a
whole is this well wait a minute
Knight D3 I'm I'm skeptical of Rook H4
she's saying I don't care you can try to
pretend like you're going to meet me but
but it is dangerous why not she's got
this crafty G5 tactic
don't miss that don't miss that G5 you
might lose a rook in one move that's
that's a big one H7
so 93 she's laid a cunning trap for
Alice well Alice recognize that the
desirable Queen E2 will be met by G5
that is a very nice so the time
situation is Alice just has a five and a
half minutes whereas Irena crash has uh
four minutes and 20 seconds okay nights
a big moment right here Alice must be
feeling that her Bishop is really really
is she's switching for the room
I don't like this Knight to D3 I feel
the Knight should be in a defensive
formation even though it was a nice G7
G5 instantly C5 and now Queen E2 right
definitely has my attention because
Queen E2 will set up that Rook H7
let's go back for just a second to the
previous game check the last move
that Wesley just played Bishop F3 Bishop
to F3 from H5 what
so after 97 Knight h4a6 so he's getting
in his B5 business Queen C2 94 give me
the Knight on H4 Knight went to F5
Bishop F3 Queen G5 on tap
oh
that move wasn't part of the that is the
middle of the match if it works wow if
it works three that's a visual
especially given the match situation
right because Wesley only needs a draw
right now precisely so let's calculate
if you take on F3 okay Queen you go
Queen to G5 check
I go Knight G3
oh wow what do you take back with I'll
take I I'm not even afraid of Queen H7
so while I was planning to play Bishop
takes
E3 Knight takes G3 is not terrible
either
okay let's go Bishop Bishop takes and
what if I take on e4 now and let's say I
put my Bishop literally anywhere right
King H1 and then you tell me all I need
is a draw so coin H5 so you let me know
oh you're getting your Perpetual aren't
you yeah I surely am yeah
surely very well very well calculated by
Wesley right but
I would be afraid after I saw the move
Bishop F3 that I might be losing
but unfortunately for Hikaru he's in a
must win situation you don't have to
worry about losing you just now you're
right
if they draw we've got playoff with
everything to play for tomorrow are we
going to see two playoffs
quite possibly
exactly I mean those are those people in
the elimination group you know I mean I
don't know don't call them zombies but
they're back from the dead huge comeback
and I'm just looking at ways for Hikaru
to prolong
the game and uh let's just uh jump back
to the ladies because we thought that
Alice was it was no excuse me let me
just refresh my board apologies for
whoa crazy things are going on
everywhere
uh C5 takes takes Queen E2 threatening
Rook H7 and mate H6 stop that Rook
sacrifice Bishop E6 Queen E5 B3
get rid of that Bishop oh
you cannot defend that Bishop anymore
because Bishop C4 was met with me Alice
has got a nice Cheapo right an
Intermezzo Knight takes
Tom our producer will be does it work
though we will be deliriously happy to
know that switching zuk is existing
Knight takes E6 Rook takes E4 that's
what's uh and if you go Queen C5 you
just take take and The Rook only seven
is hanging right
that's what Tom said
and he doesn't even play chess
you go take take and The Rook is hanging
nice crafty defense foreign
I mean the bishop isn't actually running
anywhere is it that's true
the position
uh what's the times well
um Alice just over three and a half
minutes whereas Arena has two minutes
and 40 seconds
and Ticking it is and Ticking I like
your Rook d8 move
but they also have to bear in my life
before
is possible to kick away the night that
is true
that is true and Karo by the way has
found a way to continue the game it has
a little let's jump back over there
after the move Bishop F3
he played he played Knight to G3 Bishop
takes G3 F takes G3 and Bishop to H5
so Wesley didn't decide to continue with
Queen H4 which at first blush looks
pretty enticing instead he captured and
dropped back
yes and G3 is hanging but so is D5 that
is correct
how do we assess well I mean if I'm in
white shoes and I've got to win you
think I takes D5 what else am I supposed
to do H7 is
G3 is temporarily defended because
um the night blocks so Knight takes D5
we go Bishop D6
what G6 Bishop Bishop G6 yes okay
let's put them on your board yes yeah
Knight takes D5 Bishop to G6 I thought
hey you could at least meet that with
Knight to F4 I agree wholeheartedly by
the way I love this idea of ripping upon
and capturing if I take on G3 now Knight
takes G3 take I take
let's just go with the flow oh you want
me to take one no I was like he's done
it
92 E7 wait a minute yes yes yes yes yes
you can't take the Rook yes yes yes I
agree I agree
Bishop E2 this is a bit unexpected well
I like this it defends the pawn it
threatens Bishop D3 as well as the Rook
this is a much stronger move than Bishop
G6
Knight takes D5 Bishop E2 on the board
the clock times again sorry
Hikaru has just over two minutes whereas
Wesley has just under two and a half
minutes you remember when Hikaru had
nine minutes against four yes once again
Wesley catches up on time yes
the bishop E2 really stunned Hikaru
Hikaru did not see this move when he
captured because he
he hasn't responded but he needs to pay
Dash four he needs to control the D3
Square Rook f4 on the board
easily playing itself Bishop to D3 Queen
to D1 understood but then we have moves
like 95 or Knight C5 remember this night
is hanging
on a D5 it's it's loose that's why in
the air Knight C5 is on the board
C5 Bishop to D3
and he Wesley intending to recapture can
we throw in Knight F6 check no that
doesn't make any sense does it
but Wesley dominating simply dominating
at the moment Queen takes D5 he's
looking good he's looking Sharp
like if you have to play Bishop takes D3
he's really looking ask your dark Square
Bishop how it feels
and Bishop E1 an indication that the
bishop doesn't feel very good at all
Knight takes C5 but you know what I take
this Pawn with a queen with the queen
that's what he did and eat the pawn on
E3 as well
you're you're safe because Bishop takes
Bishop is met by Queen E3 yeah Bishop
takes D3 Queen takes E3 check correct
Hikaru is getting frustrated
[Music]
on the cusp of forcing
um
Queen takes E3 on the board
hovering around them one minute Mark wow
only your drawers all it takes to see
these two players tomorrow King H2 on
the board Queen takes D3 Wesley if he
holds his nerves because the position is
completely won
it's just about nerves now Queen G4
he has the time Japan dominating
position
uh Hikari is not happy look at him
he is not happy wrong
but remember what Wesley said yesterday
in his interview Hikaru starts shaking
he said that's when he starts counting
okay Rook d8 bring the bring the bits
into the center
that was the old British School of Chess
I think it's still valid and bring the
bits into the center it's called Bishop
C3 Ryan I mean it's such a sad position
especially when you're in a muscle in
situation truly upon down you have
absolutely no activity that's why that
beautiful queen on D3 look at that
Central Knight only I'm controlling
everything the light squares are just
domination here but I think if we have
Bishop C3 he's done it but the problem
is he took it he only needs a draw he
only needs a draw true that but giving
up that gorgeous night that's okay no
problem that would have tasered me I
would have played like but still there's
a queen H4 B5 no problem B5 of course
I'd love to keep that pawn uh anything
to be said for Rook D2
and he prepets in the air Rook to D2 oh
it's a nice natural
B5 is
Rook f
pardon me this is C3 to F3 defend that
pawn why not
attack the pawn defend the pawn yes
makes sense to me too he's also well
Hikaru is also threatening Rook G4
Rook G4 and asking questions to the
queen okay but I would take care of the
little one first with Rook D7 and after
your Rook G4 which was played I'd move
my queen to E6 hang around the queens of
the king side
and uh Chris Queen Basics Queen to D6
okay Queen to G5 no Rook to F6 whoa
that's okay that's just that's just
temporary that's not an issue why Queen
D2
rookie six but can I go Queen H6 now
probably I will have to play G6 in that
case but I still don't have anything
why didn't he play Queen D2 with the
threat of rookie two that's a good
question he did not he played rookie six
it's on the board it's all about the
nerves right yes guys and Hikaru now
just over 100 seconds Queen H6 or queen
G5 he's got to make some kind of threats
against Wesley's King but G6 just simply
stops everything in his tracks
any offensive
by the white pieces it stopped after G6
and Wesley looking very confident here
by the way I think the game between
Alice Lee and Arena cross is looking
like it's going to end in a draw
looking like a draw did you say Okay
that's going to be a draw uh Queen G5
I'm shocked that Wesley hasn't played G6
like in an instant but he actually spent
like 30 seconds to play G6 remarkable
but he did Rook F4 Rook takes F6 and
Rook takes F6 on the board Wesley upon
up and uh again in Pole Position all he
needs is a draw and he's got a position
that's highly favorable keep your nerves
and you got it young man right
yeah Queen 77 Queen F4
to get out of the PIN
still looking at that pawn on A6
greedily
isn't it time for your
active moves the queen can come down to
E2
I'm looking at C3
looking at C3 B take C3 Queen takes A3
Rook D2 active moves you got it and if
you uh ah if you take on A6 I have Rook
takes G2
and queen B7 that's a nice nice way of
indirectly defending the pawn on A6 and
I think that was when
oh Rook takes G6
and queen takes F2 okay but this is a
queen upon ending this is where 25
centralized the queen where you just go
Queenie five A5 B4 and the three pawns
on the king side don't help only player
that can play for a win right now is
Wesley he doesn't even have to look
after his King because normally you try
to protect the king it's whilst you
advance the pawns exactly and nope the
draw is going to be enough to take
Wesley to playoffs tomorrow let me just
refresh wait a minute
did Queen A5 no
hands are shaking
yeah it is it is nerve-wracking to play
these positions where you absolutely
have to win
or draw
in this case taking on H5 was a very
good move for Wesley he did not see it
Queen to E5 still a very good move as
well
shape six King H7 hide the king
now we've got a couple of checks don't
well B4 something to be said for B4 I
like it and he likes it too yeah he sure
does
and everything's dropping off and look
at Wesley Wesley's ready to recapture
boy was he ever 0.65 oh no Queen to E3
it doesn't matter and then he's gonna go
Queen E4 threatening H1 Perpetual just
take on G5
take on G5 take on G5
no it's a it's a draw right away right
Queen E4 Queen H1 no he can get Queen H1
like you say there's no way to escape
Queen H1 maybe I can start running with
my king maybe I can mate you Queen G2 is
that mate he's gonna try to do it Queen
G2 could be made
okay Queen to B8 but now I can take no
don't they
shaky hands okay Queen F2 right check
and then you can take on B2 yes yeah now
Queen takes B2 Queen F4 okay Hikaru is
trying all the way until the end Queen
wait a minute how do you defend
I have to go crazy eight King G8 H7 okay
I'll take it take and take on F7 C4 as
well oh King G8 H7 King h8
King h8 don't forget about the maid on
H2 that's a great move let's see if
Wesley goes for it he does he does he
these guys are so good even with no time
on the clock
they have the six cents they got it
they're just so special it was like he
got it wow
and he's got at least a perpetual and
probably simply winning I think Wesley
moves on
and uh in the meantime it looks like
yep no Irina is also totally winning
it's a case of Alice getting nervous at
the wrong moment wow and by the way C3
and now Wesley is totally winning yes
because we get to just pick up that pawn
on H7 for free and uh what a match what
a Titanic struggle between these two
players it's this time control it's this
time control that uh Wesley is the most
comfortable in he's played some great
games at this time control and that's it
I think we're going to see a resignation
I just don't see the way
Hikaru can continue this game well queen
queen is it Queen E6 26 might be the
only way in which you mess it up somehow
right
you can't even get mated anymore because
you know you check on f8 and you check
on H6
won her game
big surprise Irina has won her game and
Hikaru Hikaru just left yeah he got up
our congratulations to Wesley as he
extends the match to tomorrow I know and
Wesley making a huge comeback you know
it goes all the way to Championship
Sunday yes and Hikaru is not happy yes
two zero and where did uh when we left
it we kind of it was the game yeah we
had that's Visions Rook takes E4 and
somehow they got into a major peace
ending which transposed into a rook
ending which
Arena outfoxed her opponent with
what this is completely drawn what
holy smokes it's three versus three yeah
no that's why I'm saying obviously got
nervous in the time pressure and made a
mistake
well let's see the end of the Arena game
in slow-mo because we well
there you have it
you put them on the board okay that is
really uh going a little bit further
than we expected
okay so she oh
well she won two Pawns
look at this
how did she win the Pawns
one by one one by one
oh okay so this is how uh this is
actually a very clever skewer
that uh she made this is later now it's
already winning at this point she's got
the game in the bag
Arena the king is cut off and there goes
the the pawn but this is how she won the
epon so this is an easy draw this is a
just a simple draw but this is this is
cute E4 check
and there goes the First Pawn
this is a draw
and oh I'm not so happy about this
capture probably if I were white here I
would have played H3 myself
but uh not happy about this capture and
suddenly we're in a position
uh Vasily Smith Drew this ending but
this is probably one of the hardest
endings to draw
and Irina actually didn't have much of a
problem winning this in a way we go we
saw the rest this is where Alice gave up
so Arena crash
yeah winning with the black pieces which
means in the next games You'll Play
White obviously and she needs his
drawers needs a draw wow
it is uh in the first game that's from
the first game in the playoffs sorry
right it's uh Alice Lee once again she
finds herself in a must win situation
this time with a black piece and this
time with the black piece is not going
to be an easy task but it has been done
before we saw Wesley do it against
Hikari Nakamura right if she manages to
do this Herculean task then we will find
ourselves in another Blitz player yeah
Blitz player yeah that's the three
minutes plus two seconds right and Alice
waiting in the playing Hill
and I I got to tell you after a loss in
the playoff you just feel like it's you
against the world you know I mean it's
very painful it's Alice actually manages
to come back and win this one I will
kind of applaud her no end because how
she lost this game this last game is
Just devastating to lose a completely
drawn of a component yes yeah that feels
really really really harsh and there she
is at the board thinking to herself how
did I do what I just did
now for Wesley so fans
he was very impressive I want to say
that the last two games that we saw
including that move Bishop F3 Christian
look you play that move Bishop F3 you
feel pretty darn good Bishop F3 was just
a masterful
move right we only needing a draw in the
match situation playing the match
situation so skillfully I have to say I
really enjoy that move and that
performance by Wesley so but it's not
unexpected I anticipated this I knew
that he will go for this type of
situations in the 10 plus 5 portion of
this match and he came on with the white
pieces with a single focus and that is
let's make a drawing the classical match
let's take this match to the playoffs
where we can play some raptures
and speaking of playing some rapid chess
here we are we're set up for the second
game and Alice in a must win situation
is black Arena has been and finally in
the whenever we get into these must
situations it seems like everybody goes
for the modern or perk or rat or however
it is you want to look at it those fiend
Shadows playing Bishop takes C3
check and uh her game with begum
and uh now yes comes the crunch time is
Alice going to emulate Naji and said no
instead she decides to lock down the
center I think this is a good choice
Black's plan is relatively simple just
to develop the pieces and at the right
time just to break open the center with
F7 F5 right
and whilst this game is starting up
let's go to Christian who has a very
special guest in the studio Wesley you
came in you said I like your Thai I say
I like your church really really nice
and today you had a clear strategy let's
make a draw don't take any risks in the
classical chess play some rapid and that
ten plus five portion I have to say
you're a master of that I think yeah
well yeah I mean the most important
match was one from like three four days
ago over uh when I was still in the
winners bracket but it is what it is I
mean I wanted to play the classical game
today but there was simply no time to
prepare any good ideas good Novelties
with the opening yeah also
the game yesterday was very taxing
mentally but it felt like from the match
that you just mentioned as being the
most important the first encounter
between you and Hikaru he took some
information from that you understood
that in ten plus five you can outplay
him did you feel like that and was that
part of the strategy no well the
Champions bracket was important because
I didn't realize there was an extra ten
thousand I only found that out yesterday
but uh
yeah I mean you know I just uh as long
as I'm determine as long as there's a
chance I'll try to take my chance and
play my best chess I mean I think Hikaru
is still you know relatively the
favorite in in ten plus five or in Rapid
but uh
as long as I can put up a good fight and
I'm happy with that and guys join the
conversation absolutely well first of
all uh Wesley uh well done I mean you
did what you had to do uh you extended
the match for tomorrow yeah make it work
yeah right thank you very much for that
by the way we were we were talking about
the prize fund there we were thinking
this is such a nice tournament having
you guys play just for the honor of the
event not necessarily for the variety I
mean and the commentators are going to
split the person what about your cash
birth birthday cash funds I I wanted to
ask you about the second game and when
you found the move Bishop F3 uh
Christian if you could bring that
position to the to to to the board and
just share with the viewers your
thoughts at exactly that moment because
we thought the move Bishop F3 was simply
outstanding well I thought
I was fine but maybe bishop G4 was
inaccurate and then I missed Queen A4
I'm not sure what's happening there but
um
yeah when he played when I played the
Knight E4 I already had lots of ideas
with Bishop F3 present like if Knight
takes maybe Rook takes Knight F5
and then here I was already looking at
Bishop F3 or queen G5 but then nice very
nice move yeah but then as he was
thinking after Knight F5 my first
intention was Queen G5
on on the game during the game during
the game right
if you take on now instead of Bishop F2
oh we saw the bush my first launch of
Queen G5 but he's got the move F3 which
is really annoying breaking and this was
still a very nice move Bishop to F3 I
have to say we were all very impressed
yeah I wasn't sure what if it worked or
not but I didn't wanna I didn't want to
wait to slow death and yeah I was
already down the clock so I thought Play
Bishop F2 see
Wesley congratulations big match victory
for you we'll see you tomorrow yeah
thank you oh congratulations again as
the game uh between Arena and Alice is
underway Alice again she's lost with
white so she is in a must-win situation
she's played what we all understand is a
dubious system but uh an attempt to keep
all the pieces on the board so it's a
king's Indian with
C5 and E5 what we call a Czech benoni
and she's played F5 and Arena said I
love this for white I'm the one who's
going to take advantage of the open G
file I haven't castled kingside you have
I'm going to play Rook G1 and I'm going
to play Bishop H6 and in the near future
I'm going to take this pawn and put the
Knight on e4 and quite frankly this is a
dreadful position for black and you're
forced to play the move F4 but now
White's King can happily go to the queen
side and the the open G file means as
play on one goal so for example just to
show you how silly is the position
Advantage white you go King D2 King C2
and then everything goes to the queen to
the king side and read this for choice
certainly looks that way but I mean I
have to say on a practical level I do
think that Alice has her chances because
yes if the king steps to D2 and C2 as
long as Alice can do something
immediately say like with Knight A6
Knight C7 B5 just you know anything to
expose the white king okay
uh you go for it uh one other thing uh
that is very standard for white in these
positions is Sacra it's upon sacrifice
you do go Knight G5 in many cases you do
go 96 you the the bishop you know you
end up taking and white takes you end up
winning the pawn but thanks to the fact
that the D5 square is no longer is
vacated yeah because the pawn is on E6
but Irena has a completely different
approach to this WOW Bishop D2 she
played Queen to E2 she's getting ready
to Long Castle
do we like this we probably do I mean
the position's quite favorable for white
so Arena just played it slowly Bishop D2
Queen E2 and castled okay I wanted to
put my king on C2 she wanted to put her
King on C1 Fair
and Knight went to H4 this says to me
that um Alice did not want to see Rook
G1 and H4 herself so she put the Knight
on the blockading Square H4 but what's
it doing there otherwise you don't
really want to trade it right perhaps
you do perhaps you just want to trade
and try to focus on the queen side after
that say that okay that night was kind
of threatening 95 96 maneuver was
annoying okay 97 Rook G1 these are easy
moves for arena I don't like 97. you're
not a big fan and now she she ended up
having to play Knight takes F3 Queen
takes F3 very very quickly and now it's
all play on one goal I think Arena's got
this she's going to play H4 Bishop F1
and Bishop H3
and that's that's devastating
be careful not to allow any sort of
counter play on The Queen side though
because I will try A6 and B5 and try to
open up the position there right but uh
you once you play A6 and B5 you're never
going to take on C4 because that's just
bad you're never going to play B4 so
I've always felt that those type of
attacks for black get nowhere so it's
time to go H5 H4
but you see the problem is this bishop
yeah
the moment you put the bishop on H3 you
instantly realize it's working and the
pawn on H4 is useful
because it takes away Queen H4 and on a
good day it even acts as a um
so you have to be precise then with your
move order because you should go H4
right here right now
Queen D3 Bishop to G4 I think or perhaps
Queen to H5 Bishop G4 Okay the reason I
I would prefer the pawn on H4 is because
sometimes again the pawn can be used as
a as a
what's the opposite of a blockader
you you you break down the castle with
you you break it down
the guys take these big things and they
crash the door yes they do
what is that thing that crashes the door
it's a big wooden thing that's what it
is that's exactly right
you go H4 H5 and you're battering ram
Queen G2 by the way uh this is
uh now oftentimes this battering ram is
also useful to stop the night from uh
ending up on the G6 Square here I would
be tempted by Bishop H5
why not yeah I mean just that Rook you
know push that Rook to some for Lauren
Square
Irena is feeling it right now well she's
definitely in the group uh times both
players around seven men oh every now
six minutes six minutes versus seven
minutes for Alice close very close
Bishop to H5
7 immediately played it's a nice tickle
now here once again Queen there's five
yeah I was gonna say I preferred Rook C7
G1 next how do you defend against that
well you can go I've got an idea
two Rooks on the seventh so you have to
go B6 and Rook A7
okay yes that makes a lot of sense
I'm keeping the game alive right you
know what the problem I think is yeah
our therapistics I go Queen F6
now I'm threatening root hg7 be careful
I
I that's why I didn't respond
oh excuse me I have a thread guys B6 I
go Bishop F7
Bishop F7 was a very very nasty threat
that's why she defended with Bishop D7
one of the things that I really like
what Irene has done I liked H4 Bishop H3
I love this move F3 because I see this
bishop as making a triumphant return to
the king side Bishop E1 Bishop H4 she's
played Bishop E8
there was something about that move
Queen F6 that just looked Divine but I I
guess it wasn't there
uh Rook G2 Rook H it's so many
wonderful attacking happy moves for wide
in this position Alice Alice is just
holding on grimly for dear life here on
the board of Bishop H4 yes it is
and don't forget Irina is okay with the
draw so if it goes to some sort of an
end game and we started exchanging
pieces I'm okay with that
takes on the board and again Bishop H4
he's extracting Knight G6 no
McQueeney eight Queen E8 white is never
going to be worse now after that well I
wouldn't trade Queens i i i
Jovi's uh yeah Golden Rule don't break
it don't don't trade Queens when
unnecessarily now but I agree with you
Queen takes E8 is Advantage but I was
thinking about the tripling on the G
file yeah why not Queen G4 Rook G2 Rook
G1 and Irina this is something that she
said also when she came for an interview
she said that
the best thing you can do whenever
you're in a must draw or like you you
can win a match with a draw is not to
play for a draw exactly
not to exchange the Queens go for the
mate and this is what she's doing right
now Queen G4 followed by Bishop H4
followed by Bishop F6
and she played Queen where G4 G4 good
term
somewhere Arena's coach is applauding
Her Moves
I'm wondering whether
it's very difficult to do anything even
you've got to do the defending on the
light squares
so maybe it's time for
B6
or B5 B5 let's get active let's go and
okay Rook F7
let's go
I guess you got Knight g69
yeah that is true
why isn't my battering ram on H5
uh okay you're gonna use that for a long
case in that case let's get the
battering ram going
now again the reason that I'm I'm not
even paying any attention to the queen
side is because I don't see the move B5
takes C4 as a threat I mean you've
opened up the B file bit to borrow a
page from your book I can easily cover
B2 but after this H4 I mean can you play
the very risky but you know I feel like
it's really quite critical times H5 yes
it is legal that you're not gonna like
it I'm not gonna no I'm not liking it no
a queen can come you just
make room for by the way I think Rook C7
is on the board
Queen G4 Rook C7 right
huh
and let me just double check this it
sure looks like The Rook is on C7
definitely in G4 Rook C7
I look I mean you got to do something uh
Alice you gotta play actively B5 you may
not have liked it but B5 seemed like a
better chance Rook C7 is it time for the
battering no Rook G2
Purina
and her her brand of strategic chess has
brought her enormous success and she's
she's true to her her style yeah well
now is the time B5
open up there it is oh Lord yeah we kind
of been banging the drums there but
we're gonna see Rook G1 and don't allow
me Queen takes G7 that's a mate
that's a mate
Rick A7
Rook A7 and I will introduce the
battering ram
I'll never forget it anymore ooh king h8
boy that sure is tempting she's tempting
me with this uh
Queen sacrifice really you want to take
no no no no I'm tempted don't do that
don't do that you can go Bishop H she's
okay introducing the ram the ram the
battering ram H5
H5 H6 uh Arenas dream
so if if H5 would you sacrifice your
queen
this does look down the position I think
I would have taken that pawn you know
you might as well be born up right and
the lockdown is kind of oh but Queen A4
no Alice is going to get mated there is
no attack imagine you go Queen takes A2
there is no attack there on the queen
side but okay B3
at least she's trying but B3 B3 B3 is
one way of just a very easy way to get
out of everything well thank you very
much and then just go H5 right and uh
yes you can also just go H5 first by the
way oh B3 uh if you go Queen A3 you
might get your hand caught in the cookie
jar over there uh oops excuse me that
was not my intention I my intention it
jumps back to D7 she's begging for the
queen trade now she's begging for the
queen trade uh
gosh it's such a tempting Queen trade
now suddenly
um but Queen H5
Queen H5 looks really good I'm
threatening Rook takes G7
Queen also H5 isn't that quite good H5
one thing that Alice is doing is putting
some pressure on our irina's clock
okay I'll definitely go with H5
I mean also because Irina
and by the way there's Knight also oh
Queen H5 Arena's sensing that uh the
position offers more
uh than uh just a better ending Queen to
E8
will we see Queen G4 and a kind of a
uh well she can do that I'll probably
draw that way
two and a half minutes for Irina
she gets an extra 10 seconds for sorry
five seconds per move Queen F5
okay again Arena's idea is simple she
wants to go H5 and Bishop H4 and she
could also shut down the queen side
activity with Knight B2 and Knight A4 so
she is nominating but
nerves clock times
Rook F7 it's all about the nerves right
now
Rook F7
Queen to H3 perhaps yeah yeah I like
that move Queen to G4 is also an idea I
quite like Queen G4 and then keep up
with the plan of going H5 Bishop H4
but how do you break through Queen H5
okay
uh a little too and twoing and throwing
here
and again I am seeing I am seeing this
idea of Knight B2 to C to A4 to shut
down things in such positions yes I like
sacrificing the Knight for the two pawns
uh Knight A4 Bishop F2 Knight C5
and uh
Advantage wide
if we see the move Rook B7 do you think
we'll see Queen F5
I think so yeah kind of offering a draw
from a position of strength yeah I think
so
so Alice is nothing better than to
shuffle the pieces right and I'm just
wondering whether there's a threat on
the board whether Alice can just go a A5
A4 and
hope right
for something good to happen rookie
seven Queen F5
could be
a repetition
Queen F5
but you know Alice is not going to
accept that no
to play she has she's forced to play so
Alice oh we take C8 okay Queen takes E8
Rook takes E8 H5 the battering ram is in
place give me one more move page four
followed by Bishop F6 one word six
and I say thank you very much here's the
Checkmate correct that exactly
arena is dreaming of that night went to
and Bishop came to H4 so Arena's got
everything she wants
uh up to this moment and she only needs
a draw so I need to F2
where is that night going is it going to
go to G5
that's Bishop F6 okay
Alice's grimly determined to hang on
Bishop takes F6 followed by H6
battering ram
Bishop takes but uh if he could Bishop
takes the Knight will obviously capture
which has happened and she's reached for
the h-bond but then pulled back as she's
thinking about Knight G4
that still looks
quite tempting there is a beautiful
smothered mate in the position
eight
Alice is fighting her way back into the
game but I don't know that's a big
threat though but Knight G4 she H6 or
Knight G4 originally Arena reached for
h-pond but ig4 is a really nice move
right right because if you go Knight G4
Knight takes H5 I have Knight
h68 and root G8 guess who just caught up
nice Rook D5 okay ideas of Rook F5 and
Knight G4 still abound
I don't think you're reaching for your H
Bond and allowance because you have not
you have rookies she's played Rook G8
and very quickly Arena said I do want to
establish my Pawn on the H6 square but
how is this one actually if you capture
the rook and then just go Knight to G8
then 90 G4 and there's no way that you
will ever ever be able to capture the
spawn and that's probably what she's
striving for so can we try something on
the queen side A4
A5
so Rook G8 on the board sorry H6 is on
the board and Rook f
7 are you allowing me Rook G7 that's
probably what Irina should be thinking
about doing but Rook to G7 I have Knight
H5
doing the D2
okay just
Rook takes G5
and Rook to G8 wait a minute
black has not black has play wait a
minute this is not easy guys if you lose
the H6 Pawn in a night's end game you
might be in trouble
G6 and then you have a knight to
and then you take it and you take on H6
to release your King right that's right
Arena has
blown this I I think she has okay
I'm not 100 sure but maybe Knight H3 is
our only move now she has 30 seconds 24
seconds page three
may keep her in the game but it she's
definitely given Alice well give Alice a
lot of credit because Alice was really
cool we're expecting things she ate
immediately and wait a minute
she must be planning Knight H3
king of seven it doesn't matter I don't
give it up but she could have played
Knight H3 why why develop the king it's
it's a fallen pole pawn and Irina less
than 10 seconds on the clock arena is
losing now it's amazing turn around
as Alice was just so so uh busted just
terrible King takes H4 Knight C7 she's
doing her best I don't need to give you
that pawn and she didn't A5
Knight b598 I'm defending absolutely no
the night the night's on the wrong
circuit the night needed to go
to d8
oh she's and now you have to bring that
no that's too slow now I just bring the
king to G3 and I push my Pawn
hold on I'm gonna try to get my king to
F2 before you get your king to Jesus
what she's doing
and she still has Knight C6 in mind
which is somewhat still in the game I
mean hang on a second if the white king
can park itself on G2 and the Knight
could go to C8
freeze there you go the action yeah
not H5 she had to go with the King on
age I think that's an experience right
there the king had to go to H3 King G2
may have just secured
Arena crush the championship
as now the king side is completely shut
down in Knight C6 and maybe the worm
turns again it might be the case
now at the same time
what if I get the king to F6 you take my
opponent on A5 and I get the king to E7
how do you get your knight out
and if you don't then I get my knight to
G5
push my H Pawn and start collecting your
points well we're thinking that we're
gonna take on A5 we'll put the Knight on
B5 and play A4
enforce an amp is on no we'll we'll take
the pump
that's that's a good way the question is
who's going to be first exactly somehow
it became a race still wow uh salute to
Alice because her opening was horrible
and the position was horrible and she
gainly stayed in yeah she just survived
and I have to say it's like Lazarus
coming back
right it was all over we did we did we
were wrong right but Alice has to find a
way to to break through arenas
and what did she yes 45 seconds
remaining for Alice she needs to find a
way I think Alice
is frustrated that somehow her H Pawn is
now stopped yeah and but one thing she
can do is like you guys have been
mentioning just put you can put the
Knight on G7 move the King around and
you still have an entrance he's going
for it King F6 I think F6
okay do we go King H3 and King H4
no I'm a material girl I'm taking the
pawn not that easy anymore though now
it's now it's crunch time
why with 10 seconds
King D7 you have to play it fast and I
go King H3 King H3 and King H4 I'm not
in time
three against
you cannot get my knight to G5
no no that that that's the juicy Square
for you and There She Goes three
and Arena Crush closing in on her second
American Cup championship title I think
she's okay but hang on a second you have
nice F6
no she went Knight she's seven King is
coming to G5 and that's it you're never
going to do anything but she needed to
put her Knight on episode because then
you have the possibility of going takes
each exactly
okay now basically with this move she's
saying
I recognize
the position to draw
an arena is saying I think it is
but do you have
everything he's not thinking about
winning right now she just wants to make
a draw absolutely let's make a draw
let's finish the match exactly and there
you go
she's doing precisely that
oh and the players are repeating except
Irina said if you don't want to repeat
I'm very happy to go Knight to G8 Knight
to F6 and Knight takes H5
very happy to play Knight G8 here
but is this Knight F5 that's good enough
as well yes let's just trade and take
that pawn off the board
once that Pawn's gone I mean the chances
of losing went
Knight C7 but there's no circuit the
Knight can't get to the White Queen size
in full control right now yes she's got
the game in the bag it's no longer a
question of a draw so she's not going to
win Irena has done it wow
unless a major accident happens and
she's not trying to win it no no she's
not trying to win and here comes the
nights are dancing
irena's gonna claim the draw by
threefold repetition
H6 and that will do it
Alice gamely fought and our
congratulations to Alice for breaking
that mold that she got off the schneid
she never defeated Arena Crush she did
it in classical chess today yes she did
it absolutely she is the American Cup
champion women's section true Bravo
and congratulations to Arena crash who
has thirty thousand dollars richer
thanks to the five thousand dollar bonus
uh incredible stuff what a beautiful
tournament for her just unbelievable
performance and to come back from such a
devastating loss today impressive
impressive
and for the open uh we have a grand
final tomorrow to talk about we do
because Hikaru Nakamura Anna Wesley so
we'll be playing again Hikaru of course
was on two lives we just lost one to
Wesley and now they're gonna play the
elimination time control of 25 minutes
this is what we're expecting for
tomorrow
and if the match is tied after those two
games which is probably likely knowing
these two we're gonna go to The
Accelerated rapid playoff which is 10
minutes plus five second increments two
games of bad time control and if it's
still tied we're gonna see a blitz
playoff and finally to clinch it all if
it's still tied it's gonna be decided by
Armageddon well I mean when I think
about the Lavon versus Harvey we're our
defending Champion probably got knocked
out in the Armageddon this is what arena
was saying if you Alice you should have
played the move King H3 and Alice is
sitting there saying could I have one if
I had done that already how are you
going to dislodge the king from F2
that's what Alice is is asking as well
and arena is just enjoying the moment as
she recognizes this phenomenal Talent
Alice Lee is going to be a fixture yeah
she's going places this is going quickly
and you have to bear in mind she's just
13 years old already two International
Master Norms to her name she's a
runner-up once again in the American Cup
yes and you know so many talents and so
many achievements also University grade
calculus hello hello Arena doing
everything she can to suppress her smile
but she's feeling really really good she
accomplished her goals yeah she did it
again and uh the thing is for arena it
was a struggle today because she started
off with a loss in her classical game
but the fact that she came through will
make this Victory even sweeter than last
year's
and he hears the women's final standings
[Music]
first place it is Grand Master Irina
Crush who walks away with a wonderful
thirty thousand dollars in second place
Alice Lee with eighteen a thousand
dollars
finishes in third place with twelve
thousand dollars
she played some wonderful chess as did
beg him too frankly yes she did and uh
what a fantastic competition I have to
say what I loved about it was that every
single participant came to the board in
a fighting mood they gave it everything
that they had and we had very few
playoffs in the women's section and I
think it was to do with this fighting
Spirit Well that for sure but also the
format just as a commentator it seemed
like there was action everywhere whether
it was in the classical games the rapid
chess the the the playoffs when we had
them and uh Christian uh for for me I
love this format and we got one more day
one more day to go I love it as well uh
yeah and I don't want it to finish right
it just feels like there's still
business to be settled right between
these players especially that match well
the only match that we still have left
the one in the Open Championship between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura and these
guys have been going head to head in
every single encounter they've had every
single game it's a battle for inches on
that chessboard and this is exactly what
we're expecting to see tomorrow as well
just what an incredible match speaking
of business we have some business
between ourselves that we have to settle
let's just take a look at our
predictions
well
trophy going to
going to varusian oh yeah and you two uh
wow I have to say I see you're still in
the game yes yes you're still in the
game uh Jovi you reached into your bag
of tricks and you picked number one and
number one in both sections and well we
were rewarded for our choices in the
ladies but between you and I what's
what's the difference between our
players at this moment in your mind very
little actually yeah I have to say I do
think it is Advantage Wesley you know
he's an incredible chess and his skills
in the rapid format are just fantastic
can you speak for themselves as we saw
today but for tomorrow
we are having one playoff
oh and the players will be playing at a
rapid format two games 25 minutes plus
10 seconds right and me all we also have
as a side events yeah it would be all
kinds of fun going on tomorrow as uh
Blitz a lot of your players in in the
Blitz from Missouri Tigers oh absolutely
yeah the Mizu tigers are coming are
coming to town and they're ready to
fight that's for sure there's fighting
words Christians great because we uh get
ready uh to interview Arena I was once
again uh defending her title and very
successfully at that
she will be setting up with a Christian
and
it was fun it was just so good it was
just so good let's let's hear from Arena
herself over to you Christian Arena
we've analyzed and reanalyzed everything
that was happening on the board uh We've
mentioned your sentiments her sentiments
what are your initial feelings after
this incredible matchup yeah well
it's hard to you know I was in a in a
definitely feeling very bad after that
uh game in the classical time control
where I managed to lose I would say like
Unthinkable position like you can't
really lose that position you have so
many ways to play and I and I uh and I
achieved that so you know then you're
left feeling like you know
it's like how do you lose out of nothing
you know what I mean like it wasn't it
wasn't like even harder for me to play
and so to lose that and you're like okay
well why did this happen you know and
how am I going to come back and then
you're spending the next hour before
your
um a rapid tie break just trying to uh
get back into a normal frame of mind and
it was also a feeling of a trend
shifting from your side to her side
because this was the first game that she
actually defeated you either In
classical or Rapid or Blitz this was a
big shift how did you recover from that
did you call your coach did you go look
over some lines what did you do yeah I
did not look at any chest in between
um in that hour uh there wasn't really
any point it was clear that was not
going to be useful
um I did talk to my coach you know just
generally about you know how to approach
the match and actually the best thing
that we did is we started talking about
the future official random chess
something to do nothing with my game and
we talked about my game obviously but we
moved on to talking about what's the
future of Chess you know what's
happening to classical jazz why are the
games you know again not as interesting
as they could be you know and um how
quickly fisherandom is going to arrive
and all the advantages of that for a
sportsman
so you know believe it or not that was a
very tricky conversation because I think
we understood like that was the point
like talk about something else and
actually once I got done talking about
Fisher random I felt you know a lot
better that's very interesting just
change the topic all together and come
back to the game refreshed guys yeah
join the conversation our
congratulations Arena really really
fantastic stuff one of the things that
really helped us as commentators was the
large number of decisive games that uh
the American Cup produces your thoughts
about the large number of decisive games
yeah well I mean I think the format is
great because they're going to be
decisive games no matter what even if it
starts out kind of slow in the classical
chess
um you're gonna you know make the
players play some decisive games
eventually so I think the format you
know is wonderful
um it's exciting I mean matched uh match
play I think is probably the uh the most
exciting format in chess right you just
like direct matchups and you have
everything classical you know rapid
Blitz and
um you know I love this format then
hopefully I contributed a little bit to
the excitement in the tournament yeah
and Irina did you do any special
preparations for this event
you know nothing too special you know of
course I always want to prepare more
it's always the things like I start
thinking about it you know as soon as I
get my invitation but honestly in my
schedule it's just been so busy that I
mean I I almost never feel like I get to
do what I want you know in advance of
the tournament but I did do something of
course and
in fact you know I started thinking
about Alice you know before I even
played my first match you know back home
um I mean I knew I wasn't going to face
her early on but somehow it was just my
intuition telling me like I could and so
I um I actually did spend some time
thinking about
our potential openings and and some of
that I was able to use it in in our
matches
Arena won a final question what is next
for you you have so many fans around the
world where they can see you next yeah
um well next is going to be very soon
actually guys first of all next you're
probably gonna see me on YouTube I'm
sure I'm gonna do some videos about this
tournament and
um you know some of these key moments
and after that I'm going to be going
very far away long trip to
um the country of Kazakhstan for the
world championship match between Ding
and nepo and I'll be commentating
alongside a very illustrious lineup so
it's going to be such an honor to
comment on the first four games with
vishyanand and then with danil dubov and
uh just a quick question about the
commentary thing and nepper who's your
favorite or who's your pick to win the
event
yeah that's hard to say who's my
favorite between these two players I
mean I think they're both very nice in
general I like all chess players so
unless I'm like you know unless I'm
especially friends with them I will just
kind of it's hard for me to root against
someone you know like I don't know ding
at all personally but I think he's a
very nice guy you know from what I've
seen very nice humble I mean I don't I
know Jan maybe like just marginally
better and he also seems like a nice guy
so I mean I'm rooting for the chess
actually that's the way to answer it
right I'm rooting for the chest to be
exciting
um not too long and exciting wonderful
well have fun and uh our kind regards to
Vichy as well I'm sure you'll enjoy uh
calling the action with vishu once again
Arena you are the champion of the
American Cup well done thank you thank
you and I just wanted to say thank you
to Rex thank you to the St Louis chess
club uh for organizing this tournament
again and um yeah it's wonderful
wonderful event
I'm sure we'll see you next year yes
thank you
[Laughter]
the action was over I did I was
expecting Blitz for our coverage
tomorrow I was wrong I was wrong and
what an unbelievable day of chance it is
uh Christian final thoughts as we wrap
up uh day eight just an incredible day
of Chess and still one more to go that
big clash between Wesley so and Hikaru
Nakamura is coming tomorrow that final
clash and we're going to be here to call
all the action guys it's been fun yes we
will and thank you so much for joining
us tell your friends where you're
hanging out and we'll see you all
tomorrow same time same place goodbye
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited